I'D LIKE TO CALL BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE --
TO TO ORDER --
THIS IS A WAY OF ANNOUNCEMENTS --
ON ISSUES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
HELD OPEN OF WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO
IS WE HAVE A WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT.
WAIT TILL THE END OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S PRESENTATION TO
MAKE THE SAID OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING.
SECTION IF WE'RE ACTUALLY GET
TAKEN ACTION AND I WILL LAST THE
PUBLIC COMMENT DURING THE TIME
TO WIN THE MATTERS PRESENTED --
WITH THAT A LATE WAY FOR MYSELF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
TO COME FORWARD AND WE WILL JUMP
TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY.
IS HERE.
WE HAVE.
ISSUE NUMBER --
SEVEN MORNING.
GOOD MORNING HAPPY.
BRING I GUESS SPRING START
YESTERDAY.
WHEN IS AMIR FOR SURE?
THE MORNING WAS CHAIR --
JARVIS CALLIE PA THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD
TODAY I WILL BE VERY BRIEF
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE OF YOUR YOUR
BIG AGENDA.
I'LL JUST SAY THAT WE HAVE
SEVERAL TECHNICAL ISSUES BEFORE
YOU THAT I KNOW YOU CAN ONLY
VOTE THEM BUT I JUST I JUST
WANTED TO SAY --
THAT THE YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION AND AND FINANCE
AND I I AND ALL OF US TRIED.
TO PUT FOR SOMETHING THAT WOULD
MAKE.
YOUR LIFE EASIER TURN PROCESS
PAPERWORK LITTLE MORE
EFFICIENTLY SO OUR INTENT WAS
PURE BUT I THINK OUR EXECUTION
WAS LACKING.
AND SO AS THE AS STAFF --
FOR NOTED TO MANAGE COLLEGE SIZE
FOR THAT BUT I THINK --
AND I'LL DEFER TO FINANCE WITH
ANY OTHER SPECIFIC QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE ON THAT PROCESS.
BUT IN TERMS OF OUR OUR ONE ITEM
AND I'LL JUST BRIEFLY SAY THAT --
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE SMALL
GRANTS OR IS NOTHING NEW TO YOU
ALL AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
AND IT IS TRULY A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR
FUNDING FOR ANOTHER YEAR.
THERE'S NO CHANGE IN DOLLARS OR
ANYTHING OF THAT NATURE --
THERE ARE OTHER BIG ITEMS ON THE
LIST TRAINING TO SEVERAL OF OUR
BOARDS FARMS IN OFFICES AND
THEY'RE HERE AS WELL BEHIND ME
IN CASE YOU HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT THOSE.
TERMS IS SIX SEVENTEEN I KNOW
THAT I I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
THAT'LL PROBABLY BE A BIGGER
DISCUSSION ITEM.
BUT WE WANT TO CLEAR UP ONE
LITTLE -- WE
THINK THE ONE LITTLE MISS
MISCOMMUNICATION PART ON OUR
OFFER US EXCUSE ME --
TWENTY TWO POSITIONS THAT ARE
WERE ASKING FOR THEY ARE
PERMANENT POSITIONS THERE SO
THEY WERE ESTABLISHED PERMANENT
WHICH IS SEEKING FUNDING FOR
THOSE POSITIONS.
AND THIS IS --
MOVING FORWARD TO IMPLEMENT AND
I'LL JUST.
CUT OFF THERE AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
GOOD GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ROSS BROWN WITH THE LA --
THE BIGGER ISSUE AROUND TO SERVE
THE TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS A B.
C. P. IN THE LEVEL OF
INFORMATION THAT'S PROVIDED I
THINK WE'VE COVERED THAT I THINK
IN SOME PREVIOUS TESTIMONY --
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN VERY
RESPONSIVE TO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS WE HAD ABOUT THE LITTLE
DETAIL ON SOME OF THE PROPOSALS
AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK
WORK WITH THEM ON KIND OF WHAT'S
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF INFORMATION
FOR YOU TO CONDUCT YOUR
OVERSIGHT OVER SOME OF THOSE
REQUESTS --
I DON'T KNOW MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
WOULD LIKE --
TO DISCUSS SB SIX SEVENTEEN
POSITIONS.
RIGHT NOW IT'S SO I CAN.
WHY SINCE WE SPLIT THEM UP AND
SEVEN SEVEN A WE GOT THE WE
OVERVIEW AND WHICH WOULD INCLUDE
IT I'D LIKE TO YOU KNOW IT'S THE
INTENT TO HOLD?
THE OTHER OF VARIOUS TECHNICAL
ISSUES AND GET --
TO AB SIX SEVENTEEN IN GENERAL.
OUR SPECIFICALLY --
THE RECOMMENDATION OR CALLING
SAYS ANY HAVE BODY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON JUST THE VARIOUS
TECHNICAL.
ADJUSTMENTS UNDER ISSUE SEVEN
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS TO HOLD IT
OPEN --
THING NINE WILL TAKE NO ACTION
ON THAT AND THEN NOW GOING. TO
SIX SEVENTEEN WHAT WE START WITH
THE LA --
AND WE'LL GO BACK.
TO SURE YEAH SO.
I THINK WE DON'T HAVE ANY ISSUES
WITH THE YOU KNOW MOST OF THE
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS PROPOSALS
I THINK THE ONE EXCEPTION IS AS
WAS MENTIONED --
THE REQUEST TO EXTEND FUNDING.
FOR TWENTY TWO MISSIONS THAT WAS
PART OF THAT TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT BCP JUST BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND --
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THE
LEGISLAURE APPROVED --
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN WHICH WAS A NEW
PROGRAM FOCUSED ON COMMUNITY
LEVEL AIR POLLUTION MONITORING
AND EMISSION REDUCTIONS IN LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
AS PART OF THAT ACTION --
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED LIMITED
TERM FUNDING FOR TWENTY TWO
POSITIONS IN LIGHT OF THE FACT
THAT THAT WAS A NEW PROGRAM THAT
WAS GETTING UP GOING TO AND THE
ONGOING WORKLOAD WAS UNCERTAIN.
AND IN SOME CASES SORT OF THE
NATURE OF THE WORK --
THAT NEEDED TO BE DONE BY CARB.
MIGHT BE DIFFERENT IN THE
INITIAL YEARS OF THE PROGRAM
RAMPS UP COMPARED TO ONCE IT'S
ON GOING AND DISTRICTS PLAY.
A MORE A ROLE IN KIND OF THAT
CONTINUING MONITORING AN
EMISSION REDUCTION PLANNING
ACTIVITIES.
THE REQUESTS WAS TO EXTEND THIS
FUNDING FOR THOSE TWENTY TWO
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT BCP.
ORIGINALLY THERE WAS NO DETAIL --
PROVIDED FOR THE JUSTIFICATION
FOR THE WORKLOAD THE WORKLOAD
JUSTIFICATION FOR THAT THOSE --
TWENTY TWO POSITIONS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS.
SUBSEQUENTLY WE ASK CARP TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
THEY PROVIDED SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON JUST THAT THE
GENERAL TYPES OF ACTIVITIES THAT
WOULD BE ON GOING THAT THESE.
POSITIONS WOULD SUPPORT.
THERE WAS NOT --
A DETAILED QUANTIFICATION OF THE
WORKLOAD TO JUSTIFY THE
ADDITIONAL TWENTY TWO POSITIONS
BEYOND THE FIFTY POSITIONS AND
SO IN OUR FEBRUARY --
BUDGET ANALYSIS WE RECOMMENDED
THE TWENTY TWO POSITIONS --
DUE TO INSUFFICIENT WORKLOAD
JUSTIFICATION I DO WANT TO NOTE
THAT --
SINCE OUR RECOMMENDATION CAME
OUT IN OUR SAID DORI BUDGET
ANALYSIS THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROVIDED SOME ADDITIONAL
QUANTITATIVE INFORMATION
REGARDING THE ON GOING WORK
THOUGH THEY EXPECT FOR AB SIX
SEVENTEEN TO SUPPORT THE THE
OVERALL SEVENTY TWO POSITIONS
INCLUDING THE TWENTY TWO THAT
ARE THE FOCUS HERE.
WE'RE CONTINUING TO REVIEW THAT
INFORMATION AND IN FACT WE HAVE
A MEETING SCHEDULED WITH CARP TO
KIND OF GO OVER THAT WORKLOAD
INFORMATION MORE DETAIL NEXT
WEEK AND WE'LL UPDATE THE
COMMITTEE.
AS NECESSARY YEAH IN YOUR
RECOMMENDATION AND THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO CHECK
WITHOUT PREJUDICE SO EVERYBODY
IS WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE HERE
FINANCE TO HAVE SOMETHING TO ADD.
JULIANNE MOORE IS A ME WITH
FINANCE.
THANK YOU --
CHAIR WHITE HOUSE KEY WE OKAY --
OR SOFT SPOKE YOUR WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LA --
AND A A RP IN WORKING OUT --
THE JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
WORK IS IMPORTANT.
AND IT THE WORKLOAD IS IS
TREMENDOUS FOR IT AND THEN GIVEN.
THURMOND NOW YESTERDAY MONDAY'S
HEARING.
IT LOOKS LIKE THERE'S JUST AN
INCREASED AMOUNT OF FOCUS ON
THIS.
SO WE WOULD LIKE WE WOULD.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO COMING BACK
LATER IN THE SPRING.
I WHEN HERE FROM THE H. SAID
JUST.
REFRESH EVERYONE'S MEMORY WHEN
WHEN THIS MATTER CAME BEFORE THE
ENVIRONMENT QUALITY COMMITTEE WE
HAD EVERY REGIONAL AIRPORT WAS
OBJECTING BECAUSE OF THE FUNDING
TO ITSELF THE BECAUSE OF THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF FUNDING AND
HISTORICALLY.
THE POLLUTER HAS PAID AND HERE'S
WERE ASKING FOR G. G. R. F.
MONIES TO PAY FOR TO MEASURE THE
POLLUTION WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IS
THAT THE TECHNOLOGY IS AVAILABLE
AND I AM SURE YOU GUYS ARE AWARE
OF THIS.
THAT WE CAN USE EXISTING
STATIONS WITH THE AIR QUALITY
STATIONS AND IN IN A GREAT THAT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION WHETHER
IT'S WARNING ON FIRES WHATEVER
IT IS THAT WE HAVE OF WHAT A LOT
A LITTLE COMPUTERS A LITTLE
STATIONS OUT THERE.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO REINVENT
THE WHEEL SO WE'RE WHILE I WAS.
CHALLENGED WHEN WE WERE HAVING A
HEARING ON SIX SEVENTEEN IN THE
WAY THAT THAT WENT DOWN I'M
SURELY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE WE ARE --
EXPRESSING TO THE PUBLIC THAT
WE'RE DOING THIS WE'RE NIMBLE
AND WE'RE USING THE EXISTING
FACILITIES THAT THE STATES HAVE
AND THE AND NETWORKS FOR
TELEPHONE AND ALL THAT TO PUT
THESE TO MAKE THE MOVE.
THE APPOINTMENT THAT'S ALREADY
ON THE POLLS WORK BETTER BUT
PLACES HERE FROM ANYTHING ELSE
IN THE AGENCY.
WELL I'LL JUST CHECK --
THAT'S THAT'S THAT THOSE ARE
IT'S A VALID POINT AND I KNOW
THAT THEIR BE HAS AN OUTREACH
COMPONENT TO THIS AND THEY'RE
WORKING WITH COMMUNITIES TO
ADDRESS ISSUES JUST AS JUST AS
YOU JUST LAID OUT.
AND OF COURSE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE LA --
AND FINANCING YOUR STAFF TO WORK
THAT OUT SO WE CAN PUT FORTH A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN FOR YOU TO
ACTUALLY SINK YOUR TEETH INTO.
AND ANALYZE GOING FORWARD.
OKAY LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
PLEASE.
CALL THE ROLL.
MY COUNTY HERE DOWNS MCGUIRE.
YOUR MORNING HERE STERN.
OKAY -- THIS
IS THE THE CHAIR WOULD ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO RECHECK BUT BEFORE
KNOWLEDGE I'D LIKE TO OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING ON THIS
MATTER HI THIS IS. EIGHTY SEVEN
A VARIOUS TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS
REGARDING AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN PLEASE COME.
FOR A GOOD MORNING MY CLAIBORNE
I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND I JUST WANTED TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL TO HAVE
FUN THEY ADDITIONAL 22% ARE THE
CURRENT TWENTY TWO POSITIONS FOR
A BE.
SIX ONE SEVEN LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL'S AN ENVIRONMENTAL AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE NONPROFIT BASED
IN FRESNO AND WE HAVE OFFICES IN
BAKERSFIELD.
AND EAST COACHELLA --
AND IN OUR EXPERIENCE OVER THE
LAST A YEAR OR SO A. B. SIX ONE
SEVEN HAS BEEN A CRITICAL AND
NECESSARY TOOL. TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS AND COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENED BY
MULTIPLE SOURCES OF POLLUTION.
CAR MUST PLAY POLITICAL CRITICAL
ROLE IN IMPLEMENTING AND
REGULARLY UPDATING THE STATEWIDE
AIR MONITORING --
PLAN AND STATEWIDE STRATEGY FOR
EMISSIONS REDUCTION IN ADDITION
TO ENSURING COMPLIANCE WITH THE
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
BLUEPRINT.
THEY WILL ALSO HAVE TO ENSURE
TIMELY ACCURATE EMISSIONS DATA
REPORTING TO FULFILL
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE KIDS --
COMMUNITY EMISSIONS INVENTORY.
MOST IMPORTANTLY CARB IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR SELECTING
ADDITIONAL COMMUNITY IS TO BE
PART OF THIS PROGRAM.
AND THIS WILL ALL REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT STAFF TIME AND
RESOURCES --
IN BOTH FRESNO AND COACHELLA
WHERE WERE MOST INVOLVED IN THIS
PROGRAM CAR STAFF SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES.
HAVE BEEN INVALUABLE AND SORELY
NEEDED WE WOULD SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR I
APOLOGIZE I NEGLECTED TO REFER
TO CAR THEY DID ONCE HE IF YOU
ARE A FEW WORDS --
I HAD TO APOLOGIZE FOR
INTERRUPTING PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
PLEASE COVER MIKE.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU --
I'M KAREN MOLLY AUTO AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY ARE PROTECTION AT CARB
AND WE IMPLEMENTED THE OFFICE
HERE TO SO WE COULD HAVE THE CAR
PRESENCE IN IMPLEMENTING THE
PROGRAM --
SO I UST WANTED TO SAY THAT WE
VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ON THE LA --
IN YOU -- IN
PROVIDING THAT ADDITIONAL
DOCUMENTATION ABOUT THE
INTENSIVE WORK THAT'S GOING
FORWARD I'M AS YOU HEARD
GIULIANA MENTIONED WE HAD AN
OVERSIGHT HEARING IN ASSEMBLY
NATURAL RESOURCES ON MONDAY. TO
HEAR FROM US TO HEAR FROM THE
AIR DISTRICTS --
AND VERY IMPORTANTLY THE MEMBERS
FROM THE COMMUNITY STEERING
COMMITTEES WHICH ARE REALLY
SERVING AS PART OF THIS PROGRAM.
AND ONE OF THE KEY MESSAGES THAT
CAME FORWARD AS YOU JUST HEARD
FROM THIS TESTIMONY FROM
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL WAS THE NEED
FOR CARP TO PLAY A STRONG ROLE
IN THE CONTINUED IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE PROGRAM.
I'M ESPECIALLY TO BE A BRIDGE AS
PART OF THAT PROGRAM A BRIDGE --
TO WORK WITH BOTH AIR DISTRICTS
LIMIT THE PROGRAM AS WELL AS A
BRIDGE TO OTHER STATE AGENCIES --
THAT REALLY HAVE A ROLE IN
HELPING TO PROVIDE REDUCTIONS IN
THESE COMMUNITIES --
AND THE TWENTY TWO POSITIONS
THAT YOU'RE CONSIDERING TODAY
ARE ACTUALLY THE ONES THAT ARE
ON THE GROUND WORKING WITH THE
AIR DISTRICTS AND THE
COMMUNITIES TO BE THAT.
BRIDGE FOR THE PROGRAM AND BRING
THE COMMUNITY VOICES AND
PRIORITIES BACK TO CARB SO THAT
WE CAN THEN WORK WITHIN OUR
AGENCY TO IDENTIFY WHAT WE NEED
TO DO.
AND THEN WORK WITH OTHER
AGENCIES TO BRING THEM INTO THIS
PROCESS AS WELL AND THIS IS
REALLY A LONG TERM COMMITMENT.
TO THESE COMMUNITIES WE SET UP
THE PROGRAM SO THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE -- A
FIVE YEAR A MISSION REDUCTION
PLAN AND THEN CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT THAT FOR AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
YEARS -- AND
OUR ROLE IS REALLY A COMMITMENT
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE PROCESS.
SO I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS THE CHECK MY
TOWN WHAT'S.
OPEN IT UP MEMBERS OF THE PANEL
ANY QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE OF
EPA OR CENTER STERN THANK YOU
MISTER JUST VERY BRIEFLY SO
THESE WOULD BE --
FOR POSITIONS IT LOCATED IN
VARIOUS AIR DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
THEY ARE LOCATED BOTH IN
SACRAMENTO AND I'M DOWN IN OUR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OFFICE --
BUT THEY GO TO AND PARTICIPATE
IN EVERY SINGLE COMMUNITY
STEERING COMMITTEE --
pIMPLEMENTING THE WORK IN THESE
INITIAL TEN COMMUNITIES.
DEDICATED SPECIFICALLY TO
PARTICULAR TWENTY TWO
COMMUNITIES THAT YOU'RE FOCUSED
ON OR ARE.
THERE ARE TEN COMMUNITIES
OVERALL --
SO WE HAVE DEDICATED STAFF BOTH
FROM SORT OF A POLICY STRATEGY
PERSPECTIVE AS WELL AS PROVIDING
TECHNICAL SUPPORT. TO EACH OF
THESE COMMUNITIES AND THEN THE
OTHER KEY ELEMENT --
OF THE TWENTY TWO POSITIONS IS A
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT FOR US TO
DEVELOP IMPROVE TECHNICAL TOOLS
TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM.
AND ONE OF THOSE IS A TECHNOLOGY
CLEARING HOUSE SO YOU KNOW AS WE
GET BETTER INFORMATION ABOUT.
WHAT PEOPLE ARE BREATHING WHAT
THE SOURCES ARE IN THE COMMUNITY
IT THEN REALLY GOES TO HOW DO WE
REDUCE THAT POLLUTION IN THE
TECHNOLOGY CLEARING HOUSE?
IS DESIGNED TO BE THAT SOURCE
FOR WHAT ARE THE BEST PRACTICES
IN PLACE TODAY BUT ALSO AS WE
LOOK FORWARD WHAT KINDS OF MORE
ADVANCED ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES ARE COMING ON TO
THE SCENE [inaudible]
SENATE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANNA.
SHE THAT CLARIFICATION AS A
RECENT APPOINTEE TO THE
CARDBOARD I AM LEARNING ABOUT
THE WORK --
PARTICULARLY IN THESE TEN
COMMUNITIES AND IMPART PICKED
BECAUSE OF HIGH --
PUBLIC HEALTH.
CHALLENGES WITH HIGH INCIDENCE
OF ASTHMA IN CHILDREN ETCETERA
SO IT'S IT'S CLEARLY THE RIGHT
PLACE FOR OUR ENERGIES TO BE
DIRECTED IN.
I GUESS MY QUESTION MISTER CHAIR
I APOLOGIZE FOR GETTING HERE A
LITTLE LATE.
I JUST WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
CLARIFICATION FOR ME ON THE
RECOMMENDATION.
OF REJECTING WITHOUT PREJUDICE
HONOR ON ON THIS MATTER --
I JUST NEED THE REASSURANCE THAT
THIS WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
PROSPECT FOR FOR OUR BUDGET --
WIRE HIM BUT IMAGINE THE
AGENCIES GET AS THE SCRUB THIS
AND COME BACK I I CAN'T
GUARANTEE IT BECAUSE I'M NOT
WITH THE AGENCY EITHER FINANCE
BUT I'M.
CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL SEE THIS
AGAIN I JUST RATHER THAN HOLD IT
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT GIVEN
OUR HISTORY.
IN THIS AREA THAT WERE REJECTING
IT WITHOUT PREJUDICE --
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
CLARIFICATION THANK YOU.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CARE
VERY GRATEFUL I JUST HAD A QUICK
HOUSEKEEPING ITEM --
AND I APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS
FLEXIBILITY TODAY WHAT TO LEAVE
AROUND ONE PM FOR THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON FISHERIES AND
AQUACULTURE AND I APOLOGIZE
ABOUT THAT --
AND THEN ON THIS ISSUE AND JUST
WANT TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK ON
CORRESPONDENTS THINK THAT WE ARE
RECEIVING THE BLUE A GRAND JURY --
A LARGE TRIBE.
HUMBOLDT COUNTY.
WHO HAVE BEEN VERY INVOLVED --
WITH -- THE
AGENCY IN WE FOCUSING ON LARGE
POLLUTERS ACROSS THE STATE --
IN FOCUSING ON COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY DEEP
POVERTY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO GET.
ENHANCE DEFINITION AS WELL
SUGGEST.
FOR I MENTION WITHIN LA AS
REPORT I THINK THE WHAT HOW WE
DO THAT.
RESPECT WHERE THE CHAIR --
WANTS TO BE ABLE TO GO ON WHOSE
FOCUS SEEN IS IT GOING TO BE
FROM STATEWIDE LEVEL OR AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL ON EMISSIONS
REPORTING ENHANCE ENFORCEMENT
WITH PEOPLE --
SIX ADDRESS.
IN NO THIS IS IMPORTANT SHOULD
EVERYONE BUT I JUST WANNA ALSO
KNOWLEDGE --
THE TRIBAL CHAIRWOMAN WHO HAS
SUBMITTED A LETTER HERE TODAY
FROM BLUE LAKE.
OBVIOUSLY DEEPLY CONCERNED
ASSERTION CHALLENGES --
WITHIN THEIR REGION AS WELL
[inaudible]
COOLEY NOTED.
CENTER JONES YOU HAVE A MOTION --
TO REJECT THIS MATTER WITHOUT
PREJUDICE.
THERE'S A MOTION --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THIS IS A
MOTION TO REJECT THE ITEM SEVEN
A WITHOUT PREJUDICE.
I CASKEY AYE OWNS.
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HAPPY HUNTING.
OKAY LET'S GO TO OUR VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR CAESAR MOTION THIS IS.
ARE THERE ANY.
ANY ITEMS AT A MEMBER WOULD LIKE
TO WITHDRAW FROM THE VOTE ON THE
COUNTER.
NONE WE ENTERTAIN A MOTION
NUMBER. TWO FOR ISSUES ONE THE
FOUR FIVE AND SIX THERE'S A
MOTION BY SENATOR MINING DE SER
ITEMS ONE FOUR FIVE AND SIX
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I CASKEY HI AND MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
STERN.
AND WE'D ALSO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
RIGHT NOW ON ITEMS ISSUES TWO
AND THREE MOVE BY SENATOR MINING
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I JONES.
PLAN HI MONNING [inaudible]
HI.
OKAY THAT MATTERS APPROVED A
FOUR ONE ARE THOSE MATTERS ARE
APPROVED FOR ONCE LET'S CONTINUE
ON WITH OUR GENDER AND CALL UP A
WE HA.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER.
HOPEFULLY IT'S EIGHT ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT HOT SPOT PROGRAM.
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
THE MORNING OF CHAIRMAN Y.
CASKEY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE --
I'M LAURIN SIZE SIGN OF TO
RESTORE WITH.
OKAY.
OKAY BY LAWRENCE ICE I'M
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT OR A WE HOW AND WITH
ME IS OUR CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
ALAN HIRSCH --
SO -- WE IS
IS IN A CALL HE IN.
SIX SEVENTEEN AND AS THE BILL'S
IMPLEMENTATION HAS PROGRESSED.
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE EMPHASIZED
THE IMPORTANCE OF CONSIDERING
HEALTH IMPACTS IN THE BILL'S
ACTIVITIES.
AND THIS FORMS THE BASIS OF A WE
HAS ROLE IN SIX SEVENTEEN GIVEN
OUR CORE EXPERTISE IN EVALUATING
HEALTH IMPACTS.
OF ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTANTS.
WE'RE REQUESTING FOR PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
AN ANNUAL CONTRACT FOR THREE
YEARS FOR A TOTAL OF NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND OF NINE HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND AND FUNDING
FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND TO SUPPORT CARD.
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS AND IMPACT
TO COMMUNITIES IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIX SEVENTEEN
AND THE REQUESTED --
WE HAVE STAFF AND CONTRACT FUNDS
WILL PROVIDE FIRST EXPERTISE.
IN THE INTERPRETATION OF
POTENTIAL HEALTH EFFECTS THAT
MAY RESULT FROM.
EXPOSURES TO AIR TOXICS OBSERVED
THROUGH AIR QUALITY MONITORING
DATA.
AND THE EVALUATION POTENTIAL
HEALTH BENEFITS FROM REDUCING
THOSE EXPOSURES SO TO PUT IT
SIMPLY WHEN COMMUNITIES ON IN
THE STEERING COMMITTEES ARE
CONSIDERING.
CHEMICALS TO MONITOR AND READ
WHEN I HEAR ABOUT THE HEALTH
IMPACTS AND UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE REDUCTION SAID
AND THE MONITORING THAT'S BEING.
CONSIDERED.
THE SECOND THING IS TO DEVELOP
HEALTH GUIDANCE VALUES NEEDED TO
FULLY ANALYZE HEALTH EFFECTS AND
THE BENEFITS OF REDUCING
EMISSIONS TO THOSE.
POLLUTANTS THESE GUIDANCE VALUES
TYPICALLY IDENTIFY LEVELS OF
AIRBORNE POLLUTANTS THAT DO NOT
POSE SIGNIFICANT HEALTH RISKS.
SO WITH THE MONITORING.
SHOWS LEVELS OF A POLLUTANT
ABOVE THE GUIDANCE LEVEL IT
RAISES QUESTIONS ABOUT HEALTH
RISKS WE HAVE --
GUIDANCE LEVELS FOR MANY
CONTAMINANTS.
WE'RE ANTICIPATING THE NEED FOR
GUIDANCE VALUES FOR MANY MORE.
THE SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM MOVES
FORWARD ERMS OF WHAT MONITORED
AND WHAT'S IDENTIFIED THROUGH
THE MISSIONS INVENTORIES.
AND THE THIRD THING IS FOR THE
DESIGN.
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF TARGETED
BY A MONITORING STUDIES TO TRACK
EXPOSURES IN COMMUNITIES.
SO BY MONITORING PROVIDES LEVEL --
INFORMATION ON WHAT'S IN PEOPLE
CHEMICALS AND IN THAT ARE
MEASURED IN HUMANS AND IT'S SO
IT'S A REAL DIRECT MEASUREMENT
OF EXPOSURE.
AND BIOMONITORING ANSWERS KEY
QUICK KEY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
LEVEL AND EXTENT OF EXPOSURE --
POLLUTION CAN VARY WIDELY ACROSS
A GIVEN AREA.
AND NEIGHBORHOODS THAT HAVE A
LARGE BLUE --
CONTINUOUS ARE LARGE POLLUTANT
SOURCES ARE KIND OF A IN A
SPECIAL CONCERN.
IN BY A MONITORING CAN HELP
IDENTIFY INCREASE LEVELS OF
INDIVIDUALS IN THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS.
SO -- SO THE
TARGET CAN COMPLEMENT.
EXISTING MONITORING.
THE MASS THE QUESTION I KNOW
WHEN WE HAD OUR DEBATE LAST YEAR
WITH LEAD PAINT I COME FROM AN
AREA THAT HAS A LARGE.
INDO AMERICAN POPULATION HAS A
LARGE LATINO POPULATION THEY
MEASURED LEAD CONTAMINATION IN
CHILDREN AND FOUND IN SOME
NEIGHBORHOODS AND EXCEEDINGLY
HIGH AMOUNT OF OF LEAD.
IN IN IN THE THOUGHT --
THIS MUST BE LEAD PAINT.
EXPOSURE OR F. EXIDE EXPOSURE
WHATEVER WHATEVER FOLKS WANT OF
HIM LIVE AN EXCITING AND THEN ON
FURTHER LOOK THOUGH THE
MEASUREMENT WAS THEIR HIGH THEY
FOUND OUT THAT --
WITHIN THE INDO COMMUNITY THURS
CERAMIC PAINTING THAT IS PUT ON
CHILDREN'S I LET'S AND THINGS
LIKE THAT THAT HAS LED IN IT
THEY GIVES THAT.
A KILLER INDIVIDUAL HIGH LEVEL
SAME THING WITH THE THE JEWELRY
WE GET FROM SOUTH OF THE BORDER
THAT THAT HAS A HIGH LET IN IS
THIS BY --
MONITORING WHICH WILL GIVE YOU
THIS PRECISE MEASUREMENT MAKE A
DISTINCTION FOR THE SOURCES
BECAUSE WE'RE AN AIR DISTRICT.
MINOR NOT THAT WE DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE OVERALL HEALTH BUT IS
IT COULD GIVE YOU THAT SORT OF
SPECIFIC INFORMATION SO --
YOU GIVE THE EXAMPLE OF LED OF
COURSE THERE'S MANY.
EXPOSURES TO LEAD MANY DIFFERENT
EXPOSURES TO LEAD SO SOMETIMES
BY A MONITORING ACTUALLY
IDENTIFIES A PROBLEM THAT YOU
NEED TO RESEARCH FURTHER AND
FIND OUT THOSE SOURCES --
BUT THERE ARE OTHER KINDS OF
CHEMICALS WHERE WE HAVE SOME
PRETTY GOOD MARKERS OF AIR
EXPOSURE FOR EXAMPLE DIESEL
EXHAUST SO WE HAVE A STUDY.
IN OAKLAND WHERE WE'RE LOOKING
SEEN COMMUNITIES AND LOOK IN A
PARTICULAR MEASURE OF DIESEL
EXPOSURE OF A CERTAIN COMPOUND A
NITRO PYRENE COMPOUND.
AND WHEN YOU SEE THAT IT'S
REALLY A VERY GOOD MARKER OF
EXPOSURE TO DIESEL.
SO IN CONSIDERING WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BUY A MONETARY YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE KEY CONSIDERATIONS IS.
WHAT CAN WE USE AS INDICATORS OF
HEIGHTENED EXPOSURE THAT WILL
LINK BACK TO THE SOURCE?
OKAY I'M FORMER FINANCE.
WE FOR THIS BEFORE WE'RE GONNA
SAY IT AGAIN WE UNDERSTAND THE
AMBITION OF SIX SEVENTEEN WE
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THAT WAS.
THE EXTENSION OR THE FLEXIBILITY
OF OF GREENHOUSE GAS FUNDS
REALLY DOESN'T KICK IN UNLESS WE
HAVE OPTION FUNDS FROM THE YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL UNDER.
AB THIRTY TWO AND WHILE THE TOO
MANY --
MONITORING IS A GREAT IDEA IT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS WHICH IS THE
NEXUS BETWEEN AB THIRTY TWO A
COINCIDENTALLY WE KNOW THAT IN
THE LAST OPTION MAY WE DID
RECEIVE SOME FUNDS. FOR AT THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE PERIOD TO
THOSE FUNDS ARE APPROPRIATELY
BEING USED FOR A. B. SIXTEEN
THIS IS SOMETHING SHORT OF A
BILLION DOLLARS.
JUST PUTTING DOWN A MARKER
TREATMENT THAT WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT THAT NEXUS BECAUSE AS
WE GET OTHER PROGRAMS IS SORT OF
MIX THINGS UP WE HAVE TO BE SURE
ANY ALEJO.
I'M EXPECTING A REPORT ON THAT
THAT WE DON'T EXCEED THOSE --
THOSE --
LEGAL LIMITATIONS.
LA -- DO YOU
HAVE SOMETHING TO ADD ON THE
ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT SHAMMAR WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
DIDN'T RAISE ISSUES WITH THIS
PARTICULAR --
PROPOSAL --
SAID.
FINANCE ANYTHING THAT.
MOVES THE EERIE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE HEAR AND UNDERSTAND
YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE LEGAL
USE OF THAT TEACHER AFFAN LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
YOUR STAFF AS WE CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP THE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN.
THIS IS THE RECOMMENDATION HOLD
OPEN MEMBERS HAVE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS AND I NUMBER.
EIGHT ALRIGHT LET'S SAID THIS IS
THE ONLY THING WITH A WE HAVE SO
I'LL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING.
THIS IS ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
SUPPORT FOR COMMUNITIES AND AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN TO HOLD OPEN ITEM.
SEEN NOBODY WILL CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH KEEP UP THE GOOD WORK --
CAL RECYCLE THIS IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCE RECYCLING
AND RECOVERY [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
MISTER SMITH FLANK GOOD MORNING
AND WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GIVE US AN
OVERVIEW COULD YOU SORT OF GIVE
US A LITTLE BIT OF AN UPDATE ON
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS --
SPECIFICALLY ON THAT KEPT
RECYCLING CAL RECYCLING PROGRAM
FOR CPAS SPECIFICALLY WE DON'T
HAVE IT'S NOT ON ONE OF THE
ITEMS.
BUT IT JUST GENERALLY HOW ARE WE
DOING WITH A BOTTLE BILL.
THE BOTTOM THE PROFESSOR OF GOOD
MORNING MR MEMBERS --
SCOTT SMITH LINE --
DIRECTOR COVER CYCLING JOINS
MORNING BY OUR CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CAN ROSA --
SO THE BOTTLE BILL YOU WOULD
LIKE A BRIEF UPDATE ON A BOTTLE
BILL SIR --
YOU KNOW I HAD I TOOK AN
INTEREST IN.
CHANGING IT LAST YEAR
LEGISLATIVE FULL WE'VE HAD A
VARIETY OF OF A CONCERN WITH OUR
COLLECTORS AND PEOPLE OUT I THE
FIELD WE'VE PREVIOUS YEARS
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE WE'VE HAD.
TONS OF PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO FIX IT WE WOULD
DO NEEDED MINISTRATION.
WE HAD THREE YEARS OF INTEREST
GROUPS AND COLLABORATIVE
MEETINGS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
BUT NOTHING CAME OUT.
SO WE HAVE NEW GOVERNOR NOW SO I
JUST WANT TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE PROGRAM IN
GENERAL SURE.
BE HAPPY TO DO THAT AND I I
GUESS I'LL START WITH YOU KNOW
THE NOT SO GOOD NEWS AT THE THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM IS NOT ACHIEVING.
ITS 80% --
RECYCLING RATE GOAL THAT IS IN
STATUTES SO THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
PORTENTS TO US --
WE AIM TO ACHIEVE ALL THE THE
GOALS AND AND THE STATUTES THAT
WE IMPLEMENT --
THERE'S A NUMBER OF REASONS FOR
THAT -- YOU
MENTIONED ONE THAT BEEN VERY
SIGNIFICAN IN A PRESS
SIGNIFICANTLY LATELY WHICH IS
THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF
CLOSURES OF RECYCLING CENTERS --
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THAT
CONTRIBUTE SOME TO THE REDUCE
RECYCLING RATE.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO TEASE OUT --
IN THIS VERY COMPLICATED PROGRAM
AS YOU ARE AWARE WHAT IS DRIVING.
WHAT CHANGE THAT WE SEE IN THE
PROGRAM FOR INSTANCE OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS THE
DEPARTMENT IMPLEMENTED PURSUANT
TO NEW LEGISLATION IN NUMBER OF
ANTI FRAUD MEASURES WHICH WE
BELIEVE?
HAS BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE AT
REDUCING FRAUD IN THE PROGRAM
AND COULD HAVE.
CONTRIBUTED TO THE REDUCED
RECYCLING RIGHT THAT WE SEE IN
TERMS OF REDUCING --
WHAT WOULD'VE BEEN FRAUDULENT
REDEMPTIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THERE'S A GOD.
ACCEPTING CERTAIN MATERIALS AS
FREELY AS THEY ONCE DID.
THAT ARE CONSUMED A LOT OF OUR
EXPORT MATERIALS ARE NO LONGER
TAKING NOTES SO THAT'S HAD.
A MARGINAL IMPACT IF NOT MORE ON
THE PROFITABILITY OF SOME THE
RECYCLING CENTERS IN OUR ABILITY
TO EXPORT THIS MATERIAL IN
ADDITION PRIMARILY WE'VE SEEN.
ONE OF THE SIGNIFICANT PROFIT
DRIVERS OF THESE RECYCLING
CENTERS REDUCED AND THAT IS --
NOT ONLY THE ALUMINUM CANS
LIMóN CANTON WHERE THE PROPER
DRIVERS FOR THESE RECYCLING
CENTERS WE'RE SEEING IT
REDUCTION IN BOTH THE VOLUME OF
CONTAINERS AND ALUMINUM AS WELL
AS THE SCRAP VALUE FOR LIMON HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED --
GLOBALLY --
THAT'S NOW I DID STATES A
DYNAMIC.
SO THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES ND AS YOU MENTIONED
THERE'S A NEW ADMINISTRATION AND
WE ARE [inaudible]
WORKING --
WORKING TOGETHER TO SORT OF
DISCUSS WITH A NEW MINISTRATION
AND STAKEHOLDERS THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE --
AND YOU KNOW I'D BE HAPPY TO
COME IN AND PROVIDE YOU AN
ADDITIONAL BRIEFING WE SHOULD BE
GETTING A NEW QUARTERLY REPORT
IT OUT IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
HOPEFULLY AND THAT SOMETHING
THAT MIGHT SHED SOME LIGHT ON
THE DIRECTION WE'RE GOING WITH
THE FUND --
WHERE THE SURPLUS MAY BE HEADED
AND WHAT THE CONDITION OF THE
FUND IS?
WHAT'S THE THAT BEFORE THE MAY
REVISE PLEASE CONTINUE WITH YOUR
OTHER REMARKS ON THE DEPARTMENT
IN GENERAL WE HAVE TO DO --
IF SO -- OR
WE CAN GO STRAIGHT TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
NINE I DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER
PREPARED REMARKS FOR THE THE
DEPARTMENT GENERAL BABBY DID
ANSWER ANY.
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
ALL RIGHT --
LA -- DO YOU
HAVE A COMMENT ON MISSION I'M
NINE THIS IS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS I'M SORRY I
HAVE I HAVE PREPARED REMARKS
REASONABLE AND I THOUGHT YOU
MEANT MORE GENERALLY FELT
DEPARTMENT LET'S START WITH
ISSUE NUMBER NINE OKAY.
HANG ON SENATE MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SEE
YOU -- REFER
FREE WORK SIR LOOK I I THINK
THAT THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAD
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
AND WITHIN THE RECYCLING PROGRAM
VERTICALLY IN RURAL AREAS SOME
THAT WE SEEN IN FOREIGN MARKETS.
HOUSE IMPACTED US SO I THINK
WE'RE NOW WE'RE RUNNING ON YEARS
THREE WITH --
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA LITTLE TO
ZERO RECYCLING CENTER AVAILABLE.
ON AND SO I I WOULD CATCH IT IS
I THINK THE THE FULL OF THE
FOREIGN INFLUENCES OF WHAT WE'VE
SEEN AS OF LATE.
AND ONLY EXASPERATED PROBLEM
WE'VE HAD.
I'M HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN
GENERAL [inaudible]
N..
I GUESS WHERE THE FRUSTRATION IS
IN SMITH I AM NOT TRYING TO KEEP
THE DOG AS WE HAVE BEEN IN MANY
MANY MEETINGS TOGETHER AND I AM
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN
THESE MEETINGS AS WELL AS YOU
WANT.
TO BUT OPINION YOUR AYE --
BUT LOOK I THINK THE BOTTOM LINE
IS WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT THAT
THERE ARE CHALLENGES.
IN THE LONGER WE WAIT THE WORSE
IT GETS IN NOW WORD STILLNESS
WANTING THIS ONE GETS BIGGER --
AND THERE'S NO END IN SIGHT SO
WE HAVE A NEW ADMINISTRATION I
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
WHERE WE GONNA GO FROM HERE
BECAUSE ESPECIALLY IN RURAL --
WE'VE --
ELEVEN WITH THIS CHALLENGE WE
SAW THE HUGE LUMP WITH CHINA.
ENOUGH I'D THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
ACCURATE --
THEN I I GUESS I CAN JUST --
WITH THE OBVIOUS WE DO NOT HAVE
A B. C. P. BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ON THE BEVERAGE TEN
RECYCLING PROGRAM BUT I CAN TELL
YOU.
THAT THE DYNAMIC WHICH YOU REYES
WHICH IS --
WHATEVER THE HARDSHIPS THAT ARE
FACING THE RECYCLING CENTERS THE
LOW VOLUME IN THE REALISTICALLY
WITH THE LOW VOLUME SITES --
FACE THAT THE WORST BECAUSE A
LOT OF THAT WITH THE WAY THE
STATUTE IS IMPLEMENTED IS THAT
WE WE PAY RECYCLING CENTERS.
ON A STATEWIDE AVERAGE.
HONOR IT RIGHT AND SO --
I GUESS I CAN SURE DO THAT THAT
DYNAMIC IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY DISCUSSING AN AWARE OF
AND IT'S STILL A PRIORITY FOR US
SO THIS ISN'T IT IS NOT --
NOT FORGOTTEN NOT AT ALL BEING
CRUNCHY --
BUT IT'S BEEN A PRIORITY
[inaudible] FOR THREE YEARS AND
WE STILL DON'T HAVE ANY
SOLUTIONS TO DATE THERE BEEN A
VARIETY OF ON PROPOSALS THAT
HAVE BEEN ADVANCED BY THE
LEGISLATURE --
A AND THOSE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE --
TO GO ANYWHERE CANDIDLY THIS IS
GOING TO HAVE TO BE AN ISSUE
THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION'S GONNA
I'M HAVE TO TACKLE AND BECAUSE
IT'S THE SAME AGAIN NOT AT ALL.
IN COUNTRY TRYING TO KICK THAT
DEAD DOG RIGHT BUT A LITTLE
EASIER AGAIN IT IS GROUNDHOG DAY.
MESSAGE RECEIVED CENTER.
LET'S MOVE TO OUR CENTER MONNING.
I JUST WANT TO ECHO SOME OF
SENATOR MAGUIRE'S CONCERNS.
THERE WAS A JOINT HEARING
YESTERDAY THAT.
CHAIRMAN STERN COCHAIRED WITH --
CHAIR ALAN ON THE IMPACTS OF
MARINE.
IN.
A LOT OF THAT.
IS PLASTICS COME.
IN PLASTICS THAT AREN'T BEING
RECYCLED --
OR THAT.
DEGRADE ASSESS AND END UP IN
THESE MICROCHIPS.
THE CONCLUSION OF THAT HEARING
YESTERDAY THERE'S NO WAY TO
RECYCLE OUR WAY OUT OF THIS
PROBLEM.
WE GOTTA GO TO SOURCE POLLUTION.
IN I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS.
SOMETHING YOU'RE DEPARTMENT
LOOKS AT SOME.
BUT IF SO.
RE DOING UPSTREAM TO ENCOURAGE
MANUFACTURERS [inaudible] TO TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT
THEY'RE PRODUCING AND TO LOOK AT
UP SENATOR.
WE HAVE VERY LIMITED EXISTING
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO TAKE THAT
TYPE OF ACTION --
WE HAVE A COUPLE PROGRAMS THAT
DO INVOLVE SOURCE REDUCTION AS
PART OF IMPLEMENTATION RIGID
PLASTIC PACKAGING PROGRAM WOULD
BE ONE OF THOSE AND WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING THAT PROGRAM BUT IT
IS FAIRLY LIMITED IN SCOPE --
BUT I AGREE WITH THE SENTIMENT
YOU REYES --
AND I THINK --
THAT.
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO RECYCLE
OURSELVES OUT OF THIS SITUATION
I THINK THAT'S AN ACCURATE
STATEMENT I THINK WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT REDUCING THE AMOUNT.
OF SINGLE USE PACKAGING THAT --
CONSUMED IN OUR ECONOMY AND I
THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE A
PRIORITIES WE MOVE.
FOR I APPRECIATE THAT NOW LOOK
FORWARD [inaudible]
TO ANYTHING EITHER.
RECYCLE OR IN IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE CAN
DO TO RAISE THIS.
ON THE ON THE SCALE OF PUBLIC
AWARENESS IN CONCRETE OPTIONS IN
BRINGING MANUFACTURES TO GET
THERE.
PARTICIPATION IN THIS IT AFFECTS
EVERYBODY.
SO THANK YOU. 30% STATUTORY
MANDATE WOULD HAVE HELP.
DIRECTOR SMITHKLINE I'VE I WOULD
PRESUME MISS CENTER STERN YOU
HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS ARE FRIENDS
FRIEND OF THE NORTH COAST.
AND WILL BE WILL BE EXPRESSING
OUR THAT SENTIMENT AGAIN A I
WOULD ASSUME THIS YEAR
LEGISLATIVELY IT'LL COME BACK TO
YOU.
ON DEALING WITH THE SHORT TERM
ISSUE.
BECAUSE IT IS AN ISSUE.
BUT YOU HAVE BIG VISION AT THE
SAME TIME YOU'RE TRYING TO SOLVE
NEAR TERM PROBLEMS WE GET WE GET
THIS --
NATURE THAT CHALLENGE BUT I
GUESS I WOULD JUST.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW SIR
MECHANICALLY HERE.
IN THE NEAR TERM HI WHAT WHAT IS
THE SORT OF PLANNING PROCESS
THAT'S GOING ON IN TERMS OF NOT
JUST.
THE PRESSURE AT THE LOCAL ALL
COLLECTION CENTER LEVEL BUT ALSO
TERMS OF THE DEVELOPMENT ZONES
IN SORT OF THE LACK OF CAPACITY
IN THE SYSTEM RIGHT NOW IS THAT.
PART OF YOUR CURRENT PLANNING
FOR HOW.
TO SPEND SOME OF THESE DOLLARS
THIS YEAR --
I I I THINK I UNDERSTAND A
QUESTION I THINK YOU'RE
REFERRING TO THE CONVENIENCE
OWNS AND THE THE WHEN YOU SEE
DEVELOPMENTS ON SO I WERE YOUR
FRIEND CONVENIENCE OWNS RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD SO.
THERE'S CONVENIENCE OWNS BUT
THERE'S ALSO THE THE I THINK
IT'S IT'S SORT OF A DEAD LETTER
RIGHT NOW WE'RE TRYING TO
RESURRECT THE MARKET DEVELOPMENT
ZONES TO LOOKING AT SORT OF NEW
OPPORTUNITIES --
YOU ARE IN THE RECYCLING MARK
DEVELOPMENTS --
YEAH GRAHAM OKAY.
WELL THAT PROGRAM IS --
ROBUST AND CAN BEING FULLY
IMPLEMENTED --
AND SO THAT PROGRAM HAS FULL
SUPPORT WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
AND I I I DON'T KNOW.
THERE'S NOT A SPECIFIC
RELATIONSHIP RIGHT NOW BETWEEN
THAT PROGRAM AND THE BEVERAGE
TEN RECYCLING PROGRAM.
WELL THERE I MEAN THERE IS A
RELATIONSHIP AND THAT THERE'S NO
MARKET.
TO AB PROCESS HELLO OKAY SERIAL
YES I'M SURE TO TRY TO GET A
SENSE TO JUST USE NEAR TERM
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR IT FOR THE
YEAR GOT IT SO WELL I SORRY FOR
BEING DENTAL IT'S OKAY NO
THERE'S A LOT OF MOVING PARTS A
LOT OF OUR GRAMS I PREACH.
I THINK I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING NOW --
THE REALLY CRITICAL IMPORTANT
POINT SO --
I THINK THE STATE HAS A GOOD
TRACK RECORD WHEN WE SET OUR
MIND TO IT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
INCREASE DOMESTIC RECYCLING FOR
THEIR MATERIAL THAT ONE POINT IN
TIME.
WE USED TO EXPORT --
98% OF PT WHICH IS OF COURSE
THAT THIS THIS WATER BOTTOM
UNTIL RIGHT HERE RIGHT.
THROUGH A A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP TO THE PLASTIC MARK
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM NOT THE ARMS
YOU BUT TO A PROGRAM WITHIN THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM WE INVESTED IN.
PT RECLAIMING CAPACITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE NOW CONSUME 75% OF
THE PT AND READ --
PROCESS IT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND EXPORT --
LESS THAN 25% OF OF THIS --
UBIQUITOUS MATERIAL HERE SO I
THINK THERE'S A TRACK RECORD FOR
THAT AND WE ARE LOOKING VERY
CLOSELY AT THE ENTIRE MATERIAL
STREAMING TRYING TO DO AN
ANALYSIS OF WHAT ARE THE
MATERIALS THAT ARE RIGHT. FOR
CALIFORNIA TO REINVEST IN
REMANUFACTURING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
NUMBER OF REASONS --
NOT ALL MATERIAL TYPES MY SO
MATERIAL TYPES THAT WE AND IT'S
FOR RE INVESTING IN
REMANUFACTURING CALIFORNIA BRING
JOBS --
WHICH MATERIAL TYPES ARE
PROBABLY MORE PROBLEMATIC WE
WANT TO LOOK AT REDUCING OUT OF
THE STREAM SO WE ARE CONDUCTING
THOSE ANALYSES CHARACTERIZATION
PROCESS IS UNDER WAY RIGHT NOW
THAT'S CONTEMPLATED IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET.
EXTENDING UPON THAT THAT'S
ALREADY UNDER WAY IT IS IT IN
THE IN THE CAPACITY OF ITS --
AN ONGOING RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO BE.
CONDUCTING THESE TYPES OF
ANALYSES NOT.
SPECIFIC TO ANY PROPOSAL KILLER
REGULATION IRAQ IT JUST SORT OF
A GENERAL WILL READ THAT'S GOOD
BECAUSE WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
THAT TOO SO I I APPRECIATE THAT
WORKED AT BEING DONE IN ADVANCE
BECAUSE FRANKLY THE LG TIME.
CAN BE SIGNIFICANT EVEN IF WE
PASS SOME OF THE LEGISLATURE
THIS YEAR AND ADD ON TO
AUTHORITY WHATEVER MAY BE THEIR
NEEDS I MEAN.
I SEE IT I DON'T THINK SEE A
LACK OF STATUTORY AUTHORITY FOR
YOUR DEPARTMENT WITH THESE
DOLLARS TO BE DOING THAT.
THAT WORK RIGHT NOW SO THANKS
FOR THAT.
LET'S MOVE ON IN A SMALL WAY TO
DISS SUSTAINABLE PACKAGING FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THIS IS
OUR FOOD SERVICE.
SIR -- DON'T.
COVERS LIKE A REQUEST ONE
PERMANENT FULL TIME SENIOR
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENTIST IN A
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS INTEGRATED WASTE
MANAGEMENT FUND IN ORDER TO
IMPLEMENT S. B..
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE SB.
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE PROHIBITS
STATE FOOD SERVICE FACILITY FROM
DISTRIBUTING FOOD SERVICE WHERE
THAT IS NOT REUSABLE RECYCLABLE
OR COMPOSTABLE.
IT'S WRECKED CAR CYCLE
PROMULGATE REGULATIONS AND
ESTABLISH A PROCESS FOR
DETERMINING WHETHER FOOD SERVICE
WHERE'S REASONABLE RECYCLER
COMPOSTABLE AND IT ALSO REQUIRES
US TO CONDUCT ONGOING
EVALUATIONS. FOR FOOD SERVICE
PACKAGING WHICH WILL INCLUDE
ANALYSIS OF MATERIALS AND
PRODUCT PERFORMANCE AT END OF
LIFE ASSESSMENT RIGHT RECYCLING
AND COMPOSTING INFRASTRUCTURE
MARKETS.
TECHNICAL STANDARDS INTESTINE
EXTENSIVE CONSULTATION WITH
OTHER --
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN AGENCIES.
THE BILL AUTHORIZES THE
DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOP
DEFINITIONS FOR THESE TERMS.
WHICH WILL ALLOW COVER CYCLE TO
EVALUATE PRODUCTS BASED ON
UNIQUE CRITERIA AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
HELLO YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON HI
MISTER TURN SENATORS JUST
COMPUTERS WITH THE ALEJO --
WE DON'T RAISE ANY ISSUES WITH
HE FOOD SERVICE PACKAGING
PROPOSAL OR THE OTHER PROPOSAL
THAT CAL RECYCLE HAS ON YOUR
AGENDA TODAY.
BUT I DID JUST WANT TO REMIND
THE COMMITTEE THAT OUR OFFICE
CONTINUES TO I'LL LOOK INTO AND
THINK ABOUT THE LARGER ISSUES OF
RECYCLING AND WE ARE OF COURSE
AVAILABLE TO THE COMMITTEE ON TO
PROVIDE ANY ASSISTANCE YOU MIGHT
NEED.
COUNTS ME THAT WILL BE ASKING
FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE THIS IS A
RECOMMENDED APPROVED AS BUDGET
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON ISSUE
NUMBER.
NINE SB THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE IN
THE PROPOSED PERMANENT POSITION
TO FILL THAT MISSION.
THE MOST WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR MINING PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
CASKEY HI.
JONES [inaudible] ONE THANK
[inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
STERN HI.
THAT MATTER PASSES FOR ONE LET'S
MOVE ON THE SHARPS THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER.
TEN PHARMACEUTICAL AND SHARPS
WASTE STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM THIS.
DIRECTOR SMITH ONE THANK YOU CAL
RECYCLE REQUEST ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION IN THE PHARMACEUTICAL
AND SHARP STEWARDSHIP FUND
INTEND POSITIONS.
AND ONE POINT TWO MILLION ON
GOING BEGINNING IN. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
TO IMPLEMENT SB.
TO TWELVE SENATE BILL TWO TWELVE
DIRECTS PHARMACEUTICAL INSURANCE
MANUFACTURERS DISTRIBUTORS
LICENSED AS WHOLESALERS RE
PACKAGERS.
LICENSEES OF TRADEMARKS OR BRAND
AND IMPORTERS TO ESTABLISH A
PHARMACEUTICAL IN CHARGE
EXTENDED PRODUCE RESPONSIBILITY
PROGRAM.
THIS PRIVATE SECTOR DESIGN
APPROACH WOULD ESTABLISH A
PHARMACEUTICAL AND SHARPS WASTE
PROGRAM FOR THE PROPER END OF
LIFE MANAGEMENT OF COVERED DRUGS
AND HOME GENERATED SHARPS WASTE.
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB TO TWELVE
WOULD DECREASE THE NUMBER OF
UNWANTED DRUGS AND SHARP FROM
ENTERING THE TRADITIONAL WAY
STREAM. FOR ME INTO THE BY
SHIFTING COSTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF PRODUCT
DISPOSAL TO MANUFACTURERS AND
OTHERS WHO DIRECTLY BENEFIT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND TAX RATE
PAYERS.
WILL EXPERIENCE A REDUCTION IN
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH WASTE
WATER TREATMENT FACILITIES
LANDFILLS AND MATERIAL THE
RECYCLING FACILITIES.
WERE BURNED BY THE IMPROPER
DISPOSAL THESE PRODUCTS.
PRESUMABLY OUR HOSPITALS AND
HEALTH CARE CENTERS ARE.
GETTING OUT OF THE BUSINESS OF
FLUSHING.
UNUSED PHARMACEUTICALS THAT'S
OUR GOAL.
ELLIE -- IF
YOU'RE OKAY WITH THIS ANYTHING
ADDITIONAL FOR FINANCE.
THIS IS MEMBERS THIS IS APPROVED
AS BUDGET ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
INITIATION OR IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE SEARCH A PROGRAM.
THERE'S A MOTION LET'S OPEN UP
PUBLIC OUR COMMENT THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER. TEN TEN POSITIONS AND
BEGINNING THE PHARMACEUTICAL AND
SHARP STEWARDSHIP FUND PROGRAM.
SEEING THEN.
WILL CLOSE.
THE PUBLIC HEARING AN OPEN AND
CALL THE ROLL.
I COUNTY HI JONES [inaudible]
WITH [inaudible]
ONE MONEY [inaudible]
STERN.
THAT MATTERS APPROVED FIVE ZERO
THANK YOU TO DIRECTOR SMITHKLINE
LET'S CALL UP THE OUR MEN OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION
[inaudible]
WE HAVE [inaudible] TWO ISSUES.
A SERVER OVERVIEW.
FIXING THE FUN.
ACTING DIRECTOR MARKS GOOD
MORNING.
JOINING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN --
MY NAME IS FOR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS THERESA
MARKS ON THE ACTING DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION.
AND I HAVE WITH ME TODAY LESLIE
FORTY WHO IS THE DIVISION CHIEF
OF OUR FISCAL DIVISION --
THE PURPOSE ARE REGULATIONS
MISSION IS TO PROTECT HUMAN
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT BY
REGULATING PESTICIDES SALES AND
USE SOME OF FOSTERING REDUCE
RISK PEST MANAGEMENT.
THE P. R. ALSO PROVIDES
OVERSIGHT FOR LOCAL PESTICIDE
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS OF ALL
FIFTY FIVE COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS AND THEIR COMBINED
STAFF OF APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED NINETY BIOLOGIST.
DOES TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET IS A HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
CONTAINING THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT POSITIONS AND
INCLUDING TO BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS REQUESTING FOR
POSITIONS.
OUR FIRST BCP IS --
SESSIONS FOR INFORMATION
SECURITY TEAM IS A REQUEST FOR
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR ONGOING COST
ANNUALLY THERE AFTER FROM THE
DPR FUN TO COMPLY WITH STATE
REQUIRED ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTY
SECURITY ASSESSMENT REMEDIATION.
AND CLOUD MIGRATION SECURITY
HARDWARE.
WITH THE ADDITION OF THREE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
SPECIALIST TO FUNCTION AS ITS
INFORMATION SECURITY TEAM DPR WE
BETTER SITUATED. TO MEET THESE
NEW SECURITY REQUIREMENTS.
THE SECOND B. C. P. CONCERNS
PESTICIDES IN SCHOOL SITES
REQUIRE IT'S THE CENTERED AROUND
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTEEN IN OUR EFFORTS.
TO ENFORCE THAT REQUEST A
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE DVR FINE
ANNUALLY FOR TWO YEARS TO
IMPLEMENT A CITY ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN REQUIRES
DPR TO SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO THE VALUE
WHITE THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
EFFECT.
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
HEALTHY SCHOOLS ACT AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND ADVOCACY OF
THE HEALTHY SCHOOLS ACT.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE ANALYSIS AND
ADDRESS CONCERNS RAISED
REGARDING OUR FUNDING CONDITION
WHICH I KNOW CAN RISE STAR
DOCUMENTS STERN CERTAINTY THAT
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY GETS US.
RIGHT.
AND IN JUST TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF --
EXPLANATION OF THAT IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THE DPR FUND
BALANCE HAD APPROXIMATE
RESERVISTS 17%.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
GOAL IS TO HAVE A RESERVE AMOUNT
WITHIN 325%.
IN ORDER TO REDUCE OUR RESERVE
WE HAD SPENT MORE THAN THE
REVENUE RECEIVED CREATING A
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE FOR THE
PAST SIX YEARS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR
REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES UNTIL
WE MEET OUR 325% GOAL.
AT THAT TIME DEEP YOUR WILL NEED
TO EXPLORE SAVINGS CANNOT BE
MADE IN ORDER TO MAKE CRITICAL
NEEDS OF THE STATE WE MAY NEED
TO EXPLORE THE OPTION TO RISE
THE APPROPRIATE FEES.
WHICH INCLUDE THE MAIL
REGISTRATION AND LICENSING FEES.
WITH THE NEW FINE CONDITION
NUMBERS PART PROVIDED THIS WEEK
DPR DOES NOT EXPECT TO REACH
THAT LEVEL OF 325%.
UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'LL BE
HAPPY TO ADDRESS THOSE.
THE THE CHALLENGES THAT WE KNOW
WHEN THIS CLIMATE CHANGE
ENVIRONMENT THAT ONE OF THE
LEAST TALKED ABOUT --
CHALLENGES PASS AND AND WE DON'T
KNOW WHEN IT'S GOING TO HIT BUT
WE KNOW THAT THAT WE'VE GOT
THESE INVASIVE SPECIES IN ALL
THIS ACTIVITY IS GOING ON AND
THE CONCERN IS THAT THE YOUR
DEPARTMENT WILL BE PREPARED.
WHEN THAT CALAMITY OR?
SUGGEST A CALAMITY IT COMES AND
THAT'S I GUESS THAT'S THE
QUESTION AND I WOULD HAVE IS IS
GIVEN THE UNIQUE NATURE OF WHAT
DEPARTMENT DOES IN THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES IS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SEA LEVEL RISE AT LAKE.
I'D ASK OTHER FOLKS WHO DO YOU
HAVE A COMMENT ON ON THAT.
YET TO OCCUR.
CALAMITY.
RIGHT AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND CERTAINLY
THAT SOMETHING WE'VE CONSIDERED
AT THE OFFICE WE NOW WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE THERE COULD BE A
CHANGE IN THE TYPE OF PASS WE
HAVE THERE COULD BE A CHANGE IN
THE NUMBERS --
IT CERTAINLY EITHER. ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER --
WE LOOK AT BOTH OF THE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH WITH THE OFFICE AND
WE'RE TRYING TO PUT MORE
EMPHASIS ON THEN WE HAVE IN THE
PAST IS THE INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS.
WE WANT TO LOOK AT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS PAST
CONCERNS IN THE FUTURE WITHOUT
THE USE OF THE MORE TOXIC
PESTICIDES THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY
DEALING WITH.
SO WE WHEN WE LOOK AT
INCORPORATING THOSE OTHER
MEASURES WE'RE TRYING TO DO --
RESEARCH WE'RE TRYING TO TO DEAL
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON HOW WE CAN
INCORPORATE THOSE LESS TOXIC
MEASURES TO CONTROL PASSED IN
THE FUTURE AND THAT CERTAINLY
BEGINNING BECOME MORE NECESSARY
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE.
WE'VE COME A LONG WAYS WITH THE
STERILE FRUIT FLY IN BT COLLINS
SEVEN SOME MALATHION.
SENATOR MONIC.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
APPRECIATE.
THIS UPDATE.
I'M ON THE HELP THE SCHOOLS
IMPLEMENTATION IN THE BROAD
COMMITMENT.
TO INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT --
WE TALK ABOUT PASS BUT I THINK A
LOT OF IN THAT BROAD CATEGORIES
WEEDS AND A LOT OF THE WEED
CONTROL ON SCHOOL SITES.
THEY'RE USING ROUNDUP CAN WE BE
ASSURED THAT ROUNDUP IS NO
LONGER BEING USED AT SCHOOL
SITES.
NO SIR WE CAN'T GIVE YOU THAT
ASSURANCE --
I THINK THAT THAT'S UP TO THE
SCHOOL DO.
AROUND UP IS STILL REGISTERED
FOR USE IN CALIFORNIA AND AS
LONG AS IT'S USED ACCORDING TO
LABEL DIRECTIONS IT'S NOT
PROHIBITED BUT I THINK CERTAIN
SCHOOLS CAN MAKE THEIR OWN
DETERMINATIONS AS TO HOW THEY
WISH TO USE IT OR WHETHER IT.
WAS LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
SCHOOL SITES YES SIR THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING AND YOUR
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN OFFERED ANY
ADVICE REASON LIGHT OF RECENT
SCIENTIFIC DATA SHOWING THE
NEXUS BETWEEN ROUND UP AND
CANCER.
WE HAVE NOT PUT GLYCOSIDE INTO
REEVALUATION AT THIS POINT THAT
DOES NOT MEAN THAT THAT MIGHT
NOT BE COMING.
ON OUR SITE IS CONTINUALLY
EVALUATE THOSE TYPES OF THINGS
AND WE HAVE.
CERTAINLY AYE AYE ACTIVE
INGREDIENTS IN REVALUATION NOW
ANY COULD BE ADDED AT SOME POINT.
I APPRECIATE THAT NINE OH MY
QUESTION GOES A LITTLE BEYOND
THE BOUNDS OF THE BUDGET REQUEST.
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT'S ON YOUR RADAR
BUT I WOULD.
JUST TING COURAGE IN LIGHT OF
RECENT.
PUBLIC MEDIA REPORTS ABOUT THE
COURT DETERMINED --
ADVERSE HEALTH IMPACTS OF ROUND
UP.
AND REVIEW REALLY
INTERNATIONALLY.
PARTICULARLY WAS SCHOOL SITES I
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE P. R. TO BE
AS PROACTIVE AS POSSIBLE AND
PROTECTING OUR SCHOOL SITES
THANK YOU.
IN A CERTAIN OVERALL QUESTION ON
THE PR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ACTING DIRECTOR FOR
BEING HERE --
ONE SECOND COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUE
ON THE LIFE AS A FRIEND.
PEOPLE DON'T ALWAYS
DISTINGUISHING IT AT A A
JUDICIAL DETERMINATION WHAT
HAPPENED THE GOVERNMENT THEY
WONDER.
IF THERE'S A CLASS ACTION SUIT
OR SOME OTHER DECISION WHY ARE
WE DOING ANYTHING ABOUT IT SO
THE MORE YOU CAN DO UNDER YOUR
EXISTING AUTHORITY WE DO
APPRECIATE ONE OTHER.
CHEMICAL AND I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED IBM AND YOUR EFFORTS
ON INTEGRATED PES MANAGEMENT ON
THIS SORT OF LOCAL DISCRETION
ISSUE.
DO YOU SEE --
SUFFICIENT AUTHORITY CURRENTLY
TO DO MORE THAN JUST MORE
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT SORT
OF PUSHING ON THAT SIDE BUT
ACTUALLY TAKES SOME OF THIS --
RODENTICIDE OFF THE SHELVES THAT
MAYBE WE DON'T WANNA BE PUTTING
IN BEHIND OUT YOU KNOW AND ARE
PAID BOXES AND OTHER THINGS
BECAUSE WE YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD.
MULTIPLE IT IS A THERE'S ONLY A
FEW MATT LINES LEFT IN ALL OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THIS IS AN
AMAZING APEX PREDATOR LIVES
THERE AND WE LITERALLY KEEP
LOSING THEM YEAR AFTER YEAR FROM
FROM THIS STUFF.
AND IT KEEPS IT AROUND SO YOU
KNOW.
IS VERY REAL AND THERE'S ALL
KINDS OF INTERESTING
ALTERNATIVES AND PEOPLE MAY.
NOT THINK THAT.
USING RAFTER POLLS ARE OTHER
SORT OF NON CHEMICAL SOLUTION
SOUND HIPPY DIPPY BUT IN FACT
THEY'VE BEEN PROVEN IN VENTURA
COUNTY TO BE PRETTY EFFECTIVE WE
JUST FINISHED A CASE STUDY OUT
THERE SO.
I GUESS QUESTION ON LOCAL
DISCRETION TO MOVE --
AND THEN WHAT KIND OF
ALTERNATIVES ARE YOU LOOKING AT
ON THE IBM SAID.
ACTUALLY WE HAVE --
JUST RECENTLY PUT SECOND JAN
ANTICOAGULANT READINESS SIDES
INTO EVALUATION REEVALUATION.
WE PROPOSE THAT I THINK WAS IN
JANUARY WE GO THROUGH A COMMENT
PERIOD AND THEN WE'VE OFFICIALLY
PUT THEM INTO RE EVALUATION AT
THIS POINT.
SO DURING THIS TIME THEIR PERIOD
THERE WILL BE NO EXPANSION OF
SECOND GENERATION ANTICOAGULANTS
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
WILL BEGIN AN EVALUATION OF SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT YOU'VE
MENTIONED THE EFFECT ON ON NON
TARGET ORGANISMS.
THANK YOU.
WITH THE ENTHUSIASM SHOWN BY MY
COLLEAGUES ON SCHOOL SITES WHEN
WE MOVED TO ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN
WHICH IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYOR
SU CHI'S BILL THE IMPLEMENTATION.
OF AND THE EVALUATION OF
EFFICACY OF THIS OF OF THAT.
ACT.
IS ARE WE ARE ARE PREPARING IT
TO TO DO THAT TYPE OF EVALUATION --
ARE HEALTHY IN OUR OR ONE OF OUR
BRANCHES WE HAVE A HEALTHY
SCHOOLS ACT --
DIVISION THAT DOES INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT PROMOTION WITH
SCHOOLS WE HAVE A GROUP OF FOLKS
THAT GO OUT --
IN PARTICULARLY OFTEN WERE
INVITED SOMETIMES E HEAR ABOUT
SOME PROBLEMS SCHOOLS HAVING IT
WILL CALL THEM AND ASK THEM IF
THEY NEED OUR HELP WE'LL GO OUT
IN A TIP TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
INFORMATION ON HOW THEY CAN USE.
SUBSTANCES SUBSTANCES THAT ARE
NOT NECESSARILY THE TOXIC
ALTERNATIVES --
GOLFER TRAPS THAT'S BEEN A BIG
THING WITH A LOT OF SCHOOLS
BECAUSE OF THE THE HOLES I HAVE
<c.red>N THE ATHLETIC FIELDS --</c>
WE TALK TO THEM ABOUT WE HAD
WHEN I WAS THERE.
TO WE TALK WITH ABOUT RISING UP
THEIR TRASH CANS --
WE TALK ABOUT CLEANING OUT THEIR
TEACHER'S LOUNGES AND AND THINGS
LIKE THAT WITH OLD FOOD SOME OF
THIS STUFF IS COMMON SENSE BUT
SOME OF IT OR THINGS THAT WE
HAVE FOUND. TO BE VERY HELPFUL
IN DEALING WITH PAST PROBLEMS IN
SCHOOLS SO WE GO OUT ON A
REGULAR BASIS AND DO THAT NOW
WITH THIS HEALTHY SCHOOLS ACT --
EVALUATION WILL BE CONTACTING
THE SCHOOLS TO DETERMINE.
WHAT KIND OF CHANGES HAVE BEEN
MADE?
WHERE WE ARE SEEING --
AS AN INCREASE IN THE USE THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS TO REPORT BACK
TO THE SENATE.
COLLEAGUES THEM FROM THE CENTRAL
COAST QUESTION OF RECENT
INFORMATION YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE EFFICACY OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE HEALTHY
SCHOOL ACT OF TWO THOUSAND AND
IT WOULD BE.
NOT BE ON THE GROUND THAT THEY
WOULD SAY OH THIS IS THE HERE
ARE ALTERNATIVES THAT HAVE BEEN --
PRODUCED SINCE 200-022-00020 AND
YOU MIGHT WANT TO USE THIS AND
ACTUALLY IF YOU DID USE THIS YOU
HAVE A BETTER.
RESULT.
IT'S CONCEIVABLE THAT.
THE FOLKS WORKING ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENTISTS WORKING ON THAT I'M
ONLY THIS IS RECOMMENDED HOLD
OPEN DO YOU HAVE A COMMENT.
CHAU MARTIN AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE'RE NOT RAISING ISSUES WITH
EITHER OF THE TWO PROPOSALS
BEFORE YOU --
REGARDING THE DEPARTMENT HAS
SAID REGULATIONS HOWEVER WE
WANTED TO BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION A LARGER ISSUE.
THAT DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION THERE --
PESTICIDE REGULATION FIND WHICH
IS OVER 90% OF THEIR BUDGET WE
HAD NOTED THAT THE BALANCE IS
SHOWN IN THE JANUARY TENTH --
BUDGET. FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES WERE DECLINING
SPECIFICALLY FOR TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN FROM FOURTEEN
POINT FOUR MILLION TO SEVEN
POINT FOUR MILLION IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
THEN ANOTHER DECLINED TO FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
A COUPLE OF DAYS AGO RECEIVED AN
UPDATED FIND CONDITIONS
STATEMENT.
THAT PAINTS A BRIGHTER PICTURE
IN THIS CASE.
THAT BALANCE FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES TWENTY POINT SEVEN
MILLION IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN DECLINING TO
TO THIRTEEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND THEN DECLINING TO
GET A TEN POINT SIX MILLION.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
OPPORTUNITY GIVEN WE JUST
RECEIVED THIS INFORMATION A FEW
DAYS AGO TO DO AN ANALYSIS OF
WHAT'S CAUSING THIS BUT GIVEN
THAT -- THAT
THAT FUND BALANCE IS DECLINING
WE THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO HOLD
THESE ITEMS OPEN AS RECOMMENDED
BY STAFF INTEL WE CAN LOOK INTO
IT MORE.
FINANCES DECLINING BUT NOT AS
STEEP AS ORIGINALLY THOUGHT AND
WITHIN THE 325% WILL RUN.
YES LIVE VERY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE --
AT THE TIME OF GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ON ALL THE FUN USERS HAD IS
CLOSED SO SINCE THEN WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO RECONCILE THE FIND
AND PROVIDE YOUR STAFF AND THE
LA OUT WITH AN UPDATED FINE
CONDITION [inaudible]
CENTER MONEY.
MISTER CHAIR IN.
AGAIN MAYBE I'M DRIFTING BACK
INTO THE POLICY NO PUN INTENDED
I'M CONCERNED ON THE SCHOOL SITE.
MONITORING.
THE HEALTHY SCHOOLS LOOKS A LOT
AT PRACTICES ON SCHOOLS GROUNDS
TURF IT CETERA.
BUT THE OTHER BIG RISK IN RURAL
AREAS IS DRIFT OF PESTICIDE FROM
AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS.
IN MY DISTRICT IN PARTICULAR
THERE'S PARENTS AND TEACHERS
LOOKING AT CHLORPYRIFOS.
WOULD THAT BE WITHIN THE SCOPE
OF THE SAFES.
BEYOND --
WHAT'S CONTEMPLATED IN THE SAFE
SCHOOLS.
EFFORTS.
IT THAT WOULD BE ON BEYOND THE
HEALTHY SCHOOLS ACTING WAT'S
CONTEMPLATED IN THIS PARTICULAR
BILL HOWEVER WE DID PASS
REGULATION LAST YEAR THAT DEALS
WITH PESTICIDE USE AROUND
SCHOOLS.
AND IT HAS PROVIDED THAT --
WITHIN A QUARTER MILE OF SCHOOLS --
BETWEEN SIX THE MORNING IS A
SKIT AT NIGHT --
YOU PESTICIDES THAT ARE SUBJECT
TO DRIFT.
SO THAT AT THAT WE THINK IS
TAKING CARE OF A LOT OF THOSE
CONCERNS --
EIGHT ALSO RESTRICTS THE
APPLICATION OF HIM AGAIN --
WITHIN THIRTY SIX HOURS OF WIND
CHILDREN WILL BE PRESENT AT
SCHOOL AND THAT KIND OF STUFF SO
WE REALLY THINK THAT THAT.
THAT HAS MADE MORE OF A OF A
MARKER ON PESTICIDE USE AROUND
SCHOOLS PARTICULARLY IN
AGRICULTURAL AREAS.
THANK YOU IN ON A LOOK FOR TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT BEYOND THE
BUDGET BE GLAD TO SEND YOU SOME
INFORMATION ON THAT I THINK I
RECALL CENTER WHEN WE HAD
HEARINGS ON THAT AS PROPOSED
REGULATIONS.
THE DEBATE WAS HOW MUCH NOTICE
THE COMMUNITY GOT WAS IT WE'RE
GOING TO LAY THE PESTICIDES OUT
ON SATURDAY WHEN THE SAME
POPULATION IT NAMES LIVES CLOSE
TO THE SCHOOLS GOING TO BE
ADVERSELY AFFECT ALTHOUGH THERE
WOULDN'T BE ANYBODY.
ON THE SCHOOL SITE SO THAT.
WAS WHAT IT WAS ALREADY WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN FOR
LET'S GO TO ISSUE NUMBER. TWELVE
ON THE INFORMATION SECURITY.
TEAM AT THE PR.
AND HAVE OUR PUBLIC HEARINGS.
THE INFORMATION SECURITY TEAM B.
C. P. IS ONE THAT WE'RE
REQUESTING.
BACK UP --
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY SIX THOUSAND
IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND
600-406-0004 ON GOING COST
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER --
THIS UP A IS USED TO COMPLY WITH
STATE REQUIRED ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
SEVENTY THE SECURITY ASSESSMENT
RATE REMEDIATION IN CLOUD
MIGRATION SECURITY HARDWARE
SOFTWARE AND SERVICES.
WITH THE ADDITION OF THREE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
SPECIALIST THE FUNCTION AS ITS
INFORMATION SECURITY TEAM DPR
WILL BE BETTER SITUATED TO MEET
THE NEW SECURITY REQUIREMENTS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I GUESS MY QUESTION WOULD BE ON
THIS IS SECURITIES THIS IS
SECURITY NOT MARGARINE GOT IT
AND HAVE A QUESTION.
HELLO NOTHING.
FINANCE HAVE SOMETHING THAT.
YES MISTER CHAIR --
GO I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
NOTATION ON THE OVER ARCHING DPR
FUND -- IN
THAT.
IT'S PART OF THE MAY PROCESS.
AS WELL NO WE DID SHARED THE
UPDATE WITH THE ACTUAL IS.
FOR SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THOSE IN THE
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IN
NINETEEN TWENTY NUMBERS WILL
REMAIN STATIC.
BECAUSE DURING THE MAY REVISE
PROCESS WE ALWAYS DO AN UPDATE
ON PROJECTED REVENUES IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING AND THE DEPARTMENT
CAN.
CORRECT ME IF I'M MISSTATING
THIS BUT THEY ALSO HAVE CSU
FRESNO.
CONTRACTED TO PROVIDE --
PROJECTEDESTIMATES ON THE
REVENUES.
IN REMARKS REFRESH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S MEMORY HOW MUCH
OF THE BUDGET IN THE DEPARTMENT
IS FEE BASED AND HOW MUCH IS.
THE GENERAL FUND JUST GENERALLY
I DON'T HAVE THAT.
I KNOW THE MAJORITY OF HIS FEE
BASED RIGHT.
RIGHT SO IT'S YOU GOT.
OKAY SO --
WE ARE 98% BE BASED HIGH ANNUAL
WAS SOMETHING LARGE ALL RIGHT
LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
THESE ARE ITEMS NUMBER ELEVEN
AND TWELVE AND THE SCHOOL SITE
PESTICIDE.
INFORMATION SECURITY TEAM
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD MATTER OPEN.
LOCAL CLOSE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
INFORMATION LET'S CALL UP.
WE HAVE A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
COMING UP.
KEEP THE PUBLIC HEARING OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I MAY TOUCH UNDER FROM PESTICIDE
ACTION NETWORK.
ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS OF PESTICIDE REFORM.
WE APPLAUD DPR FOR A FOCUS ON A
COMMUNITY TRANSPARENCY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH HOWEVER.
WE URGE ADDITIONAL FUNDING BE
MADE AVAILABLE FOR SUFFICIENT
STAFF AND RESOURCES. THIRTY
PAIRS INITIATION OF RULE MAKING
FOR ONE THREE DICHLORO PROBING
IS NOT DELAYED.
BUT CONTINUES AS PLANNED FOR
MAIN DECISION SECONDLY DPR
SHOULD FUND TECHNICAL SUPPORT SO
THAT ALL NOTICES OF INTENT.
THAT IS FARMERS REQUESTING
APARTMENT TO APPLY RESTRICTED
PESTICIDES AND DECISIONS ON
THESE ANALYZE BY COUNTY ACT
COMMISSIONERS ARE PUBLICLY
POSTED ON THE COUNTY
COMMISSIONERS WEBSITES.
SO THAT THE PUBLIC CAN KNOW
WHAT'S BEING APPLIED AROUND THEM.
THIRDLY DPR SHOULD UE THE
SURPLUS TO DOUBLE FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR RESEARCH AND
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS FOR
ALTERNATIVES TO THE HAZARDOUS
SYNTHETIC PESTICIDES IN THE
STATE'S AGRICULTURE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS WHO'D LIKE TO
COMMENT ON ITEM I WILL CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING.
EXCUSE THE P. R. AND CALL UP THE
TSC THIS IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCE.
WILL HAVE AN OVERVIEW --
AND THEN WE HAVE [inaudible]
ISSUES.
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN DEPUTY
DIRECTOR NAY GREED GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU SO MUCH --
FOR ALLOWING THIS TIME I'M CHIEF
ARE MATT FRANCESCA NEGATIVE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL.
AND WITH ME IS A SUPERDELEGATE
UC ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
SITE MITIGATION RESTORATION AND
ALSO THE PROJECT MANAGER FOR THE
EXITE PROJECT.
WE HAVE AN OVERALL --
REPORT.
HE GOT.
TAKE MEDICATION HAZARDOUS WASTE
PROGRAM IN GREEN CHEMISTRY YOU
HAVE ANYTHING THE ONE UPDATE US
ON I I HAVE NO UPDATES --
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS ARE REMARKS
ARE ARE SPECIFIC TO THE TWO
PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE REGARDING
EXIDE.
KELLY -- ANY.
QUESTIONS ON THE OVERALL --
PROPOSAL LOOKS LIKE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE THE HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
IS GOING.
TO I HAVE A TWELVE BILLION
DOLLAR.
SHORTFALL THIS YEAR YOU HAVE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
JOHN MARTIN AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THAT HAS BEEN
AT AT A TOPIC THAT WE HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSING WITH LEGISLATIVE
STAFF AND PROVIDING THEM
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON THAT
ISSUE. TO TRY AND WORK THROUGH
THE OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO YOU TO
ADDRESS THAT SHORTFALL.
AND AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO DO
SO BUT AT THIS POINT WE DON'T
HAVE A A RECOMMENDATION.
NOW I GUESS THE QUESTION THE
STAFF REPORT TALKS ABOUT THE
WORSENING OF THE THE THE DEFICIT
WE HAVE.
AN LIKE A DISEASE JULIAN THAT'S
NOT A NUMBER THE IN A ABANDONED
THAT ARE IN SHOPPING CENTERS
THAT HAD --
PROPOSED [inaudible]
HI.
SECRETARY --
BLOOM AND FELT INDICATED THAT
THAT WOULD BE PART OF THIS
960-002-20012 --
THOUSAND SITES THAT THE E. EPA
ESTIMATES --
THAT THAT'D ARCHES OUT THERE.
I GUESS YOU HAVE ANY YOU KNOW WE
HAVE IT SEEMS LIKE THE TIDAL
WAVE IS COMING.
OUR WAY FOR THE CLEAN UP OF OF
THE SITES WE GET IN A LITTLE DRY
CLEANER IN A SHOPPING MALL
THAT'S GONE I MEAN IT'S GOT A
METRO MOBILE AND A KARATE SCHOOL
IN IT BUT NOTHING ELSE.
AND IN BUT THEY HAD THAT IT HAS
THAT LEGACY AND THERE'S NO
RESPONSIBLE PERSON.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE LEVEL OF
CLEAN UP IS BECAUSE THE THE CD.
BUT THE ENGINEERING BUT THE
RIVER -- THE
TECHNOLOGY WAS NOT SO ADVANCE
WHEN WE WERE.
WE STARTED DRY CLEANING BACK AND
AFTER W. W. TO TOM AND SOME OF
THE SITES ARE.
LARGELY CONTAMINATED WE JUST
DON'T NOW SO --
I GUESS I'M CONCERT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT ALSO --
I THINK PREVIOUSLY I'VE
MENTIONED SOME CONCERN I MEAN I
UNDERSTAND.
THE YOU GET THE TOXIC SUBSTANCE
CONTROL AND YOU'VE GOT THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL AND AND
AND IN THIS MAY JUST MAY BE MY
LACK OF UNDERSTANDING BUT I
REALIZE THAT PEOPLE DO WORK UP
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT WHEN
THEY'RE GETTING PAID OUT OF ONE
OF THE FUNDS.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE AT LEAST
IN MY MIND YEAH GENERAL FUND
REQUESTS HELP SMOOTH OUT THAT
THAT WERE CLOSED SO THAT YOU SEE
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE.
DO NOT BUDGETED TO TAKE MONEY
OUT OF FIND YOUR IN AT THE HAS
IT IS FINE BUT THEY'RE THEY'RE
DOING THAT WORK AND I CAN.
WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD CONFIDENCE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT WITH THE
PUBLIC ABOUT THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE AT THAT YOU'RE DOING SO.
WE HAVE TO FIX THIS PROBLEM.
FINANCE I MEAN WE NEED TO COME
UP WITH A PROPOSAL [inaudible]
I'M.
THIS FISCAL YEAR.
HAVE A COMMENT ON THAT.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
JULIANNE MOORE IS A ME WITH
FINANCE AND I ACKNOWLEDGE.
WE'VE WE'VE BEEN.
WATCHING THIS FUND AND WE WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS A
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE WITH THEIR
EXPENDITURES EXCEEDING THE
REVENUES AND HAVE KNOWN THAT.
AND BEEN WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ON CRAFTING --
SOME OPTIONS TO THE SOLUTIONBUT
UNTIL.
AT THE TIME OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET --
THE DEPARTMENT WAS STILL WORKING
ON CLOSING ITS BOOKS AND
RECONCILING THINGS THAT POINT.
WE HAVE THE DEPARTMENT HAS
CLOSED.
SO WE ANTICIPATE --
MOVING FORWARD WITH.
WITH SOME OPTIONS IN IN THE
SPRING PROCESS.
I KNOW OUR STAFF REPORT TALKS
ABOUT THE FEES IN SORT OF THE
OLD MODEL OF A BASS LINE FEE AND
IT JUST --
AND NOT REALLY BEING THE FOR
SERVICE THAT THAT POOR FOLKS ON
THE OTHER HAND.
I'M SURE THERE MAY BE PEOPLE AND
FROM THE INDUSTRY THAT SAYS GIVE
ME MY PERMIT IF I'M IF I'M COULD
PAY MY FEE I WANTED.
WANTED SOME ASSURANCE THAT'S AT
LEAST IN THE DISCUSSION FOR THE
EIGHT YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE.
IT WE GOT TO SEE SOME ACTION I
GUESS IS THE AFTER THE THE
PUBLIC AN INDEPENDENT REVIEW
PANEL CAME UP WITH A VARIETY OF
OF OF RECOMMENDATIONS SOME OF
THEM.
WERE REQUESTED TO BE.
A FORMER BILLS THE BY THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR THOSE WERE
VETOED -- I
HAVE BEEN VOCAL ABOUT HAVING A
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO TO FIXING
UP INSTEAD OF YOU KNOW.
THE RECOMMENDATION THE CAME OUT
THE SECOND QUARTER FOR MY P. R.
AND SAY OH THIS IS MY BILL NOT.
ANOTHER I SHOULD BE SARCASTIC
BUT BUT THERE'S A FUNDAMENTAL
CHANGES THAT THE PUBLIC.
REQUIRES IN THE LEGISLATURE
REQUIRES TO GET THE BE --
DEPARTMENT.
IN TIP TOP SHAPE I GUESS IN ONE
OF THEM IS THE IS THE FINANCIAL
SIDE THAT THE DEFICIT.
BECAUSE I'M A BUDGET SURE SO
THAT'S WHY I HAVE TO ASK THAT
QUESTION.
ALL RIGHT --
GENERAL COMMENTS ON DGSE CENTER
REQUIRE.
ON THE PROGRAM.
MISTER CHAIR I'M GONNA JUST.
TALK ABOUT THE ON IT JUST MY
COMMENTS ON ISSUE THIRTEEN
CORRECT WE'RE NOT.
FOR I HAVE AN OPEN UP THIRTEEN
YET AT THAT JUST GENERAL
COMMENTS ON A WHOLE CENTER STERN
WHEN YOU GO FIRST AND I'LL GIVE
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I JUST WANT TO GET SOME -
SOME GENERAL FEEDBACK ON ANOTHER
COMPLICATED.
THE SENSE IN A FIELD LAB.
WHERE THE WILL THE FIRE STARTED
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
EXACTLY WHAT THE?
TOXIC IMPACTS WERE OF THEIR THAT
INCIDENT BUT WE'VE SEEN SOME
TROUBLING SIGNS FOR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BACKSLIDING ON SOME
OF THEIR COMMITMENTS ON CLEAN UP
AND SO I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT
ARE.
YOUR BACKUP PLAN IS --
OR WHAT SORT OF SUPPLEMENTAL
ROLE YOU SEE THIS STATE TAKING
DEPENDING ON HOW THE FEDS.
IN.
THE CAR PURSUING THEIR
COMMITMENT OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW
WE'RE GONNA BE HOPING THAT.
WE ENFORCE THE THE EXISTING
AGREEMENTS THAT WE'VE GOT WITH
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
BUT ULTIMATELY WE'VE GOT TO GET
CONGRESS TO MAKE SOME
APPROPRIATIONS SOME JUST CAN YOU
GIVE SOME GENERAL FEEDBACK TO
FROM A BUDGET PERSPECTIVE.
HOW TO I WORRY ABOUT THE
STALLING?
TACTICS AND SORT OF HOW LONG
THEY'RE GOING TO DRAG THIS OUT
IF WE WILL HAVE TO WAIT FOREVER
IS THERE A WAY TO GET THINGS
STARTED NOW IN THE SAME WAY
YOU'RE SORT OF LOOKING AT
EXCITED WE HAVE A TRICKY SAID OF
LIABILITIES AND MAYBE SOME FOLKS
WHO ARE.
KNOWN AND SOME WHO DON'T WANT TO
BE PARTNERS.
HE THOUGHT ABOUT.
THE STRATEGY ON THAT THAT FRONT
I I I WOULD I WOULD SAY THAT
FIRST OF ALL THE DEPARTMENT IS
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT WERE
HOLDING ALL RESPONSIBLE PARTIES.
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE A A CITIES --
AND WE ARE LOOKING AT STRATEGIES --
TO ACCELERATE AND THAT PROCESS
AT THIS TIME AND AND I AM NOT
PREPARED TO DISCUSS THE SPECIFIC
STRATEGIES BUT THOSE DISCUSSIONS
ARE UNDER WAY.
AND WITH THAT WILL JUMP RIGHT
INTO ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN THIS
IS INCREASE EXIDE RESIDENTIAL
CLEAN UP TWENTY FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION FROM GENERAL FUNDS TO
THE TOXIC.
SUBSTANCE CONTROL ACT FUN.
FOR VARIETY OF THINGS PLEASE GO
AHEAD WITH YOUR PERMISSION
CHAIRED LIKE TO ADDRESS ON BOTH
ISSUE SIMULTANEOUSLY --
RIGHT THEN LET'S CALL THEY'RE
BOTH ABOUT AND EXCITED THE
EXCITED PROJECT RIGHT OKAY LET'S
CALL ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN
ACCELERATION OF ADDITIONAL CLEAN
UP.
BRICKS I TECHNOLOGY AND WE'LL
TAKE A THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
TO KEEP FOURTH OPEN SO.
LET'S TAKEN TOGETHER ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WELL WE'RE HERE TODAY TO TO TALK
ABOUT -- THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
ACCELERATE THE CLEANUP OF
PROPERTIES INCLUDING RESIDENCES
SCHOOLS DAY CARE CENTERS PARKS
AND CHILD CARE FACILITIES
SURROUNDING THE NOW SHUTTERED
EXIDE LEAD ACID BATTERY
RECYCLING PLANT.
INSTEAD OF CLEANING UP TO TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED PROPERTIES BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO CLEAN
UP TO THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
PROPERTIES.
THIS BUILDS ON THE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS THE DTS SEE IS MADE
OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS ON THE
PROJECT.
THE STATUS OF THE CLEAN UP IS
THAT WE ARE CONTINUING TO CLEAN
UP RESIDENTIAL PARCELS WITH TO
CONTRACTORS.
AS OF MAY FIFTEENTH A TOTAL OF
SIX EIGHTY NINE PARCELS HAVE
BEEN CLEANED UP. FOUR HUNDRED
NINETEEN PARCELS ARE IN THE
CLEAN UP QUEUE WHICH MEANS
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH THE PRETTY
CLEAN UP PROCESS IN PREPARATION
FOR EXCAVATION AND BACK FELL ON
LAND AND LANDSCAPING.
CURRENTLY HAVE TWENTY FIVE CREWS
IN THE FIELD.
RELATED TO PARKWAY INVESTIGATION
AND CLEANUP WITH THE SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION RECEIVED IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT D.
TSC IS ENTERED INTO THE CONTRACT
TO CONDUCT.
THE PARKWAY INVESTIGATION WITH
DTS SEE OVERSIGHT WE EXPECT THE
CONTRACTOR TO SUBMIT A DRAFT
WRITTEN REPORT BY APRIL TWENTY
NINETEEN NEXT MONTH.
ADDITIONALLY THE TSC MET WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DISCUSS THE
PARKWAY SOIL SAMPLING STRATEGY
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND PEOPLE IN NEARBY COMMUNITIES.
AS WE IMPLEMENT THE
INVESTIGATION.
PTSD IS UNDERTAKEN SEVERAL
EFFORTS TO ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY TO MEMBERS OF
THE IMPACT TO COMMUNITIES.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED AN ADVISORY
GROUP CONSISTING OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THESE MEETINGS ARE HELD
THREE TIMES PER YEAR.
IN ADDITION DTC HOLD PUBLIC
MEETINGS FOUR TIMES PER YEAR
THESE MEETINGS PROVIDE
INTERESTED PARTIES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE CLEAN UP EFFORTS.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE OPENED A
FACILITY A FIELD OFFICE IN
COMMERCE TO HELP BUILD COMMUNITY
PRESENCE AND OFFER BETTER OUT
REACH.
THROUGH ITS OFFICE OF PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION DO TSC REGULARLY
CAMPUSES NEIGHBORHOODS TO SECURE
ACCESS AGREEMENTS TO OBTAIN SOIL
SAMPLES AND CLEAN UP PROPERTIES
WHICH FURTHER ASSISTS WITH
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
WE ALSO USE OTHER MEANS FOR
COMMUNICATING WITH THE IMPACT TO
COMMUNITIES WE RELEASE A BI
MONTHLY REPORT ON CLEAN IMPACT
CLEAN UP ACTIVITIES.
IN ADDITION WE'VE ESTABLISHED A
HOTLINE WHERE COMMUNITY MEMBERS
CAN CALL AND INQUIRE ABOUT OUR
CLEAN UP ACTIVITIES.
FINALLY WE REGULARLY UPDATE OUR
WEBSITE AND DISTRIBUTE A
NEWSLETTER TO INTERESTED PARTIES
BOTH WHICH INCLUDE INFORMATION
ON A VARIETY OF TOPICS INCLUDED
INCLUDING DATA COLLECTION
PROPERTIES CLEANED AND SAMPLING
STATUS.
OUR WEBSITE INCLUDES AN
INTERACTIVE INTERACTIVE MAPS
THAT ARE SEARCHABLE BY ADDRESS
SOME PARCEL AND UPDATED MONTHLY
TO SHOW CLEAN UP PROGRESS.
THE PROPOSED A AN BUDGET
PROPOSALS --
TOTALING SEVENTY FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION WILL ALLOW US TO CLEAN
UP TO APPROXIMATELY THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED PROPERTIES.
THE FIRST A TWENTY FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL IS
TO COVER INCREASED COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CLEAN UP OF
THE FIRST TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
PARCELS PRIORITIZED IN THE
CLEANUP PLAN.
THIS IS A LOAN FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO TOSCA AND AUGMENTS A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLAR LOAN
AUTHORIZED IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE INCREASED.
COVERED BY THIS MOON ARE DUE TO
UNKNOWN FACTORS ABOUT THE SCOPE
AND NATURE OF THE CONTAMINATION
IN THE COMMUNITY SURROUNDING
EXIDE AND THE ASSOCIATED COSTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE AMOUNT WILL
COVER COSTS THE ORIGINAL
ESTIMATE DIDN'T DID NOT INCLUDE
SUCH AS A QUALITY ASSURANCE
OVERSIGHT CONTRACTOR SAMPLE
STORAGE COSTS PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT AND PERFORMANCE AND
PAYMENT BONDS.
THE GOVERNOR IS ALSO PROPOSING
AN ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN MILLION
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT WILL
ALLOW FOR THE CLEANUP OF UP TO
SEVEN HUNDRED ADDITIONAL PARCELS.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS WILL ENABLE
THE TSC TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF CLEAN UP CREWS FROM TWENTY
FIVE TO THIRTY PER WEEK ON
AVERAGE.
THESE ESTIMATES ARE BASED ON
INFORMATION WE'VE GATHERED ON
THE COST OF THE PROPERTIES CLEAN
TO DATE HOWEVER SHOULD THESE
ASSUMPTIONS CHANGE THE NUMBER OF
PROPERTIES REMEDIATED WILL ALSO
BE SUBJECT TO CHANGE.
THE TSC ESTIMATE TO COMPLETE
THESE CLEANUPS BY DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ALTHOUGH WHETHER
SCHEDULING WITH RESIDENTS
HOLIDAYS AND OTHER FACTORS CAN
AFFECT THOSE TIME LINES.
WE APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORTED DTS HE'S EFFORT TO
ADDRESS THE SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPACT OF LEAD
CONTAMINATION IN THE COMMUNITY
SURROUNDING THE EXITE
TECHNOLOGIES FACILITY.
AND TO MEET OUR COMMITMENT TO
CLEAN UP THE MOST CONTAMINATED
PROPERTY IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
WE UNDERSTAND THE LA OWES OFFICE
HAS SUGGESTED SOME QUESTIONS AND
WE ARE PREPARED TO RESPOND TO
THOSE QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME AND
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE RELATED TO THE EXITE
PROJECT.
SO ALL ALL START OFF WITH THE
FIRST QUESTION --
WINDOWS DGSE ANTICIPATE IT WILL
COMPLETE THE SAMPLING OF THE TEN
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THREE PARCELS WITHIN THE BE I A
AND THE CLEANUP OF PARCELS
CONTAMINATED BY LEAD --
THERE ARE BE I A STANDS FOR THE
PRELIMINARY INVESTIGATION AREA
THE PROJECT AREA.
THE THERE ARE TEN THOUSAND HAN
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
PARCELS IN TOTAL --
WE HAVE AS OF MARCH FIFTEENTH
OUR COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT STAFF
HAS.
ENGAGED WITH EACH OF THESE
PARCELS I NEVER SEVEN TIMES.
FROM KNOCKING ON THE DOORS TO
SENDING FLYERS TO LEAVING
MATERIALS ON THEIR DOORSTEPS TO
WRITING LETTERS.
AND WE HAVE SIMPLE EIGHT
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO PARCELS.
OF WE WE SWITCHED FROM STOPPED
HERE.
WE'VE CREATE A FUN OF A HUNDRED
NINETY SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
YOU'VE KNOCKED ON DOORS OF
FIFTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE IN VERNON
AND THEY HAPPENED WITH THE BEEN
TOTALLY UNRESPONSIVE.
YOU'VE GOT EIGHTY FIVE HE SAID
TEN THOUSAND SOMETHING AND IN
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED SO YOU'VE.
HAD SEVEN CONTACTS WITH ALL
THESE PEOPLE AND THEY HAVE BEEN
UNRESPONSIVE. TO THE AGENCY
ABOUT THE CLEAN UP ABOUT SIXTEEN
HUNDRED PARCELS REMAIN
UNRESPONSIVE [inaudible]
SO.
WHAT DOES ONE DO TRESPASS ON THE
PROPERTY AND PICK UP SOME SOIL?
TO TO DETERMINE IF THEY'RE
CONTAMINATED OR NOT OR LOOK AT
THE NEIGHBORS AND SEE WHAT THIS
GUY'S CONTAMINATED SHE'S
CONTAMINATED.
WE WE WOULDN'T THAT BE --
EASY THEN TO FINISH THE PROJECT
OUT AND WE DID WE DO NEED ACCESS
AGREEMENT TO A TO ENCROACH UPON
ANY PROPERTY TO COLLECT EVEN
COLLECTS SAMPLES.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE THE DEPARTMENT
HAS TAKEN ACTIONS IS THAT WHEN
WE SAW THAT WE WERE NOT
COMMUNICATING.
WITH -- WITH
THAT SOME OF THE PARCELS WE
LOOKED AT WHAT WHAT MIGHT BE THE
REASONS.
WE FOUND OUT THAT THE OWNERS ARE
NOT STAYING THERE THE RESIDENTS
ARE STAYING THERE SO WE CHANGED
OUR AXES AGREEMENT. TO ALLOW
RESIDENTS RAN TO NEXUS AGREEMENT
SO WE COULD SAMPLE WE ALSO
STARTED WORKING WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
FOR THEM TO DISTRIBUTE OUR
MATERIALS AND FOR THEM TO HELP
US -- GET
THESE HOMERS TO WORK WITH US.
THE LA COUNTY HAS BEGAN WORKING
IN THIS OP PROJECT AREA DOING
LEAD BASED PAINT ABATEMENT --
AND WE ARE ON A MONTHLY BASIS WE
ARE SHARING LISTS WITH THEM TO
SAY THESE LIST THESE PARCELS
STILL REMAIN.
OUT OF OUR OUR PROJECT FOLD AND
AND THEY ARE DISTRIBUTING SO WE
ARE CONTINUING TO ENGAGE WITH
THESE.
FOLKS WE ARE HOSTING MEETINGS IN
THE COMMUNITIES TO ENGAGE AND
EXPLAIN WHAT THE PROJECT IS
ABOUT AND WHAT SAMPLING DOT.
AND WE ALSO I WOULD JUST WANT TO
ADD WE ALSO --
EXPECT THAT AS WE CONTINUE TO
CLEAN UP AND MORE MORE PEOPLE
SEE THE RESULTS OF THE CLEAN UP
THAT WE MAY.
BE ABLE TO OBTAIN SOME ACCESS
AGREEMENTS JUST THROUGH WORD OF
MOUTH AND THE VISUAL --
YOU KNOW THAT THAT.
THE RESULTS OF THE CLEANUP
ITSELF I MEAN I BELIEVE I WAS AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN I WHEN I
HADN'T OVERSIGHT HEARING.
OF THE EXCISE NO I WAS IN THE
SENATE IT'S FOUR YEARS AGO.
THIS IS --
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIFTEEN OKAY
WE'RE GONNA PAY ATTENTION TO
THAT BECAUSE WE'RE THE GOOD GUYS
AND WE GIVE THE MONEY TO CLEAN
IT UP.
YOU KNOW.
I'M GLAD TO HEAR TO GIVE CHANGE
AGREEMENT WITH WITH RENTER'S BUT
THIS IS.
YOU KNOW I'M GONNA HERE.
I DON'T WANT TO SPEND A BUNCH OF
TIME TALKING TO PEOPLE I WANT
THE MONEY TO BE SPENT TO DO TO
REMEDIATE REMEDIATION I
UNDERSTAND THAT FOLKS LIKE TO
HAVE THINGS EXPLAINED I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT CONTAMINATION OF OF
LEAD AND I'M SITTING HERE.
ON THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE
JUST FIX IT.
RIGHT IT AT SOMETIME WE GOT A
STOP EXPLAINING TO EVERYBODY AND
SAY WE COULD FIX IT.
AT FOUR BUT WE'RE NOT GONNA FIX
IT.
PLEASE CONTINUE WITH YOUR REPORT.
I'M SO AS AS A CHIEF NEGRI
ALREADY MENTIONED.
WE ARE AT WE EXPECT THAT WE'LL
SEE SOME --
PEOPLE FOLD COMING TO THE FOLD
WHEN THEY SEE THEIR NEIGHBOR'S
YARD GETTING CLEANED OR
OWNERSHIP CHANGES OR RENTER I'D
CHANGES --
AND WE'LL GO AS THEY SIGN AN
AXIS AGREEMENT.
THE SECOND PART OF THE QUESTION
WAS DEALING WITH THE CLEAN UPS --
EDS YES CLEAN UP SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE PARCELS --
IN THE PROJECT AREA AS OF MARCH
FIFTEEN WITH TO CONTRACTORS --
CONDUCTING THESE CLEANUPS --
AS AS SHE MENTIONED EARLIER --
DDS HE WILL ALSO IS ALSO IN THE
PROCESS OF SECURING AN
ADDITIONAL CLEANUP CONTRACT. TO
ADDRESS PARCELS THAT OUR
PUBLICLY OWNED PROPERTIES AND
CERTAIN LARGER PROPERTIES --
THAT HAVE SPECIAL REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS --
AND DGSE ANTICIPATES THIS
CONTRACT WILL BE IN PLACE IN AT
THIS SUMMER.
I DID YES HE ANTICIPATES THAT
WITH THE PROPOSED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING --
THIS THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION.
DGSE WILL CLEAN UP THIRTY TWO
HOW I A BY DECEMBER.
TWENTY TWENTY APPROXIMATELY
FORTY FOUR HUNDRED PARCELS.
ARE A AND AND THE TWENTY I'M
SORRY I'M GONNA SAY THIS AGAIN
THE THIRTY TWO HUNDRED PARCELS.
OF WILL CLEAN UP.
OF PARCELS THAT HAVE LEAD
CONTAMINATION OF REPRESENTATIVE
SOIL LEAD CONTAMINATION OF THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE PARTS
PER MILLION.
ARE THE EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED UP
PLUS PARCELS THAT WE HAVE
SAMPLED. FORTY FOUR ADDITIONAL
FORTY FOUR HUNDRED ADDITIONAL
PARCELS ARE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE SOIL LEAD
CONCENTRATIONS BELOW THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY AT THIRTY
THREE PARTS PER MILLION.
BUT ABOUT EIGHTY PARTS PER
MILLION WHICH IS DTS THESE
TARGET GLEE CLEAN UP GOAL.
THESE FORTY FOUR HUNDRED OUR
PARCELS WILL NOT BE CLEANED UP
DURING THIS PHASE THAT ARE TO BE
ENDING IN DECEMBER.
TWENTY TWENTY PUBLICLY UNIONS
AND SPECIAL SPECIALLY REGULATED
HOUSE SPEAKER OF SIZE OF A GROUP
OF PARCELS IS THAT THERE'S
HUNDRED AND FORTY PARCELS IN
THAT GROUP.
AND THAT CONTRACT IS GOING TO
TAKE CARE OF ALL OF THAT SORT OF
ALL A CART CLEAN UP.
YES IF I COULD USE THAT TERM
[inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
FINANCE.
I SEE IN.
ISSUE NUMBER. FOURTEEN WE'RE
ASKING FOR FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME FUND FOR THE AT
TOXIC SUBSTANCE ACT ALONE.
AND THEN ON ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTEEN PAYMENTS FROM THE LEAD
ACID BATTERY CLEAN OF FUN OF
SIXTEEN POINT SEVEN MILLION --
TO PAY BACK THE THE BIG LOAN
DEBT.
THAT WE HAVE.
I WAS BANKRUPTCY LAWYER WHERE WE
BORROWING MONEY AND PAYING BACK
MONEY IF WE STILL HAVE.
THE IF WE ARE FOR STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF DOING THE CLEAN UP.
THE REMEDIATION AND IT'S A
APPARENTLY GROWING [inaudible]
ALTHOUGH.
I WAS THE DEBTORS ATTORNEYS SO I
ALWAYS LIKE TO BE PAID BACK BUT
WILL.
FINISH THE JOB I GUESS IS THE
QUESTION.
WHY IS THAT [inaudible]
THERE.
WHEN THE WHEN THE LEAD ACID
BATTERY FUND THIS IS AN
ALLOWABLE USE OF THE LEAD ACID
BATTERY FUNNY SPECIFICALLY
STATED IN THE STATUTORY --
LANGUAGE [inaudible]
AND THAT THIS IS AGAIN ALL POINT
IN TIME AT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE THE LEAD
ACID BATTERY FUND ALSO WAS ONE
ONE OF THE FUNDS THAT HADN'T
BEEN [inaudible]
RECONCILED.
TOTALLY BETWEEN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
AND SO THAT THAT AND THAT
INCLUDED THE ENTIRETY OF IT.
AND THESE WERE THINGS THAT WE
HAD --
PROPOSED EARLIER.
SO AGAIN THESE ARE ALL THIS IS
ALL PART OF GOING BACK AND
LOOKING --
AND THEN COMING IN COMING IN
AGAIN IN THE SPRING THREE VISIT
ALL OF THIS [inaudible]
JOINT [inaudible]
YES.
IT IS IT IS IT MY MISREADING IS
ANOTHER. SIXTEEN SEVEN MILLION
IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY YEAH FOR AS IT
AS IT IS DISPLAYED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET YES THAT IS
CORRECT.
WE'RE PAYING BACK ONE LINE WERE
ASKING FOR AN EXTENSION OF
ANOTHER.
ONE RIGHT WHEN WE WERE ASKING
FOR DIFFERENT EDITION ALL
ADDITIONAL MONEY CORRECT THIS
AND THAT AND THIS SPEAKS.
TO THE THE NATURE OF THE THE
PROJECT ITSELF AND WE WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY WE WANT TO ACCELERATE.
WITH THE ANTICIPATION AT SOME
POINT EXIDE WILL BEGIN.
REIMBURSING THE STATE.
OF THE LEAD ACID BATTERY ALL.
IN AND OF ITSELF.
IS NOT IN A POSITION TO BE DOING
THESE LARGE CHUNKS --
WE COULD.
I MEAN THAT IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DISCUSS IF.
IF THE NEW.
IF THERE IS A DESIRE TO DO THE
DIRECT EXPENDITURE JUST OUT OF
THE LEAD ACID BATTERY FUND.
BUT THEN THAT WOULD POTENTIALLY
SLOW DOWN.
THE THE CLEAN UP EFFORTS AND AT
THIS POINT I THINK WE WANTED TO
MAINTAIN THE THE KEEP THE
MOMENTUM GOING.
FROM THE FIRST LOAN AND THEN
THIS ONE WOULD.
PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY IS THAT IS THAT IT.
IS A FUN I I THINK BECAUSE THAT
WE'VE ALREADY ESTABLISHED THAT
WAS THE FUN THAT WE TRANSFER THE
FIRST BIG MONEY AND YEAH.
SO WHILE WE'RE AT IT WHAT'S THE
UPDATE ON THE EXCITED BANKRUPTCY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE THE SITE IS
IN BANKRUPTCY THEY SHOULD HAVE A
PLAN OF REORGANIZATION I KNOW WE
GOT ASSURANCES FROM THE MOTHER.
EXCITED THAT THEY WOULD MAKE
GOOD ON ANYTHING SHORTFALL WHAT
IS THE THE DEBTOR IN POSSESSION
WHAT'S THE STATUS OF THAT.
SO THEY THEY CAME OUT OF
BANKRUPTCY THEY REORGANIZED AND
THEY ARE ON THEY ARE WORKING
WITH US ON DOING THE ON SITE --
CORRECTIVE ACTION INVESTIGATIONS
THEY'RE ALSO WORKING ON CLOSING
THE FACILITY. FOR IT.
I ATE THE SOUL.
THERE IS NO BANKRUPTCY ON ON THE
HORIZON BUT THAT.
THAT IS JUST A CONCERN BECAUSE
THEY'VE DONE IT BEFORE SO THE
PROCESS THAT THAT THAT WE'RE
FRONTING THE MONEY FOR THE CLEAN
UP THEY'RE GOING TO REPAY THIS
LOAN THAT WOULD JUST BE IN IN
THE NORMAL COURSE OF BUSINESS.
FOR ANY LARGE.
A CORPORATION RIGHT SO WE'VE WE
SUBMIT.
BILLS TO THEM.
ON THE ON THE STATUS OF THE THE
CLEAN UP --
ON THE ON THE CLOSURE OF THE
FACILITY WE DO SEND THEM
INVOICES FOR THE ARE OVERSIGHT
AND THE WORK THAT WE ARE DOING
IN IN MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
DOING THAT WORK.
ON THE RESIDENTIAL SIDE THERE IS
A PROCESS THE REASON THE STATE
STEPPED IN IS THAT WE FOUND THIS
IS A LARGE PROBLEM.
IN FACT A LOT OF FAMILIES.
AND WE STARTED THE WORK BECAUSE
WORKING WITH EXCITED WILL TAKE.
TEN YEARS HAD PASSED A TO GET
THERE THEY HAVE SUBMITTED A
REQUEST FACILITY INVESTIGATION
REPORT.
ODD THAT WE ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF REVIEWING AND AND RIVER A
RESPONDING TO THEM BUT THE
COMMENTS.
AFTER THAT THEY'LL PREPARE A
CORRECTIVE MEASURES STUDY WILL
SELECT THE REMEDY AND THEN THEY
WILL GET TO DOING IT IN THIS%
CASE WE HAVE STARTED
IMPLEMENTING THE REMEDY
SO WE EXPECT THEM TO PICK IT UP
BUT THAT IS WAYS AWAY I GUESS I
SHOULD HAVE BEEN MORE CLEAR I A
C. THE RESIDENTIAL SPOTS THE
ACTUAL CLEAN UP IN THE
DECOMMISSIONING OF THE FACILITY
THAT THEY HAVE.
I GUESS MAYBE THAT'S THE BETTER
QUESTION IS THERE THEY'RE TAKING
APART [inaudible]
THE PLACE.
THE FACILITY AND DOING SOME
REMEDIATION AND SOME CLEAN UP
THERE TO HAVE A UPDATE ON THAT --
BECAUSE THAT'S A SOURCE OF X.
BANDED CONTAMINATION RIGHT IF
IT'S THERE AND IT'S SPREADING.
ASSEMBLY THAT WAS THE SCIENCE
BEHIND IT RIGHT SO THE FACILITY
ITSELF --
WHEN THE PERMIT WAS DENIED THE
SUBMITTED A CLOSURE PLAN WHICH
WAS APPROVED WITH THE
ACCOMPANYING ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT PORTS ARE?
CLOSURE IMPLEMENTATION BEGAN
NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
IT'S ARE THE PHASE ONE IS
DECONTAMINATION I DEMOLITION AND
DISPOSAL.
OF ALL OF THE ABOVE GROUND
STRUCTURES THAT WERE USED IN
HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT OUR
ON SITE.
ARE BEING I TAKE IN I DOWN THE
THERE IS --
TWENTY TWO OUT OF THE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY UNITS THAT HAVE BEEN
CLEANED UP AS OF LAST MONTH.
ARE THERE IS A OF OVERSIGHT FROM
DTS SEE WE ALSO HAVE A THIRD
PARTY QUALITY ASSURANCE.
CONSULTANT THAT IS OVERSEEING
EXIDE.
EXCITE IS DOING THIS WITH THEIR
OPERATIONS.
THERE IS A FINAL SURE CERN'S BUT
EXCITE IS DOING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CLOSURE OUT OF
THEIR OPERATING FUNDS.
ARE THEY ARE NOT.
ALLOWED UNDER THE AGREEMENT THAT
THEY HAVE REIMBURSED FOR THAT
MONEY SO WE HAVE --
THAT IN PROGRESS.
ASIDE FROM THE FACILITY ITSELF.
THERE IS THE INVESTIGATION OF
LEGACY CONTAMINATION FROM ANY
ACTIVITIES ON SITE OF FROM SIDE
TO SIDE THE ENTIRE BOUNDARY.
ARE AND DAD INVESTIGATION IS IN
PROCESS WE ARE THEY SUBMITTED A
REQUIRE FACILITY INVESTIGATION
REPORT.
THE ALSO SUBMITTED A CORRECTIVE
MEASURES STUDY BUT WE HAVE FOUND
DATA GAPS WERE WORKING WITH THEM
ON THAT.
WE ASK THEM TO FOLLOW THEIR
CONTAMINATION THEY WENT INTO THE
NEIGHBORING INDUSTRIAL AREA.
THEY HAVE INVEST.
A SAMPLED ABOUT FIFTY PROPERTIES
FIFTY TWO PROPERTIES THAT ARE
INDUSTRIAL BUSINESSES ARE AND
THERE ARE SOME PROPERTIES THAT
REQUIRED SECOND SET OF SAMPLING.
THOSE RESULTS ARE BEING REVIEWED --
THERE IS A WORK PLAN --
THAT IS BEING REVIEWED AND THERE
WOULD THAT INDUSTRIAL ROUTE --
CORRECTIVE ACTION WILL ALSO GO
THROUGH THE THEM SUBMITTING A
FACILITY RECALL FACILITY
INVESTIGATION REPORT.
CORRECTIVE MEASURES STUDY AND A
RE IT IS UNDER WAY AND THEN THE
THIRD THING IS THE RESIDENTIAL.
CORRECTIVE ACTION WHICH WE
FOLLOW THE LEAD.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE ARE TALKING
BY THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
FORGET AND I'M REMINDED THAT
EXCITED ACTUALLY ONLY OPERATE
THE SITE FOR FIFTEEN YEARS.
SOME OF THAT LEGACY
CONTAMINATION WAS PREVIOUS
OWNERS THAT OPERATE AT THAT SITE
DOING.
RECYCLING AND AND OTHER
ACTIVITIES I KNOW I KNOW THERE
THAT THE FACE TO THE PUBLIC OF
ALL EVERYTHING THAT IS EVIL BUT
THEY WERE ACTUALLY ONLY THERE
WHEN THEY GOT THE SITE IT WAS
PLENTY CONTAMINATION.
IN PEOPLE'S HOUSES WERE PLENTY
CONTAMINATED BEFORE THEY BECAME
THE OPERATOR SO I'D.
HOPEFULLY THAT'S IN YOUR
BROCHURE TO THE PUBLIC AS THEY
ARE.
ALL MAD.
YES AND WE WE WE ARE IN EVERY
REPORT THAT WE PUT OUT THEY PUT
OUT THEY ALSO PUT THAT IN THERE
THAT THE FACILITY HAS BEEN IN
EXISTENCE SINCE NINETEEN TWENTY
TWO EXIDE ACQUIRED IT. TWO
THOUSAND THE SECOND QUESTION
THAT THE LA --
HAD FEWER WE GOT TO THE FIRST
[inaudible]
ONE YES.
I'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE THE
ANSWER TO THAT AND I I WANT TO I
WANT TO JUST AND ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WE'VE --
STRUGGLED WITH --
COMING UP WITH A NUMBER ON THIS
NOT BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO BE
TRANSPARENT BUT BECAUSE THERE
ARE SO MANY CONTINGENCIES
RELATED TO IDENTIFYING AND THE
TOTAL COST OF CLEAN UP.
THAT RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES BUT
I'M GOING TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A
RESPONSE THAT'S BASED ON THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE TO DATE
AND I LOOK FORWARD.
TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
UPDATES TO THIS INFORMATION AS
WE CONTINUE TO CLEAN UP AND
GATHER ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
SO ASSUMING THE ADDITIONAL
SEVENTY FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
IS APPROVED --
AS AND MISS PATEL INDICATED HAVE
ESTIMATED THAT ALL PARCELS OUT.
MORE ABOVE THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE PER BE CLEANED UP
USING THE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX POINT SIX MILLION AND THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION PROPOSED.
THE APPROXIMATELY OF THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY FORTY FOUR HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL PROPERTIES THAT HAVE
BEEN SAMPLED TO DATE.
THAT HAVE REPRESENTATIVE SOIL
LEAD CONCENTRATIONS OF BELOW
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
PARTS PER MILLION BUT ABOVE DTS
SEES. EIGHTY PARTSPER MILLION
TARGET CLEANUP GOAL.
AND THE COST TO CLEAN UP THIS
REMAINING FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR HUNDRED PARCELS ARE
DIFFICULT TO FORECAST BECAUSE
THE EXTENT OF THE CONTAMINATION
IS UNKNOWN --
AND CONSTRUCTION COSTS ME
CONTINUE TO INFLATE --
AS THEY HAVE OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS COULD PUT ME
INTO IS WE ATE WE HERE'S THE
EXCITES SITE IS HERE YES YOU'VE
DONE THE CLOSEST PROPERTIES NOW
YOU'RE OUT I'M A MILE.
POINT.
SEVEN COMMON SENSE TELLS ME IT'S
MAY BE WRONG BUT COMMON SENSE
TELLS ME THAT THE ONE RIGHT
ACROSS THE STREET FROM EXCITED
IS COULD BE MORE CONTAMINATED
THAN THE LAST HOUSE THAT MAY GO
ABOVE. THIRTY THREE WHATEVER
THAT THAT THE MEASURE OF LIES.
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
PARTS PER MILLION AM I WRONG ON
THAT.
AS FAR AS TO SAY IF YOU IF YOU
CAN GET ON TO THE PROPERTY CITY
THE SAMPLING [inaudible]
SO.
SO YOU WERE RIGHT.
YOU ANTICIPATE THAT IF YOU HAVE
A SOURCE AND YOU SEE DISPERSION
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE IT
DIMINISHING WITH THE DISTANCE.
THAT IS NOT THE CASE ODD WE HAVE
LOOKED ACT WE'VE BEEN SAMPLING
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN WE
MADE EXCITES SAMPLE THE FIRST
TWO HUNDRED PROPERTIES.
IN THE NORTH AND THE SOUTH AND
WE ASK THEM TO FOLLOW THE
PREDOMINANT WIND DIRECTION.
AND AND EVEN THEN WE FOUND IN
THE CLOSEST PROPERTIES WE FOUND.
DIFFERENCES IN CONCENTRATIONS
NOT ONLY WE ARE FOLLOWING
AERIALLY DEPOSITED LET.
DO YOU WOULD YOU EXPECT THAT NOT
ONLY WILL THE OUR CONCENTRATIONS
DIMINISH AS YOU ALL FARTHER AND
FARTHER AWAY BUT YOU SHOULD ALSO
SEE LESSER CONCENTRATIONS ARE
DEEPER DEPTHS.
WE SAMPLE DOWN TO EIGHTEEN
INCHES AND SINCE WEARING AT
DIFFERENT JOBS THERE IS NO
SIMPLE DISTRIBUTION THERE'S NO
SIMPLE PATTERN OF DISTRIBUTION.
AND THERE'S REASONS FOR IT.
IT MAY HAVE BEEN CHURNED IT MAY
HAVE BEEN RECONSTRUCTED RIEN
TRAINED TAKEN AWAY SOMEWHERE
ELSE AND WE'RE TALKING LEAD
THERE ARE MANY SOURCES OF BLOOD.
SO SOMEBODY COULD OF PUT IN
LANDSCAPE THEIR HOUSE DECIDED TO
TAKE OUT THE SOIL AND PUT THE
NEW SOIL IN YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
REDUCING THE LEAD THERE AND HAD
KNOWN.
WAS NO WISER FOR ALL RIGHT.
PLEASE CONTINUE WITH.
THOSE SERVICE ON MEETING THE
COST GOT A COUPLE OF OTHER
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS TO THE
DIFFICULTY IN ESTIMATING THE
COST IN THERE OF COURSE RELATED
TO WHAT WE STARTED OUT A
CONVERSATION WITH AND AND THAT
IS -- ACCESS
TO THE PROPERTIES THEMSELVES SO
WE ANTICIPATE GETTING ADDITIONAL
ACCESS AGREEMENTS TO SAMPLING
CLEAN UP THE ROUGHLY SIXTEEN
HUNDRED PROPERTIES THAT WE HAVE
YET SAMPLED --
BUT WE ADDITIONALLY AND OUT OF
THE EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED
PROPERTIES THAT WE'VE SAMPLE TO
DATE.
AGAIN -- WE
CHANGED OUR OUR ACCESS
AGREEMENTS TO ENABLE THE
RESIDENTS. TO TO PROVIDE ACCESS
TO SAMPLE BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE
THE PROPERTY OWNERS APPROVAL TO
ACTUALLY DO THE CLEANUP AND SO
THERE'S WE'LL CONTINUE TO IS TO
GET THAT ACCESS BUT THERE IS A
DELTA BETWEEN THE NUMBER OF
PROPERTY SAMPLED AND THOSE.
THAT HAVE PROVIDED US WITH AXIS
AGREEMENTS AND THAT ALL IMPACTS
THE TOTAL COST OF THE PROJECT.
ARE YOU CONSIDERING PUTTING A
LIEN ON THE PROPERTY FOR NOTICE.
IS THAT PART OF THE THE PLAN
BECAUSE YOU KNOW AT SOMETIME MY
PATIENCE IS DONE AND AND JUST
SAME IT'S IT'S WE WANT TO DO THE
RIGHT THING BUT IF WE PUT A LIEN
ON THE PROPERTY IN ANYBODY WHO'S
GONNA CHOIR THAT PROPERTY KNOWS.
WHAT A BIG RED SIGN ON THE FRONT
DOOR AND SAY THIS IS POTENTIALLY
CONTAMINATE WHATEVER IT IS BUT
BUT?
I WE HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES HERE
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE THERE'S A LOT
OF WORK TO DO YOU GOT A LOT MORE
WORK TO DO SO TO DO THE EASY
THINGS FIRST NOT THE EASY THINGS
FOR THE PEOPLE SAY YEP PLEASE
COME INTO MY PROPERTY I'LL SIGN
OFF.
WHEN DO A CLEAN UP --
OR OR YOU CAN CONTINUE TO
SAMPLING THERE'S THAT SOMEBODY
BODIES THAT THAT WE HAVE HERE
AND AT A AND I DON'T WANT TO
SPEND A LOT OF TIME.
YOU KNOW AT LEAST IT JUST SEEMS
LIKE EXTRA ORDINARY WE'RE
ALREADY VISIT YOU SEVEN TIMES
AND NOW WE'RE ON THE EIGHTH TIME
IN A NINE TIME AT SOMETIME LET'S
GO TO THE NEXT DOOR NEIGHBOR
JUST CLEAN THEIR PROPERTY BUT
PLEASE CONTINUE.
SO AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
COMMENT WE WE ARE --
PRIORITIZING ARE CLEAN UP WITH
THE PROPERTY OWNERS THAT ARE
WORKING WITH US AND WE HAVE AS
WE INDICATED FOUR HUNDRED
NINETEEN PROPERTIES IN THE QUEUE
WHERE THE PROPERTY OWNERS HAVE
GRANTED US ACCESS AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH THEM. TO TO GET
THEIR PROPERTIES CLEANED UP.
SO ARE AT UP ABOUT SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR PROPERTY --
BECAUSE OF THE DIFFERENCES IN
PROPERTY SIZE EXTENT OF
CONTAMINATION IN THE EXTENT TO
WHICH ADDITIONAL MANUAL LABOR
MAY BE REQUIRED TO CLEAN UP THE
PROPERTY.
ON THE RANGE CAN BE SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN. FIFTY TO FIFTY EIGHT
THOUSAND UPWARDS OF EIGHTY
THOUSAND SO OUR AVERAGE IS
AROUND --
SIXTY WITH THE ABOVE DESCRIBED
ASSUMPTIONS AND AND STAFF
OPERATING EXPENSES DTS THE
ESTIMATES IT WILL COST ROUGHLY
THREE HUNDRED MILLION TO CLEAN
UP THE REMAINING FORTY FOUR
HUNDRED PROPERTIES BUT JUST TO
BE CLEAR THIS DOES NOT INCLUDE
THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH
CLEANING UP.
THE APPROXIMATELY SIXTEEN
HUNDRED PROPERTIES THAT HAVE YET
TO BE SAMPLED.
SO BASED ON OUR DATA.
ABOUT SEVENTY SIX OR 77% OF THE
PROPERTY SAMPLE TO DATE HAVE
LEAD LEVELS ABOVE EIGHTY PARTS
PER MILLION.
IF WE WERE ABLE TO OBTAIN
SAMPLING AGREEMENTS FOR ALL
SIXTEEN SIXTEEN HUNDRED PARCELS
NOT YET SAMPLED --
AND WE ASSUME THAT 77% OF THESE
PROPERTIES HAVE LEAD LEVELS
ABOVE EIGHTY PARTS PER MILLION.
THE ADDITIONAL CLEANUP KARAKAS
RELATED WITH THOSE PROPERTIES
WOULD BE APPROXIMATELY NINETY
MILLION FOR A TOTAL ESTIMATED
COST OF THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY
MILLION IF WE WERE TO CLEAN UP
ALL PROPERTIES WITHIN THE P. I.
A THAT TEST --
OVER THE OUR TARGET CLEANUP CALL.
NOW THIS AREA HAS A LOT OF
INDUSTRY AND A LOT OF-CONTAMINATION.
AND I KNOW THAT IT'S POPULAR THE
THING I'M EXCITED HAVE YOU LOOK
AT THE SOURCE OF THESE OTHER
CONTAMINATIONS IF YOU'RE FARTHER
AWAY FROM EXCITE AND WE'VE GOT
THIS BIG.
LEAD CONTAMINATION IS IT
POSSIBLE THAT SOME OF THESE
OTHER INDUSTRIES ARE THERE.
ARE THERE HAVE ARE THE SOURCE OF
THE CONTAMINATION WHICH IS
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT SCIENTIFIC.
QUESTION IS EASY PEASY
EVERYTHING'S EXIDE BUT HAVING
THEM BE THE SOURCE AND I GUESS
MORALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PORSCHE THE PAYMENT THE
PORCELAIN OF THAT CLEAN UP.
THAT'S A THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
I WANT JUST TO BE CLEAR WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE AG'S OFFICE TO
HOLD ALL WERE SPONSORED WILL
PARTY'S ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE COST
OF THE CLEANUP.
LA -- YOUR
SENSE I'VE FOR THOSE ANSWERS.
JOHN MARTIN AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND WE FELT
THAT IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE A AN OVERALL
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE LIKELY
TOTAL COSTS OF THE SCREEN AFTER
GOING TO BE FOR FUTURE BUDGET
PLANNING PURPOSES.
AND I THINK THE DEPARTMENT HAS
PROVIDED THEIR BEST ESTIMATE OF
THOSE COSTS AS I ADDED IN MY IT
WAS --
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX POINT SIX
MILLION THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
APPROVED PLUS SEVENTY FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION WHICH BRINGS US TO
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
MILLION --
INCLUDING THE CURRENT BUDGET
REQUESTS AND THEN AN ADDITIONAL
POTENTIALLY.
THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY MILLION.
WHICH WOULD BRING THE TOTAL TO
SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS [inaudible]
OVERALL.
IN THE MORNING YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
WELL OUCH.
LET'S TAKE THAT SIX HUNDRED
FORTY UNIVERSAL NUMBER TO DO ALL
THE CLEAN UP.
HOW MUCH OF THAT IS AG SIDE?
COMMITTED TO WERE OBLIGATED
[inaudible]
TO WE NOW [inaudible]
SO.
AS I X. R. AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER ARE WE THEY ARE THEY
HAVE SUBMITTED THE FIRST REPORT
IN THE PROCESS WHICH IS THE
WRECKER FACILITY INVESTIGATION
REPORT.
I AND WE ARE REVIEWING IT WE'RE
GOING TO WHERE WE'RE GOING TO
COMMENT ON IT --
AND THERE IS WASTE TO GOAL
BEFORE THEY THEY WRITE ANY TAX
OR TELL US WHAT THEY'RE GONNA
PAY.
WE ARE WORKING HOWEVER WITH THE
TO NOT ONLY HOLD EXCITE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE AND WHAT THY HAVE
CONTRIBUTED BUT ALL OF THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES.
THIS IS A HEAVILY INDUSTRIAL --
AREAS -- AS
AS MISTER CHAIR MENTION.
AND SO WE ARE WE ARE GOING TO
HOLD OTHER RPGS.
ACCOUNTABLE BUT THIS IS A A
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
A CONVERSATION THAT I AM.
THAT THAT I CAN COUNT DISCUSS
HERE BUT WE ARE GOING AFTER ALL
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES.
THAT'S THE MONEY SIDE --
FROM THE PUBLIC HEALTH POINT AB
ONE REASON THE STATE HAS STEPPED
UP IS BECAUSE OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERN.
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE NUMBER
PROPERTY SIXTEEN HUNDRED
PROPERTIES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
SAMPLED.
OF THOSE HOW MANY.
ARE NOT OCCUPIED BY THE OWNERS
IN OTHER WORDS.
THERE'S A RESIDENT RENTER BUT A
LANDLORD WHO'S.
MISSING UP IS MISSING --
IT IS IT IS A GOOD MIX IT I I DO
NOT HAVE THE PERCENTAGE ON THE
TOP OF MY HEAD BUT IT IS A GOOD
MAKES THERE ARE --
RENTER'S THERE --
THEY ARE --
BECAUSE THEY'RE AFRAID OF THEIR
OWNERS THAT WAS MY QUESTION
BECAUSE YOU INDICATED.
YOU HAVE NOW.
RESIDENTS DO HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO ALLOW US TO SCHOOL NOW.
BUT NINE THAT WHAT IS THE FEAR
OF OF GOING AGAINST THE WISHES
OF A LANDLORD.
IS THERE ANYWAY TO THAT.
WE ARE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
IN LOS ANGELES COULD REQUIRED
LANDLORDS.
TO COMPLY FROM A PUBLIC.
HEALTH POINT OF VIEW PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY.
SO AT SO THIS IS THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT POINT TO YOUR MAKING A
THIS IS EXACTLY WHERE WE ARE
WORKING WITH LA COUNTY PUBLIC A
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THEY HAVE NURSES THAT GO OUT
PEOPLE ARE MORE WILLING TO TALK
TO PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES THEN DTS
SEE A PERSONNEL THAT COME AND
SAY WE ARE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
TOXIC.
I'M SO WE ARE WORKING WITH THEM
A TWO RELATED INFORMATION TO
EDUCATE THEM AND SEE IF THEY
WOULD THEY WOULD SIGN AND ALLOW
US ACCESS.
OF BUT IN ADDITION WE ALSO WORK
WITH LOCAL.
GOVERNMENTS SO WE WORK WITH CITY
GOVERNMENTS TO SEND OUT
INFORMATION AND AND INCLUDE THAT
IN EVERY CONVERSATION THEY HAVE.
WE ALSO PRESENTED CITY COUNCIL
SAW THE PEOPLE THAT ATTEND THOSE
COUNCIL.
MEETINGS WE PRESENT JUST THANK
YOU MY PLAN THE EFFORT TO THE
DEPARTMENT I DO --
IT IS A PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
AND YET IT'S TAKING YEARS AND
YOUNG CHILDREN THAT ARE.
PLAYING IN THOSE YARDS --
GO BACK IN REMOVE EXPOSURE IN
CONTAMINATION FROM A CHILD SO.
I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE IT
CONTINUES TO EXPLORE WITH LOCAL
AUTHORITIES AND MAYBE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SIR ANYWAY.
TO REQUIRE THE PROPERTY OWNERS
APART TO PARTICIPATE.
FINAL QUESTION ON THAT ANY
ESTIMATE OF HOW MANY OF THESE
RESIDENT FAMILIES SIR IMMIGRANT --
FAMILIES WHO MAY BE FEARFUL OF
SOMEBODY KNOCKING AT THE DOOR
[inaudible]
I'M.
WE HAVEN'T COLLECTED THAT SORT
OF INFORMATION OF THE DEPARTMENT
DOESN'T.
DO THAT KIND OF COLLECT DOESN'T
THAT KIND OF INFORMATION BUT I I
CAN SAY THIS THAT ALL OF MY
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT STAFF THAT
ARE DEDICATED TO THIS PROJECT.
ARE BILINGUAL AND THEY USE THEIR
SECOND LANGUAGE ALL THE TIME.
THANKS ANNA I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'RE YOU KNOW SOME OF OUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE
COMMUNITIES WE REPRESENT.
THEY OFFER EXPLICIT.
REASSURANCES TO FAMILIES WHO
MIGHT COOPERATE IN A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION THAT THERE WON'T
BE AN IMMIGRATION CONSEQUENCES
AND I DON'T KNOW IF.
THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE --
TOOL THAT COULD ALSO.
REDUCE CONCERN OR FEAR ABOUT
GRANTING --
THESE PERMISSIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. TOO MUCH
FOR THE CHURCH ONE A A WALK THE
NUMBERS IN THE MATH ONE MORE
TIME AND THEN HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS --
FOR THE DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS
FOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS A
THREE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED WELL
TO SAY THAT'S BROWN.
ONE RIGHT BECAUSE THEY WERE
LOOKING AT ANOTHER.
OVER FOUR THOUSAND AFTER CORRECT
THAT WOULD BE ROUND TWO GREATEST
[inaudible]
SO.
THE THIRTY TWO HUNDRED PARCELS
CAN YOU GIVE US ONE MORE TIME
THE OVERALL.
ANTICIPATED COSTS UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S NOT IN EXACT BUT WHAT
THE ANTICIPATED SO THAT THE THE
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED PARCELS WILL
BE CLEANED UP WITH THE ORIGINAL
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
BEFORE YOU FOR CONSIDERATION
WHICH INCLUDE TWENTY FOUR POINT.
FIVE MILLION AND AN ADDITIONAL
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
TOTAL OF SEVENTY FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR UP TO
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED PROPERTIES.
DISTANCE SO QUICK MANNER. FIFTY
ONE MILLION. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible] ONE SECOND
.
AND THEN THE OTHER. FOR FORTY
TWO HUNDRED YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
COME BACK ON THE OTHER THE
ADDITIONAL FORTY FOUR HUNDRED I
PROVIDED A ROUGH ESTIMATE.
OF THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
BASED ON AN AVERAGE COST PER
PROPERTY OF SIXTY MILLION PLUS
OPERATING EXPENSES AND AN
OVERSIGHT CONTRACTOR.
ARE WE SEEN.
THEIR PRICE PER PARCEL GO UP ARE
WE SEEN IT HOLDING STEADY
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU GIVE US A
RANGE.
OF APPROXIMATELY FIFTY EIGHT UP
TO EIGHTY DEPENDING ON THE
COMPLEXITY I WOULD ASSUME.
IN THIS.
HAS THAT BEEN HOLDING STEADY CAN
YOU GIVE SERVE DAY I CAN I CAN
TALK TO THAT --
SO.
THE COST AT THE WHEN WE SAY
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
PER PARCEL IS AN AVERAGE IT
DEPENDS ON THE SIZE OF THE
PARCEL THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
PARCEL AND THE DEATH BECAUSE WE
HAVE SAMPLED ALL THESE
PROPERTIES A SERVICE.
FOLLOWING THE AERIAL LEAD WE
WANTED TO GET IT DONE.
AS QUICK AS POSSIBLE.
SO WE WE HAVE PRIORITIZE ON THE
SURFACE CONCENTRATIONS BUT WHEN
WE CLEAN UP WE GO DOWN TO TWELVE
OR EIGHTEEN INCHES STEP.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT CONCENTRATION
UNTIL WE GET THERE.
OUGHT SO THE TOOL THAT IT'S
DEPENDENT ON THAT IT ALSO IS
DEPENDENT ON SOMETIMES CAESAR'S
MOPED PROPERTIES THESE
PROPERTIES ARE LAID OUT IN SUCH
A VERY COMPLEX CANNOT GO WITH
EQUIPMENT --
BUT MY MOM HAS IT FROM WHERE ARE
REGIONAL ESTIMATES WERE. TO
WHERE THEY'RE AT NOW.
HOUSE OF PLANO YEAH AND AND LET
ME JUST SAY THEY HAVE INCREASED
SOMEWHAT THE ORIGINAL COST
ESTIMATE THAT WAS DEVELOPED IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN WAS BASED ON
PROPERTIES THAT EXCITE CLEANED
UP.
THEY HAD DIFFERENT CONTRACTUAL
REQUIREMENTS IN THE STATE HOUSE --
THE COST OF CONSTRUCTION WAS
DIFFERENT AT THAT TIME AND WE
HAD OTHER --
THINGS THAT ATTRIBUTED TO THE
INCREASED COST PER PER PROPERTY
SO THEY HAVE GONE UP --
OUR OUR ESTIMATE THIS POINT OF
SIXTY IS AN AVERAGE AS MISS
PATEL INDICATED AND YOU KNOW --
YOU ASSUMING THAT YOU KNOW IT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE US UNTIL
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY TO
CLEAN UP THE UP TO THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED PROPERTIES BY THE TIME
WE GET TO THE FORTY FOUR HUNDRED
PROPERTIES WE WOULD NEED TO
REVISE THAT ESTIMATE BASED ON
THE INFORMATION WE HAVE AT THAT.
TIME BUT WE WANTED TO PROVIDE
THAT ESTIMATE TO YOU AND TO THE
LA -- ON
BASED ON THE LINE OF QUESTIONS
MORE INTO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO CAN YOU WALK US
THROUGH.
OBVIOUSLY THE TOP PRIORITY IS
THE SAFETY OF NEIGHBORS --
A AND CANNOT IMAGINE WHAT IT IS
LIKE LIVING IN A HOME RIGHT THAT
NEEDS TO BE CLEANED UP LIKE THIS --
AND BUT ALSO WALKING THROUGH HOW
YOU ARE LOOKING AT COSTS.
IN THE MANAGEMENT AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THIS AS FAR AS WHAT THE
BUDGET LOOKS LIKE.
THIS IS A VERY FLUID SITUATION
RIGHT.
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE --
AN IDEA OF WHERE WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO GO DEPENDING ON A LOT.
WHETHER IT'S SLOPED FLAT --
IF IT'S HOW DEEP THE
CONTAMINATION IS.
SO WHATWHAT IS THAT LOOK LIKE
WITHIN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
FAR AS TRYING TO MANAGE THAT
BUDGET JUST.
BECAUSE IT'S IT IS SO FLUID.
YES.
I APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTION AND
IT IT HAS BEEN CHALLENGING --
GIVEN.
ALL OF THE OTHER --
CHALLENGES THAT THAT DTS HE HAS
HAD.
ON THIS PROJECT.
WE'VE BEEN TRACKING IT CLOSELY
WITH.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
AND WHICH IS WHY WE'VE GOTTEN
THAT.
EXCUSE ME THE AUTHORITY IN THE
FOR THE ABILITY.
TO AYLER IT AND WE WOULD BE
COMING BACK IN FRONT OF THE
LEGISLATURE AGAIN IF IF THE COST
TO GO UP --
WE ARE AGAIN WHICH IS ANOTHER
REASON WHY WE BUILT IN ANOTHER
FIFTY MILLION WE ARE
CONCENTRATING ON THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THOSE RESIDENTS --
WE DON'T WANT TO JEOPARDIZE
THEIR HEALTH BECAUSE OF THE
BUREAUCRACY GOING ON WITH
FINDING THE RESPONSIBLE PARTIES
AND ACTUALLY GETTING BACK
FUNDING BACK FROM THEM WHICH IS
WHY WE'RE DOING THIS IS A LOAN.
AND THERE IS ALSO --
MY BELIEVE LANGUAGE IN THE
ORIGINAL.
THE ORIGINAL APPROPRIATION.
THAT -- THAT
THAT STATES [inaudible]
THAT.
IF NO RESPONSIBLE PARTIES ARE.
AVAILABLE THEN THAN IT IS A
STATE RESPONSIBILITY.
I'M NOT SURE IF THAT REALLY
FULLY ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION.
I GUESS WHAT I'M I'M SURE LOOK
AT ANYA GIVEN EXAMPLE SO --
WHERE I COME FROM THE COUNTY
CINEMA --
JAPANESE DECLARED ON A CREEK
THAT --
BRINGS WATER DOWN FROM WARM
SPRINGS DAM TO THE RUSSIAN RIVER.
I IT'S BECAUSE IT'S ENDANGERED
COHO HABITAT IN IT WE ARE HAVING
WE ARE BEING FORCED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RIGHTFULLY SO
TO BE A GREAT AUSTRIAN HABITAT.
I BRING THIS FORWARD BECAUSE IN
WHAT OUR ORIGINAL ESTIMATES WERE
TO BE TO DEVELOP WATER PER MILE
COSTA DE DEVELOP AT POSTURING
HABITAT.
WAS A LOT LOWER TO BE ABLE TO
DEVELOP A VERY SMALL DIVISION
WITHIN THE AGENCY THAT IS
MANAGING IT THE SOLELY FOCUSED
ON WHAT THE BUDGET LOOKS LIKE
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO CONTAIN --
THE INCREASED COSTS --
COMPLICATED CHALLENGES IN
REGARDS TO LAND DEAL LANDOWNERS
AND CANDIDLY ON LABOR AS WELL
RIGHT.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT WHAT
IS THAT WITHIN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BECAUSE THIS THIS HAS IN
A POTENTIAL.
I CANNOT IMAGINE THIS IS GOING
TO GO DOWN THIS IS ONLY GONNA GO
UP SO I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT
MECHANISMS ARE ARE.
TRYING TO BE A STAND TOP OF
WHERE WE'RE AT WITH THE BUDGET
BECAUSE IT'S IT'S ONLY GONNA
GROW I CAN ONLY IMAGINE.
THAT'S TRUE AND THAT'S WHY THE
ONLY THING THAT I CAN ASSURE YOU
IS THAT THAT FINANCE HAS BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH.
WITH DTS SEE NOT JUST ON THIS
PROJECT BUT HOLISTIC --
YEAH ABSOLUTELY NO THANK YOU AND
AGAIN OUR TOP PRIORITY OBVIOUSLY
IS ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH SIDE MY
LAST QUESTION --
IT TO FULL NUMBER --
ONE AS OF IN ANY THOUGHT OF
HIRING A NONPROFIT.
SO WHAT WE'VE HAD TO DO IN OUR
NECK OF THE WOODS IN CINEMA
CANYONS PROJECT.
NO ONE WANTS THE GOVERNMENT TO
BE ABLE TO COME SIT DOWN WITH
HIM IN THE KITCHEN IN TOWN THAT
WE ARE GOING.
TO BE CLEANING UP THE PROPERTY
BECAUSE WE WEREN'T ACTUALLY
BLINDERS ON WE'RE ONLY LOOKING
AT WHAT IS THEIR RIGHT AND
NOTHING ELSE.
I IN WHAT IS HELP TO
SIGNIFICANTLY IS BRINGING ON A
NON PROFIT. TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH US THE CONVERSATION
NEIGHBORS TO BE A TO GET THE
ACCESS LIABILITY.
AGAIN THE OFFENSE BUT DON'T WANT
TO DEAL WITH THE STATE RIGHT SO.
CAN YOU WALK US THROUGH THE YES
IS SO WE HAVE ENGAGED WITH A
LOCAL COMMUNITIES --
THE IN IN CANVASSING I EAST
YARDS --
COMMUNITIES.
DONE THAT WE ALSO HAVE INITIATED
WHICH WAS REQUIRED UNDER AB ONE
ONE EIGHT IS.
TO DEVELOP THE WORKS PROGRAM
WHICH IS.
A TRAINING LOCAL.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL RESTORATION WORK
AND THOSE PEOPLE THAT GO UNDER
THOSE GRADUATES OF THAT WORKS
PROGRAM ARE ALSO EMPLOYED AND
THEY ARE LOCAL.
THE PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT THAT
THAT THAT THE STATE HAS AGREED
UPON HAS TARGETED HIRING PROGRAM
AND IT HIRES ALL OF THE LOCALS.
THAT IS HELPING US.
WITH THAT SORT OF FIVE EIGHT
REACHING OUT TO THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THESE PEOPLE
AND HAVE YOU SEEN AN UPTICK OF
INDIVIDUALS WILLING TO BE ABLE.
TO GET INTO THE PROGRAM YES THIS
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED UP BOB
PROPERTIES THAT WE SAMPLED IN A
TIME SPAN OF EIGHTEEN MONTHS
THAT THAT DIRECTLY SPEAKS TO ALL
OF THAT.
IN MY LAST QUESTION IS --
HAS A PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
BEEN DECLARED IN THAT AREA BY
THE COUNTY AS THERE ARE VAST
POWERS THAT.
A GOVERNMENT HAVE --
WHEN THERE'S A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY DECLARED AND THAT THE
CHAIR BUT IT UP TALK FOR THE LA --
ABOUT THIS EARLIER IS IF WE HAVE
FOLKS WERE NOT COOPERATIVE I GET
IT IT'S THE LAST RESORT BUT
PUTTING A LIEN ON THE PROPERTY
SO CAN YOU.
SO I I I I AM NOT.
AWARE OF COUNTY DISC --
DECLARING A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY --
I KNOW THAT THEY ARE.
JERRY ARE WORKING ON LEAD BASED
PAINT ABATEMENT ARE AND WE WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM --
AND ON THE LEAN IT I BELIEVE I
WOULD HAVE --
TO GO BACK BUT I I THERE IS NO
OF PRESIDENT IN THE STATE ARE
DOING A LIEN AGAINST A PROPERTY
BUT I WILL HAVE I WILL TAKE THAT
HOME AND I WILL DISCUSS IT WITH
THE LEGAL DEPARTMENT.
YET AND THAT'S WHY I ASKED BY
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
AGAIN WHEN WHEN YOU TO CLEAR
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY THERE'S
BASS POWERS SAID.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS I JUST
DON'T FROM OUR FLOODING I DAYS
OF WHERE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
CAN ACTUALLY GET ON TO PRIVATE
PROPERTY SAID DR --
AND ASSIST HOMEOWNERS --
EVEN IF THEY LIKE IT OR NOT CAN
I'D LIKE TO ACTUALLY FOLLOW UP
AND PROVIDE A RESPONSE TO THAT
QUESTION AFTER DISCUSSION WITH
OUR LEGAL BECAUSE WE DO PROVIDE
THE SAMPLING RESULTS TO THE
PROPERTY OWNERS AND SO.
THE QUESTION OPPOSED TO THEM IS
WHAT IS THE TO DISCLOSE UPON
SALE OF THE PROPERTY AND THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION THAT YOU'RE
ASKING.
THE VIEW TO ALLOW ME TO IS TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON A
PROVIDING A RESPONSE LOOK FOR TO
THAT THANK YOU I THINK WE'VE
LEARNED WITH THE FIRE PROBLEMS
AT THE STATE DOESN'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PUT A LIEN ON IT.
THERE MAY BE.
ACTION THE AMONG SAYS TO TO GIVE
THE STATE THAT AUTHORITY IF THEY
DO DO THE CLEAN UP TO PUT TO GET
THE REIMBURSEMENT FROM THE
PROPERTY OWNER --
GIVEN THE ESTIMATES BECAUSE I
DON'T.
WE DIDN'T HAVE AB ONE ONE EIGHT
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THAT
TALKED ABOUT THE JOBS PROGRAM
TRAININGS PROGRAM I DON'T THINK
WE ESTIMATED OR ANTICIPATED TO
RE PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT ON
THE CLEAN UP ON THIS SITE.
WHAT'S THE ADDITIONAL COSTS THAT
THAT HAS YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
WONDERFUL THE TRAIN LOCAL PEOPLE
BUT BUT THAT HAS A CAUGHT AN
ADDITIONAL COST IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH.
CRISIS OF PEOPLE OR THE USING
THAT WORD TO JUST GET PEOPLE
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO COME IN
AND DO THE REMEDIATION DO WE
HAVE ANY IDEA.
AND AND WHAT THAT ADDITIONAL
COST WOULD BE GOING FORWARD.
I MEAN I I I GET DID IT BENEFITS
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY
AND NOT BUT I DID THE DOES IS
NOT FREE.
SO THE WORKS PROGRAM ITSELF HAS
NOT -- IT I
I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT NUMBERS
FOR WHAT THE WORKS PROGRAM HAS
COST TO DATE.
I IT IS IT IS IN THE LOW MILLION.
TO A MILLION AND HALF --
BUT I I THE REASON I HAVEN'T
QUANTIFIED THAT IS TO ME THE
VALUE OF HAVING THE WORKS
PROGRAM IS IS ENORMOUS.
AS YOU NOW HAVE COMMUNITY
RESIDENTS AS YOUR PARTNERS ON
THE PROJECT THEY TAKE OWNERSHIP
OF THE PROJECT AND THEY ARE
WORKING ON IT.
I AND WE ARE SEEING THAT IF I
MAY THERE IS AN EXAMPLE THAT I
WON I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH THE
COMMUNITY --
OF THEIR RESIDENT WAS GETTING
CLEANED UP.
AND THE DECIDED TO BUY LUNCH.
FOR ALL OF THE WORKERS ON SITE
INCLUDING DTS THE STAFF THAT WAS
OVERSEEING.
THIS IS THIS IS THE KIND OF
RELATIONSHIP WE ARE BUILDING
WITH THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE
WORKING ON THE SITE.
I AND SO THAT IS A TREMENDOUS
VALUE AND ANDI JUST WANTED TO
ADD THAT THAT THE ARE GRADUATING
WITH --
SKILLS THAT WILL ENABLE
SUSTAINABLE EMPLOYMENT IN THE
FUTURE NOT JUST WITH SKILLS THAT
ARE PARTICUAR AND SPECIFIC TO
THIS PROJECT I JUST NEEDED THE
QUANTIFICATION.
WE'RE AN ORAL I GUESS WE WILL BE
AND SIX HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
LARGE ONE MILLION DOESN'T ROCK
MY BOAT I JUST.
PROPORTIONALITY ALRIGHT LET'S
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING THIS
IS ITEMS NUMBER. THIRTEEN AND
FOURTEEN ROOMS OF THE PUBLIC
DEBT.
HAVE A DIFFERENT OBSERVATION OR
DISAGREE WITH SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN SAID.
I IN THE ROSTRUM OF THE SAN
ANDREAS POVERTY IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AND I WANT TO SAY AT
THE OUTSET THAT WE SUPPORT --
HAVING SUFFICIENT FUNDS TO DO A
FULL CLEAN UP OF THE EXIDE.
SITE HOWEVER --
WE HAVE TO BE VERY CONCERNED --
ABOUT THE MANY APPS THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY HAPPENING --
DGSE ESTIMATES THAT NEARLY TEN
THOUSAND CONTAMINATED SITES ARE
IN CALIFORNIA MANY OF WHICH I
HAVE NOT YET BEEN DISCOVERED
INVESTIGATED OR CHARACTERIZED.
MANY OF THESE WILL NOT HAVE A
RESPONSIBLE PARTY.
AS I THINK WE HEARD AT THE
OUTSET OF THIS HEARING THERE IS
A LARGE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN
BOTH OF THE ACCOUNTS THAT FUNDS
DTS.
AND FRANKLY I AM VERY CONCERNED
THAT EVEN OF THE SITES THAT ARE
KNOWN.
THAT WE ARE NOT FUNDING ANY
CLEANUP ACTIVITIES OR
CHARACTERIZATION OR
INVESTIGATION.
I WILL I WANT TO CALL OUT FOR
EXAMPLE.
IN OAKLAND.
THERE IS A SITE.
AGAIN IN AN URBAN AREA WITH
MIXED RESIDENTIAL COMMERCIAL
WHERE T. C. E. IS KNOWN. TO BE
AT ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND TIMES SAFE LEVELS IN
THE IN THE IN THE GROUND WATER.
AND SOIL GAS THERE IS A HUNDRED
THOUSAND TIMES THE SAFE LEVEL.
THE SOIL IS CONTAMINATED WITH
CADMIUM LEAD AND NICKEL AND LEAD
THERE IS A HUNDRED TIMES THE
SCREENING LEVELS.
THIS SITE IS ON THE THIRD
PRIORITY LIST AND I KNOW FOR THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS THERE HAS
BEEN NO MONEY BUDGETED FOR ANY
ACTIVITY AT THIS STE.
THERE ARE OTHERS IN RICHMOND IN --
DELAY KNOW WHERE OUR OFFICE IS
LOCATED --
THAT ARE NOT RECEIVING ANY FUNDS
SO WHILE I APPRECIATE THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT IT TAKES TO CLEAN
UP EXIDE.
WE WOULD BE NAIVE TO THINK THAT
THERE ARE NOT MANY HUNDREDS OF
OTHER SITES IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE THERE PROBABLY REQUIRE THE
SAME LEVEL OF INVESTMENT THEY
JUST HAVEN'T BEEN DISCOVERED YET.
AND BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
MONEY DISCOVER THE SITES WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
CURRENTLY ARE A PUBLIC RISK WE
HAVE BEEN PUTTING OUR HEADS.
IN THE SAND AND WE'VE BEEN
KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD
FOR TOO MANY YEARS AND I HAVE
NOT HEARD AND HAVE.
YET TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS BUT
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO ABOUT THE
LONG TERM IMPACT ON THE IMPACT
THAT WE'RE FACING TODAY SO.
I REALLY HOPE THAT WE CAN WORK
WITH THE TNC THE LEGISLATURE
ACTUALLY FIXING THE THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT FOR THE
CLEANUP FIND THAT TODAY IS IS
CURRENTLY HURTING PUBLIC HEALTH
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
POINT TAKEN MAX.
GOOD MORNING.
ALMOST AFTERNOON SENATOR
ACCOUNTS CAN COMMUNITY AT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHARLENE CONTROLLERS AND I WITH
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH --
WE WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR INCLUDING IN THE PROPOSED
BUDGET AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTY
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TOWARDS CLEANING UP RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES SURROUNDING THE
FORMER EXIDE.
FACILITY IN WE ARE HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL.
I IT'S ESTIMATED AS WE HEARD
HERE AT THAT THE COST FOR THE
CLEANUP IS OVER SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
IN THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS PROPOSED
IN THE BUDGET IS ANOTHER KEY
STEP IN ASSURING THAT WE HAVE
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING STREAM.
ARE AVAILABLE AND TO CLEAN UP
WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
NEW AGENCY AND DEPARTMENT
LEADERSHIP.
AND OUR ENCOURAGE WITH THEIR
DESIRE TO WORK IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE COUNTY AND LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS IN ADDRESSING THE
LONG STANDING PROBLEMS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS CLEAN UP.
AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
COLLABORATION AND STAND READY TO
ASSIST THE AGENCY AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND RISK AND
ACHIEVING THIS GOAL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANNEX.
HELLO MY NAME AMERICA SOME OF
THEM WITH THE SAN ANDREAS
PARTING THE ENVIRONMENT LAST
MONTH IN FRONT OF YOU --
I SPOKE SPANISH AND I'LL MAKE
SOME MORE COMMENTS BEEN AND
SPANISH AND THAT AS HE TO SEE
GOES THROUGH ITS --
PHASES AND LEARNS HOW TO MANAGE
ITS MONEY THAT IT ADEQUATELY.
PUTS RESOURCE TO OUR REGION TO
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
CONTAMINATED BUT DON'T GET
ADVOCATE RESEARCH.
SEES ME OUT REACH --
AND THAT'S CULTURALLY COMPETENT
AND I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHT CITY OF
INDUSTRY AS ONE WITH THE COME
ECHO.
SITE AND ALSO --
ALCOHOL AND THAT ALSO HAS T. C.
HOW THAT THAT AND HOPE THE
DEPARTMENT LEARNS TO INVEST NOT
JUST IN THE CLEAN UP BUT ALSO AN
APPROPRIATE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
CONSISTENT OUTREACH THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH LET'S CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING THE SIR ITEMS AT
THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN WE WILL
HOLD THEM OPEN THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION --
LET'S MOVE TO ITEM.
WE HAVE TO DO A LITTLE VIGNETTE
HERE FOR A COUPLE OF ITEMS THIS
IS ITEM FIFTEEN LET'S GET THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES BOARD AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
TO TALK ABOUT INCREASE DRINKING
WATER LABORATORY SERVICES.
THIS IS FOR POSITIONS EIGHT
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THIS BUDGET YEAR AND
SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
CONTINUING [inaudible]
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
OR STILL.
PLEASE WARNING SO I MUD
DURAFLAME IS I'M DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE DIVISION DRINKING WATER
TO STATE WATER BOARD A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT ISSUE FIFTEEN AND
WITH VISA.
OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
EILEEN SO BACK WE'RE GONNA
BOUNCE BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
THE IS AS WE GO THROUGH --
SO.
SO SHOULD FIFTEEN AND I SHOULD
MENTION AS WELL WE HAVE A PAGE
IN A A NEARBY IF ANY QUESTIONS
FORM SO.
ALL ALL TO ATTEMPT TO COVER THIS
FROM THE BEGINNING HERE.
SO THIS ISSUE IS REQUESTING A
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN IN FISCAL
YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY AND SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND AND
ON GOING AUTHORITY.
OF FOR OUR DRINKING WATER
RADIATION LABORATORY AT C. P. H.
WHEN DRINKING WATER PROGRAM WAS
MOVED TO THE STATE WATER BOARD
THE DRINKING WATER RADIATION
LABORATORY REMAINS OUT
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH --
WE FUND THAT THROUGH A CONTRACT
WITH THEM THE INCREASE SOME OF
THE SERVICES THEY PROVIDE FOR US.
PRIMARILY WE'RE ASKING TO OF
FIRST.
UPGRADE THEIR ABILITY TO MEET
WHAT'S CALLED T. AND I IT'S A
NATIONAL STANDARD ASSOCIATED
WITH THE QUALITY OF WORK TO DO
SO WE WANT.
THEM.
TO BE ABLE TO MEET THAT STANDARD
WERE ALSO.
ASKING THAT DAY INCREASE IN ADD
ADDITIONAL.
METHODS TEST METHODS AND KICK OF
MATERIALS TO BE TESTED UNDER THE
DRINKING WATER.
AXE SO THAT THEY CAN DO THOSE
THE THE SECOND WATER ACT
REQUIRES THAT WE HAVE A
LABORATORY CONTRACT TO THE STATE
THAT CAN DO ALL.
NCL'S LISTED.
OUR THROUGH OUR WORK WITH THEM
OVER THE COUPLE YEARS WE REALIZE
THAT THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO
ACHIEVE ALL OF THOSE SO THAT
WE'RE ADDING FIFTY ONE
ADDITIONAL CONSTITUENTS AND
TWENTY FIVE NEW ANALYTICAL
METHODS OF THE COSTS ARE
INCREASED.
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT.
AND OF COURSE THERE ARE
REFERENCE LABORATORY THEY DO A
LOT OF WORK FORCE ON REALLY
IMPORTANT THINGS LIKE.
OF THE MICRO PLASTIC ONE WHICH
WE'LL TALK ABOUT A LITTLE BIT
LATER AND P. FAST PEOPLE --
AND ALL THAT KIND OF STUFF
COMING ALONG SO IT'S IMPORTANT
WE MAKE SURE THEY HAVE.
ENOUGH CAPACITY TO HANDLE THAT
YPE OF WORK AND THAT'S IT
[inaudible]
PUBLIC HEALTH [inaudible]
IF.
TELL ME.
WHERE IS THIS LAB LOCATED I KNOW
IT'S IN THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HELP BUT IS IT LIKE RIGHT OVER
HERE ON FIFTEEN STREET THOUGH
IT'S IN THE RICHMOND?
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND WE WERE
GOING THROUGH A PROCESS WERE
WERE --
BUILDING A NEW NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY RIGHT AND IS AND WE HAVE
SO THE IDEA WOULD GET THIS.
COOPERATIVE AGREEMENT IS THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES BOARD AT
SOMETIME GOING TO BE BUILDING.
IN BUILDING NEW STRUCTURES IS
THE IS THE BIG PLAN HERE DO YOU
GET A BILL THE LAB OR WE JUST
GONNA.
USE THE PARTNER PUBLIC HEALTH.
THE INTENT IS THE LEAD USED
APARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH OR
CERTAINLY OTHER LABS WITHIN THE
STATE AS WELL THAT IF WE NEED TO
MOVE AROUND WE COULD.
DO THAT THE WATER BOARD THIS
TIME DOES NOT INTEND TO
CONSTRUCT LEVEL THAT'S ON
THERE'S ENOUGH CAPACITY ENOUGH
SHARING IT JUST BY A QUICK
UPDATE TO QUIP IN AND DO LIKE
THAT.
CORRECT OKAY I'M LA --
YOU HAVE A COMMENT.
FINANCES THAT THAT THIS IS A SIX
BUDGET IT.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT OUR MEMBERS.
INTERESTED INCREASED DRINKING
WATER LABORATORY SERVICES.
CAROLINE A CHAIN A MOTIONLESS
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING WILL
JUST HAVE MOTION BY.
UNDER MCGUIRE TO PROVE THE RE
REQUEST.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASKING HI IN [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
DURING.
KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN FOR OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS --
AND THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU
PUBLIC HEALTH N. [inaudible]
ALL UP.
CONTINUE WITH STATE WATER
RESOURCES BOARD ON HE
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING OFFICERS.
AS PRODUCT OF AB.
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR I THINK IT'S
AFTERNOON NOW I'M EILEEN SUBJECT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF STATE
WATER BOARD --
AND MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE --
SO LET ME --
SPEAK -- AS
YOU SAID --
TO THIS THIS ITEM WHICH WOULD
FUND -- AND
THE STAND UP OF AN
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING OFFICE IN
THE STATE WATER BOARD.
BUT WE ARE REQUESTING TWO POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
OF FUNDED IN PART BY THE WATER
RIGHTS FUNDS THAT WOULD ACCOUNT
FOR ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION AND
THE GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
REMAINDER FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO MILLION FOR THE
SUPPORT OF NINE PERMANENT
POSITIONS --
TO ESTABLISH --
AND OFFICE WHICH WILL PROVIDE
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORTING STAFF.
TO CONDUCT ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS AND WATER RIGHT
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS AND WHO --
PREPARE DECISIONS IN THOSE IN
THOSE MATTERS.
THAT REQUEST ALSO INCLUDES A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FOR CONTRACTED ECONOMIC
EXPERTISE.
THE STATE WATER BOARD.
ANTICIPATES PROSECUTING MORE
WATER RIGHT ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS.
IN THE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
NINETEEN THROUGH TWENTY AND OUT
YEARS.
DUE DUE TO RECENT WATER RIGHT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND NEW
CANNABIS ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY --
AND ALSO WE EXPECT --
IT IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
DRINKING WATER PROGRAM AND THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT MAY ALSO RESULT
IN MORE HEARING REQUEST IN
COMING YEARS --
AB THREE THIRTEEN SPONSORED BY --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WAS THAT'S VETOED BY
THEN GOVERNOR BROWN --
HOWEVER IN HIS VETO MESSAGE --
GOVERNOR BROWN ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
THE BILL.
IT COULD KNOWLEDGE THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT IN THAT BILL TO INCREASE
FAIRNESS AND AND TRANSPARENCY
EVEN THOUGH HE CONCLUDED THAT
THE BILL WOULD NOT WORK AS
INTENDED.
ON THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE
DIRECTED THE SECRETARY OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
TO EVALUATE.
THE POTENTIAL ROLE FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES AND
PROVIDE A RECOMMENDATION FOR
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE BOARDS
HEARING PROCESS --
AND THE SECRETARY'S
RECOMMENDATION WHICH CAME OUT OF
THAT CALLED ST OF HEARINGS
OFFICE AS A SEPARATE AND
INDEPENDENT ORGANIZATIONAL UNIT
OF THE STATE WATER BOARD.
AHMED AND THE PURPOSE WAS TO
PROVIDE QUALIFIED IMPART
IMPARTIAL HEARING OFFICERS IN
WATER RIGHT ENFORCEMENT MATTERS.
SO -- DUE TO
A VARIETY OF FACTORS INCLUDING --
COMPETING RESPONSIBILITIES FOR
BOARD MEMBER AND STAFF TIME AND
WE RECOGNIZE THERE IS A BACKLOG
ON PROCESSING HEARING REQUEST
AND THAT THERE CAN BE LONG
DELAYS BETWEEN.
SUBMISSION OF HEARING REQUEST IN
THE ACTUAL HEARING AND THEN
ADDITIONAL DELAYS BETWEEN THE
HEARING --
WHEN IT IS HELD AND RELEASE OF A
PROPOSED DECISIONS AND HAVING
HEARINGS BY HELP BY HEARING
OFFICERS AND --
DRAFT DECISIONS --
PROPOSED --
PREPARED BY THOSE --
HEARING OFFICERS.
WE BELIEVE WILL IMPROVE THE
PROCESS IF ADEQUATE FUNDING IS.
PROVIDED TO IMPLEMENT THE BILL --
AND THE ON WATER RIGHTS
ENFORCEMENT IN FACT AND THE
OFFICE WILL BE AVAILABLE TO HEAR
AN EXPEDITE OTHER WATER RIGHT --
PROCEEDINGS --
INCLUDE AFTER --
THEY FULFILL THEIR ENFORCEMENT
AND HEARING OBLIGATIONS SO WE
COULD --
REAM REDUCE.
BACKLOGS IN OTHER OF OUR AND OUR
OFFICES.
THE 25% OF THE REQUESTED --
FUNDS ARE FROM THE GENERAL FUND
BECAUSE SOME HEARINGS WILL
INVOLVE ENFORCEMENT AGAINST
PERSONS WHO ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
WATER RIGHT FEES.
OF BY VIRTUE OF AN EXISTING LAW
THAT --
WHERE THEY ARE DIVERTING UNDER
RIPARIAN ARE PRE --
FOURTEEN APPROPRIATE IF RIGHTS
SO -- AT
THIS POINT WE'RE WE'RE
ESTIMATING THAT THAT WOULD --
THAT THAT WILL INVOLVE THAT 25%
OF THE TIME OF THE OFFICE WE
WILL ADJUST THAT IF WE ACTUALLY
GET THE OFFICE AND WE ASSESS THE
CASELOAD.
SO I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON THIS
MATTER I KNOW SOME OF THE
PROPONENTS OF THE GREAT BILL ON
THE COVER HERE WE ALL.
WERE -- VERY
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THE
IMPARTIALITY ABOUT THIS.
THESE ARE THE SPEECH CAN BE.
COMPLETED I GUESS NOW THAT WE
HAVE TO PAY THE BILL SOME FOLKS
OF RAISE THE CONCERN ABOUT THE
COST --
THAT'S COMING OUT OF THE FUND
NOT TO BUT THE GENERAL FUND
PORTION OF IT THAT'S OKAY BUT
THE FUN CAN YOU COMMENT ON THAT --
OF THE SECTION PERHAPS SAID IT
SAYS [inaudible]
QUITE EXPENSIVE.
I MEAN I DON'T KNOW.
HOW MANY HEARING OFFICERS WERE
OR NINE I GUESS WE'RE GONNA GET?
IT WOULD BE NINE POSITIONS THE
IDEA WOULD BE TO HAVE THREE
HEARING OFFICERS --
AND I AM WE CAN RESPOND IN IN --
MORE DETAIL LATER BUT I I THINK
THRE ARE SOME MISCONCEPTIONS
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT WHAT PERCENTAGE OF OF OF
FEES I WOULD BE NECESSARY AND
WHETHER THERE WOULD BE AN AND
WHETHER THERE WOULD BE AN
INCREASE IN FEES NECESSARY TO
COVER ON THE COST OF THIS OFFICE.
AND IF SO WHAT PERCENTAGE --
INCREASE THERE WOULD BE AND
THERE HAS BEEN IN IN --
SOME STAKEHOLDERS HAVE AN
ESTIMATED OF THAT OR OR OR
INTERPRETED OUR DISCUSSIONS
WHICH ARE NOT --
WE WE HAVE THE I AM A COMING
YEAR YET WE'RE STILL HAVING
STAKEHOLDER OUT REACH MEETINGS
BUT THE SOME STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
ESTIMATED THAT WE WERE WE ARE
LIKELY TO INCREASE OUR WATER
RIGHT FEES BY 15%.
AND WE DON'T WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT IS CORRECT.
UP WE'VE WE BELIEVE THAT --
IT IT.
IT'S LITTLE MORE LIKELY TO BE
ABOUT 7% --
THAT IS PARTLY BECAUSE THE IT IT
WILL M..
PART PARTS OF THE INCREASE WILL
COME OUT AT PARTS OF THE
INCREASE OF OUR PROPOSED
INCREASES IN FEES ARE GOING TO
GO.
TO OTHER ASPECTS OF INCREASED --
COST NOT.
TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING
OFFICER WE HAVE OTHER.
WE HAVE OTHER.
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS WHICH WILL
BEAR THE BURDEN OF THE INCREASE
OF THOSE FEES THOSE OTHER FEES
IF THEY DO COME TO PASS --
ANOTHER -- I
THINK IT'S A CAPTION OR YOU KNOW
MISS OF MISUNDERSTANDING THAT
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO CLEAR UP IS THAT
SOMEHOW --
SINCE WE ARE ANTICIPATING THAT --
SOME -- SOME
OF THE CASES HANDLED BY THIS
OFFICE WILL INVOLVE --
WATER RATES FOR CANNABIS --
OPERATIONS --
AND THAT SOMEHOW OR OTHER WATER
RIGHT -- FEE
PAYERS ARE GOING TO BE BEARING
THE THE BURDEN OF THOSE MATTERS.
IN FACT FOR THE WATER RIGHT --
ISSUES THE CANNABIS OPERATORS DO
PAY FEES THEY'RE ACTUALLY MORE
THAN THE FEES FOR OTHER --
WATER RIGHT AND STAKEHOLDERS --
AND ALSO INCLUDE IF THERE ARE
FOURTEEN AND AND RIPARIAN USERS
AS WELL SO --
IN ARGUE THEY WILL BE BEARING
THE CANOPY TO THE EXTENT THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL CANNABIS CASES
THEY WILL BE BEARING THE COST --
IT WILL NOT BE OF THOSE CASES
OUT OF THEIR FIFTY PORTION AND
WE WILL --
TAKE A LOOK AT THE CASE LOAD OF
THE OFFICE OF ITS ESTABLISH FROM
YOU KNOW AND ON ANNUAL BASIS AND
SEE WHAT THE CASE BREAKDOWN IS
AN ADJUSTER FEES ACCORDINGLY SO
THAT'S I THINK.
THANK YOU FROM OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED AND AND
THEN IF I'M IF I MIGHT JUST BE
ANOTHER ISSUE IS WHETHER THERE
SHOULD BE A TWO OTHERS WANT ONE
SHOULD THERE BE A DELAY IN THE
IN THIS MATTER --
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
UNDER --
DISSED UNDER THE ESTABLISHING --
YOU KNOW AB SEVEN FORTY SEVEN AS
OF JULY FIRST.
IT IS REQUIRED THAT ANY WATER
RIGHTS ENFORCEMENT MATTERS BE
HANDLED BY THE OFFICE NOT BY THE
BOARD ITSELF AND THAT WOULD
CREATE A GAP IN OUR ABILITY --
TO ENFORCING HOLD HEARINGS AND I
WE THINK THAT THAT IS AND I'M
NOT A GREAT MESSAGE I'M. TO BE
SENT -- TO
NOT THE COMMUNITY AGES IS --
I'M COMPLIANT BUT TWO OUTLIERS
WHO MIGHT SEE I AS A LICENSE TO
NOT COMPLY OR TO ASK FOR
HEARINGS.
AND THEN FINALLY THERE'S BEEN
SOME SUGGESTION THAT PERHAPS WE
SHOULD WRAP THIS OFFICE UP
SLOWLY START WITH A SMALLER STOP.
UP PART OF THE REASON FOR THIS --
ESTABLISHMENT OF THIS OFFICE IS
IS AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF A
SUBSTANTIAL BACKLOG.
AND DELAYS THAT DO OCCUR SO WE
ACTUALLY BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT --
TO GET THE OFFICE UP TO FULL
STRENGTH DEAL WITH THOSE
BACKLOGS AND AND HAVE THIS BE A
MUCH MORE TIMELY AND EFFICIENT --
OPERATION STONE THE THE MOTION
IS TO APPROVE THE BUDGET THAT
WILL ALLOW THE AGENCY TO
IDENTIFY WHO THOSE THREE OF
HEARING OFFICERS WILL BE THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT STAFF YOU
STILL HAVE THE RESOURCE BOARD --
MEMBERS DOING THOSE HEARINGS NOW
THE TRANSITION WOULD OCCUR ON
JULY THEFIRST IS LIKE WE GET
THE NEW BUDGET IN AND WE SAY
HERE'S THE DOCKET.
AS YOU WOULD IN COURT YOU SAY
OKAY YOU'RE GONNA TAKE CARE FOR
THE IT'S THE IMPARTIAL HEARING
OFFICER VERSES BECAUSE THE
PARTIAL KERN OFFICER.
WELL I I I'M NOT GOING TO IGNORE
THAT THE BOARD IS IS IS NOT
IMPARTIAL I THINK THAT WE WE
FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT THE
COURTS HAVE.
HAVE THAT THAT OUR CURRENT --
OUR CURRENT ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING PROCESS --
IS LAWFUL BUT IF THE IN A TO THE
EXTENT THERE HAS BEEN A
PERCEPTION PROBLEM THIS THIS
THIS THIS LOOKS LIKE A GREAT WAY
TO CARE THAT AND TO HELP.
HELP THE BOARD TURNED ITS
ATTENTION TO OTHER.
MATTERS OF WHICH IT HAS MANY --
SO YES THAT THAT IS THAT IS OUR
LA -- YOU
HAVE A COMMENT ON THIS.
WE DIDN'T RAISE ANY ISSUES WITH
THIS PROPOSAL OKAY THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER SIXTEEN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING OFFICERS.
AS SET FORTH IN.
AB SEVEN FORTY SEVEN LET'S OPEN
THE PUBLIC HEARING PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE WHITE HOUSE
GIVE MEMBERS I'M ROBERT GORE
FROM THE QUALCOMM GROUP
REPRESENTING KERN COUNTY WATER
KINGS RIVER WATER KINGS RIVER
CONSERVATION DISTRICT.
MODESTO YOUR GEISHA DISTRICT AND
THE CITY OF FRESNO.
WE APPRECIATE THE WATER BOARD'S
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS --
THUS FAR AND WE SUPPORT MOST OF
THE ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS
OFFICE HOWEVER THE ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION MAY BE TEMPTING TO
LOOK AT HIS.
BUDGET DUST BUT TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND FEE PAYERS IT'S
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT IT
REPRESENTS WE WERE TOLD BY WATER
BOARD STAFF ON MONDAY A 15%.
RATE INCREASE --
WHICH WE FIND SOMEWHAT
BURDENSOME AND IN THE FIVE
SUPPORT POSITIONS THE HEARING
OFFICERS ARE ARE ARE WONDERFUL.
THEIR WATER RIGHTS LAWYERS
THEY'RE NOT CHEAP AND WE FULLY
SUPPORT THAT BUT THERE ARE
POSITIONS.
FOR SUPERVISING ENVIRONMENTAL
PROGRAM MANAGER STAFF SERVICE
ANALYSTS TO SENIOR ENGINEERS AND
ANY GPA THIS IS A SAVINGS OF
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS WHICH WOULD IMPACT THE
RATE INCREASED DRAMATICALLY AS
YOU CAN TELL --
ALSO -- ONE
LAST REQUEST OF THERE WAS A B.
C. P. IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN TO REDUCE BACKLOGS FOR
PERMITS THEIR UP TO FORTY FOUR
YEARS THAT'S MY PERSONAL
FAVORITE --
WE HAVE YET TO RECEIVE A
COMPLETE ACCOUNTING OF THAT SO
WE LIKE THIS COMMITTEE TO REFER
TO REQUEST SOME TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTING OF THAT BCP PLUS THE
PROGRESS OF MADE FOR THIS
[inaudible]
ONE NEXT.
STRUCTURE MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN
WITH THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM --
WE'RE GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF AN
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS OFFICE
WE THINK THAT IT.
CAN INCREASE THE EFFICIENCY WITH
WHICH THE WATER BOARD DEALS WITH
THESE WATER RIGHTS ADJUDICATORY
MATTERS AS WELL AS INCREASED
CONFIDENCE IN THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS.
I WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE WATER
BOARD STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
RELATED TO THIS THE FIRST
MEETING WAS HELD ON MONDAY OF
THIS WEEK.
ON IT AND WE ARE FRANKLY
CONCERNED WITH THE 25% FEE
INCREASE THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
DRIVERS THERE AS WAS INVOLVED IN
THE TESTIMONY BUT THE B. C. P.
IS A MAJOR ONE ON ITS
ENCOURAGING TO HEAR TODAY THAT
IT'S 7% OF THE FEE INCREASE BUT
WILL NEED TO RECONCILE.
THAT WITH WHAT WE HEARD OR JUST
LIKE TO BRIEFLY ECHO THE
CONCERNS ARTICULATED BY MISTER
GORE ARE PARTICULARLY ON
STAFFING --
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOAL OF AB
SEVEN FOUR SEVEN IN THE B. C. P.
AND ASEXPLAINED ON THE STAFF
pANALYSIS THE GOAL HERE IS TO
HAVE HEARINGS HELD BY QUALIFIED
HEARING OFFICERS WHO WHOSE FOCUS
IS.
TO PLY THEIR SPECIALIZED
KNOWLEDGE TO PROVIDE A HEARINGS
AND PREPARE PROPOSED DECISIONS
AT THIS POINT IT'S NOT CLEAR TO
US WHAT ROLE THE OTHER STAFF
POSITIONS --
DETAIL BY MISTER GORE INCLUDING
MULTIPLE STAFF ENGINEERS AND THE
CONSULTING RESOURCES WILL PLAY
IN THE YOU KNOW DECISION MAKING
PROCESS THAT WAS --
CONTEMPLATED BY EIGHTY SEVEN
FOUR SEVEN TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN TODAY SO WE
CAN CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS --
WITH THE WATER BOARD CONTINUING
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS --
AND APPRECIATE CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
DAIS IN AN THE WATER BOARD. FIVE
PUBLIC COMMENT.
IN THE CASE THAT YOU WERE
ALREADY PREPARING THE THING
HEARINGS YOU'VE GOT CURRENT
STAFF THE PREPARES HEARINGS FOR
THE SAID THE BOARD
REPRESENTATIVES.
AND IF YOU HAD INDEPENDENT
HEARING OFFICER SHE COULD JUST
USE THE EXISTING STAFF FOR OR
SOME AUGMENTATION.
THIS IS NOT WHAT'S BEFORE US I
GUESS -- YES
WE'LL SEE SOME OF THE SOME OF
THE STUFF IS GOING TO NEED TO
SUPPORT THE WORK IN
INDEPENDENTLY SUPPORT THE WORK --
ADMINISTRATIVE AND SUCH OF
ANALYSIS WORK OF THE HEARING
OFFICER'S --
BUT IN THE MEANTIME THE BOARD.
TO THE EXTENT THAT TIME BOARD
TIME IS CLEARED UP THE BOARD IS
GOING TO TURN ITS ATTENTION TO
OTHER ENFORCEMENT MATTERS AND
TWO OTHER --
OTHER OTHER HEARING --
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT IT HAS
BRITAIN'S WITH RESPECT --
TO CORRECT AT TWO AM OTHER
BACKLOGS AND SO.
THAT THE THE BOARD STAFF THAT
WAS WORKING ON THESE WATER
RIGHTS ENFORCEMENT HEARINGS IS
GOING TO BE --
TASK TO WORK ON THESE OTHER
PETITIONS AND OTHER --
ENFORCEMENT MATTERS BEFORE THE
BOARD THEY WILL BE FULLY
OCCUPIED.
I'M AGAINST AN IN IN THEIR IN
SUPPORTING THE BOARD ON OTHER
MATTERS URALS.
ACCOUNT --
HIGH --
HEARING.
I I WOULD HOPE I WILL TAKE A
LOOK.
OKAY THERE'S A M..
THERE'S A MOTION BY SENATOR --
ACQUIRE TO PROVE THE BUDGET --
FOR THE REQUEST FOR HEARING
OFFICERS AS REQUESTED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
I CASKEY I JONES.
GLANCE.
MORNING.
I PRESUME YOU'LL TAKE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT DODD.
DOES REMARKS ON ON THIS --
CAREFULLY WHAT AS WE PROCEED
WITH THE PROCESS YES MISTER
CHAIR WE WILL BE HAPPY TO TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS LET'S MOVE TO ST.
DRINKING WATER --
SYSTEM SANITARY SURVEY.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTEEN THE ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN WE'RE
REQUESTING SIX ADDITIONAL
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND ONE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
SAFE DRINKING WATER ACCOUNT TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER.
OF TOTALLY CENTERS SERVICE
COMPLETED ANNUALLY.
CENTER SURVEYS ARE BASICALLY OUR
OUR MAIN WAY OF CHECKING UP ON
WATER SYSTEMS THERE ARE
INSPECTION COMPONENT THAT WE DO
AT ALL PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS.
UNDER OUR JURISDICTION IT'S
ABOUT 60% OF THE DIVISION'S
WORKLOAD SO IT'S OUR OUR BIGGEST
WORKLOAD COMPONENT.
THIS IS THE SECOND INCREASE
WE'VE HAD WE IN --
USUALLY IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
RECEIVED TEN POSITIONS THAT.
WAS ABLETO IMPROVE OUR BACKLOG
OF SANITARY SURVEYS FROM 75% 88%
COMPLETE.
I'M NOT A BACKLOG WAY BUT THE
COMPLETE SIDE.
AND SO --
WITH THIS WE LOOKED --
WITH THIS INCREASE WE LOOK TO
INCREASE THAT TO AT LEAST 94% OR
ABOVE THAT AS WE ARE ABLE TO
MORE STAFF.
DEPLOYED IN IN THIS AREA OF WORK.
NOW FOR THESE PICK AT THESE
ADDITIONAL SIX PEOPLE I THINK
IT'D BE FOCUSING ON THOSE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY NINE PUBLIC.
WATER SYSTEMS THAT WE KNOW ARE.
FAILING OR ARE NOT PROVIDING
SAFE DRINKING WATER --
TO THE FOLKS THIS IS GONNA BE
SYSTEM WIDE.
THIS IS MORE SYSTEM WIDE
CERTAINLY WE ALREADY PUT A LOT
OF FOCUS ON THOSE SYSTEMS WE
KNOW ARE FAILING --
BUT THERE ARE SYSTEMS THAT WE
ARE GETTING TUNE SO THIS IS
REALLY TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET ALL THE SYSTEMS THAT WE
CAN.
AND PRESUMABLY THESE AT THIS
ADDITIONAL SURVEY INFORMATION
WILL ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO
MAKE THE DECISIONS ON
CONSOLIDATION AND YOU KNOW
MANDATES.
THEN THE LIKE THESE THESE ARE
THE OUR FRONTLINE STAFF THAT ARE
IN OUR DISTRICT OFFICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT ARE
THE FIRST CONTACT OF THOSE WATER
SYSTEMS THERE ARE EARLY
INDICATOR OF WHEN THEY'RE LIKELY
TO HAVE PROBLEMS IN THE FUTURE.
AND WE WE WOULD REALLY RATHER
GET TO AN EVEN BEFORE THEY SHOW
UP ON ARGUMENT RIGHT TO WATER
LISTS OF DEFINITELY.
AND I DON'T HAVE GOOGLE MAPS
WITH ME BUT I ASSUME THAT GIVE
IN TRAFFIC PATTERNS AREAS THAT
THEY HAVE TO WORK THAT THAT THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO BE MAXIMIZING.
EFFICIENCIES OF WHEN THEY GO OUT
TO THIS AREA WITH THE DIFF WITH
DIFFERENT PEOPLE I IMAGINE YOU
KNOW SOMEONE IS A LOOK AT THE
MAP SOME OF THESE AREAS ARE.
A LONG DISTANCE TO GO TO DO ONE
SURVEY OTHERS MAY BE.
IT'S WHAT THEY SAY IN LA FOR THE
FOUR OH FIVE YEAR.
IT'S JUST A BAD THING.
YES WE WE DEFINITELY DO TRY TO
OPTIMIZE THAT WAY AND YOU'RE
RIGHT IN LA WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
DISTANCE WE TALK ABOUT HOW LONG
IT TAKES TO GET THERE.
ELLIE ARE YOU HAVE SOMETHING.
ON ISSUE.
SEVENTEEN NOTHING TO ADD ALL
RIGHT THIS IS.
A QUESTION PROOF IS BUDGETED
LET'S OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC --
ON THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET REQUEST FOR SIX
ADDITIONAL PERMANENT.
CENTER MONEY MOVES PROPOSAL WILL
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL CASKEY AYE.
DOWNS MCGUIRE [inaudible]
RUNNING [inaudible]
DURING.
I WILL KEEP THAT ROLE FROM FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS LET'S MOVE ON
TO MICRO PLASTICS YES MICHAEL
PLASTIC SO.
FAR THIS REQUEST IS FOR A ONE
TIME ALLOCATION OF LE JUST A
LITTLE OVER A MILLION DOLLARS OF
A LICENSE PLATE FUND --
END OF LETTER THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME COSTS LARGELY
CONTRACT BECAUSE IT WE WILL
EXPAND TO WORK ON DEVELOPING A
METHOD OF TESTING FOR MICHAEL
PASTA X..
MICHAEL PLASTICS ARE A VERY
COMPLEX WORLD WERE ENTERING INTO
HERE WERE.
PLEASE TO START ON THIS THIS IS
REALLY THE FIRST STEP IN TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HEALTH IMPACTS IS
TO HAVE A METHOD THAT CAN BE
REPEATED BY EVERYBODY THE DOES
THE TEST SO THAT WE KNOW.
WHEN SOMEONE GIVES AN ANSWER
IT'S THE SAME IN DIFFERENT
LABORATORY OR NOT?
AND THE COMPLEXITY OF MICHAEL
PLASTICS COMES FROM THE FACT
THAT JUST BY THE MID TERM OF IT
IT CAN INCLUDE.
PAINT CHIPS MICROFIBER IS FROM
CLOTHING PLASTIC THAT'S DEGRADED
IN THE ENVIRONMENT ALL SORTS OF
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS AND TESTING
FOR IT IS OF WHETHER OUR
ACADEMIC METHODS OUT THERE.
THERE'S REALLY NONE THAT HAVE
GONE THROUGH A FULL METHOD
DEVELOPMENT TEST PROCESS AND SO
THIS FUNDING WILL ALLOW US TO DO
THAT.
AND I GET TO THAT AND START ON
THE PROCESS OF UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THIS IS AN ENVIRONMENT HOW
WHAT THE QUANTITIES ARE AND WHAT
POTENTIAL HEALTH IMPACTS ASIDE
FROM THAT [inaudible]
LIAM [inaudible]
NOTHING [inaudible]
CENTER MONNING.
THANK YOU YOU MENTIONED IT AT
THE END THAT PART OF THE TESTING.
THERE'S THE DETECTION AND THEN
THERE'S UNDERSTANDING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPACT YES.
WHAT PART OF THIS OR WHAT
STUDIES ARE GOING ON TO MEASURE?
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS OF THESE
MICROBEADS IN DRINKING WATER.
SO THERE'S NONE TAT ARE UNDER
WAY BY US SPECIFICALLY WERE
REALLY TASK OF TRYING TO GET THE
YOU THAT THE METHOD ESTABLISHED
SO THAT WE HAVE A COMPARABLE
BASIS TO GO FROM I DO KNOW THAT
THERE ARE ACADEMIC RESEARCH
GOING ON ASSOCIATED WITH THE
HELP OF MICHAEL PLASTICS.
IS THAT'S ANOTHER COMPLICATED
FACTORS WELL BECAUSE SOMETIMES
THE MARKER PLASTICS THE PLASTIC
THEMSELF IS NOT.
THE TOXIC COMPONENT IT'S THAT IT
ABSORBS CAN INTO BEING A
DELIVERY METHOD OR A FOCUS
CONCENTRATION SO THERE'S A LOT
OF WORK YET TO BE DONE ON THIS.
WOMAN MONETARY AND ONE IN ONE
AREA MIGHT BE DIFFERENT THAN
ABSOLUTELY YES OTHER RIGHT.
I APPLAUD THE EFFORT TOM.
I WOULD THINK IN ADDITION TO THE
DETECTION.
COLLECTING THE SCIENTIFIC DATA
THAT IS BEING DONE BY OTHERS IS
THAT PART OF YES SO CORRECT SO
WE'RE WE'RE ALREADY.
PRE PLANNING AS WERE DEVELOPING
THE METHOD AND GOING TO THAT
WORK THAT THE HEALTH RESEARCHERS
WILL BE THERE WITH US AND
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW KIND OF
WHERE WE'RE TARGETING WITH THAT.
AND BE PART OF THE METHOD
DEVELOPMENT SO THAT THEY KNOW
HOW TO BASICALLY.
KEEP THE BALL ROLLING FROM ONE
TO THE OTHER SO IT'S A SEAMLESS
TRANSITION ASSUME YOU'RE YOUR
FINDINGS ARE.
PUBLIC RECORD WE NEED HELP
ABSOLUTELY YES.
AND PRESUMABLY ONCE WE GET THE
ANALYTICS IN THE PROCESS THAN
THAT.
THAT WHATEVER WORK IS GET SUCKED
UP ON ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY NINE
YOU KNOW.
OUR FINAL DANCE TODAY WHEN THAT
WHEN THAT.
SAFE DRINKING WATER ACT KITS ARE
RESOLVED THEN THAT WHATEVER WE
HOWEVER WE MEASURE IT WE KNOW
WHAT IT IS THEN THE ANSWER.
SHOULD BE WHICH SHE I WILL BE
LOOKING FOR IT THERE.
ALL RIGHT LET'S OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING WE HAVE.
MICHAEL PLASTICS IN DRINKING
WATER WHICH IS RESULT OF FROM SB
[inaudible] FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
OF THE PROPOSAL THERE'S A MOTION
TO MOVE IT WAS CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING --
AND CALL THE ROLL.
WE CASKEY AYE JONES REQUIRE
[inaudible]
MONEY.
WE'LL KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND MOVING ON
TO THE GOVERNOR'S RESPONSE THE
YET ANOTHER.
SENATE BILL THIS IS A NON
POSSIBLE RE USE WATER SYSTEMS
FROM SB. NINE SIX SIX PLEASE
PROCEED YES CORRECT SO THE THE
BOARD IN THIS ISSUE IS
REQUESTING NINE HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FROM
GENERAL FUND INCLUDING FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR ON GOING
FUNDING --
TO PERMIT POSITIONS AND A FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND ONETIME
CONTRACT FUNDS TO BASICALLY DO
AN EXPERT PANEL AND DEVELOPER
WRIST BASE LOG REDUCTION TARGETS
FOR PATHOGENS.
REGULATIONS FOR ON SITE
RECYCLING.
I GUESS IT'S KEY TO NOTE THAT
THIS IS YOU KNOW WE DO A LOT OF
RECYCLING IN CALIFORNIA A
MUNICIPAL SITES LARGE.
COMPONENTS WHERE WE DO THE
RECYCLING IN WERE OR REALLY WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT IS.
BUILDING LEVEL RECYCLING SO THE
WATER NEVER LEAVES THE BUILDING
IT BECOMES RECYCLED AND CAN BE
IT'S MERGING AREA THAT THAT'S
HAPPENING IN WERE YOU KNOW PARTS
OF ONE OFF APPROVALS AND SAN
FRANCISCO EN EL áREA IS
ASSOCIATE WITH THIS.
AND REALLY THIS IS TO DEVELOP
THE REGULATORY STRUCTURE SO THAT.
LOCAL AGENCIES CAN DECIDE
WHETHER THEY WANT THIS PROGRAM
IN AND USE THOSE.
GUIDELINES WE GIVE THEM IN THIS
ROAD FOR APPROACH TO HAVE A
PROGRAM THAT CAN GOING FORWARD
IT'S NOT GONNA BE.
STATE PROGRAM FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE BUILDING SCALE IT OBVIOUSLY
HAS TO BE THE LOCALS THAT ARE
INVOLVED.
AND WE'RE TALKING NOT JUST GRAY
WATER WE'RE TALKING BLACK WATER
FOR TALKING ALL THE WHOLE WATER
DOES CONTAIN AND WE HAVE A
DIVERSITY OF WATER SYSTEMS HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WE
WOULD IMAGINE THAT THIS WOULD BE.
FOCUSED ON THE TOP AND OUR LEASE
I ANTICIPATE THAT IT WILL BE DAY
THE EFFICIENT ONES THAT ARE.
THAT ARE IN COMPLIANCE AND THAT
WITH THIS DECIDE TO TRY THE OUR
IN HOUSE.
OF TREASON SYSTEM.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY IT'S GONNA BE OF
YOU KNOW IT'S GONNA BE COST
PROHIBITIVE IN MANY AREAS THIS
ISN'T A UNIVERSAL SOLUTION BUT
THERE IS DEFINITELY APPLICATION
FORD IN SOME CASES.
WHERE IT MAKES SENSE TO YOU KNOW
NOT TRANSPORT WATER BACK AND
FORTH LONG DISTANCES AND JUST
RECYCLING ON THE SITE WHERE THAT?
LOW'S THERE THE CAPABILITY THAN
TO REUSE IT IS AND IT MAKES
ECONOMIC SENSE IN THOSE
COMPONENTS.
TO FURTHER THE WATER RESOURCES A
CALIFORNIA.
NO ANY COMMENTS ON THIS IS NOT
POSSIBLE.
REVIEWS WATER SYSTEMS LET'S OPEN
THE PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS.
ISSUE NUMBER.
NINETEEN GET THE BALL ROLLING ON
ON SITE RECYCLING.
ALL RIGHTY WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
IT'S MOVED BY CENTER REQUIRE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASKING HIGH.
IN THE CHOIR [inaudible]
MORNING.
KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN IN.
A MOVE ON THE ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY WITH THE SEWER SERVICE
PROVISION FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES PLEASE PROCEED.
HI YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
YES WE ARE SEEKING I'M.
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT A NEW
PROGRAM ESTABLISHED UNDER SB --
TWELVE FIFTEEN WERE SEEKING
THREE ADDITIONAL PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE WASTE DISCHARGE PERMIT
FUND. FOR THAT THE UP COMING
FISCAL YEAR AND SIX AN
ADDITIONAL --
PERMANENT POSITIONS --
I AM IN IN THE OUT YEARS.
SB.
TWELVE FIFTEEN AUTHORIZED THE
REGIONAL WATER QUALITY BOARDS TO
ORDER A CITY COUNTY OR SPECIAL
DISTRICT WITH AN EXISTING
RECEIVING SYSTEM --
THAT IS A COLLECTION SYSTEM AND
OUR WASTE WATER TREATMENT SSTEM
TO PROVIDE SEWER SERVICES EXCUSE
ME SEWER SERVICES TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THAT HAVE INADEQUATE SEPTIC
TANKS SYSTEMS. FOR THE
PROTECTION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
OVERALL IN THE PREVENTION
PREVENTION OF POTENTIAL IMPACTS
TO SOURCES OF DRINKING WATER SO
THIS YOU KNOW IMPACTS NOT JUST
INDIVIDUAL --
PROPERTIES WITH SEPTIC SYSTEMS
BUTTON POTENTIALLY CAN
CONTAMINATE LARGER GROUNDWATER
SOURCES.
USED -- FOR
THANK YOU WATER AND AFFECT ME SO --
THEM -- AS
AS AS I'VE SAID THEY IF THEY'RE
NOT IF IF SEPTIC TANKS ARE
IMPROPERLY MAINTAINED IF THEY
WEAR OUT OVER TIME IF THERE USED
TO BE ON THEIR ORIGINAL CAPACITY.
THEY OFTEN BECOME A SOURCE OF
POLLUTION FOR SURROUNDING
WATERWAYS AND GROUND WATERS --
AND OUR EXPERIENCE IS THAT THERE
ARE DOZENS OF WATER WAYS THAT
ARE NOW --
COMPROMISED --
AND IMPAIRED DUE TO CONTAMINANTS
THAT CAN REASONABLY BE TREATED
TRACED TO LEAKING SEPTIC.
TANKS IN THE SURROUNDING REGION
AND CURRENTLY THERE IS ACTUALLY
LITTLE INCENTIVE OR OR EVEN
ABILITY FOR MANY PROPERTY OWNERS
TO MAKE THE CHANGE FROM SEPTIC
TO SEWER.
IN MANY CASES SEPTIC TANKS SERVE
RURAL AND SPARSELY POPULATED
AREAS --
MOST MOST OF THOSE PROPERTY
OWNERS REALLY HAVE LITTLE
ALTERNATIVE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
FINANCIAL ABILITY OR
ORGANIZATIONAL ABILITY.
TO I'M NOT TO DO TO USE ANY
OTHER SYSTEM BUT EVEN IN CASES
WHERE PROPERTY OWNERS ARE IN
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO COMMUNITIES
THAT DO HAVE --
A FUNCTIONING WASTE WATER SYSTEM.
SEWER SYSTEM --
THE COSTS OF REMOVE.
AND FREQUENTLY.
THE POTENTIALLY POTENTIAL
RECEIVING --
SYSTEM IS UNWILLING TO TAKE ON
ADDITIONAL --
WITH WATER AT ABOUT COMMUNITIES --
SERVE BY SEPTIC TANKS.
THE RESOURCES THAT WERE
REQUESTING WILL LLOW THE STATE
AND REGIONAL BOARDS TO IMPLEMENT
THE REQUIREMENTS OF SB --
TWELVE FIFTEEN IN ORDER THE
NECESSARY CONSOLIDATIONS FOR
DISADVANTAGE --
COMMUNITIES --
SO EACH CONSOLIDATION OR
EXTENSION OF SERVICE.
CHIEF WILL ENSURE REAL RELIABLE
SERVICE.
THEY WERE SERVICE FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES --
AND PROTECTS WATER QUALITY AND
I'M.
IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH GENERALLY
OF COURSE WE WON'T MOVE TO
MANDATORY CONSOLIDATIONS WITHOUT
A LOT OF PROCESS IS SPECIFIED IN
THE LEGISLATION.
AND ATTEMPTS --
TO NOT TO WORK EXTENSIVELY WITH
THEM BUT ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE TECHNICAL INFORMATION
THEY NEED AND I'M TO HELP THEM
IDENTIFY FUNDING SOURCES THAT
WOULD ALLOW --
THESE KINDS OF CONSOLIDATIONS TO
AND IMPROVEMENTS TO OCCUR
[inaudible]
MMHM.
LET'S SAY YOU HAVE.
THREE HOMES THAT ARE ON SEPTIC.
AND THERE'S A SEWER SYSTEM RIGHT
NEXT TO IT AND FOR SOME REASON
LET'S JUST SAY IT'S JUST THE
LEGACY THEY JUST WERE NEVER ON
IT WHEN THE HOUSES NGUYEN IN.
ITS ITS DEVELOPED AROUND.
SO WITH THE SEPTIC SERVICE.
MAINTAINED AND THERE'S NO
PROBLEM THERE'S NO LEAK.
FLUSH THEM OUT WHEN THEY WHEN
THEY NEED TO IN THERE OKAY
THAT'S ONE FAXES.
SITUATION LET'S SAY YOU GO THERE
AND YOU SEE THAT THEY ARE.
NOT MAINTAINED OVER USE FALL
APART AND CONTAMINATING THE
GROUND WATER THAT'S THEIR WHAT
MUSCLE WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE AND
IN THE AUTHORITY THAT YOU'VE
BEEN GIVEN ON TWELVE FIFTEEN
ORDER.
THAT'S SEPTIC OUT.
YOU GET A CONSOLIDATED WITH THE
WITH THE EXISTING SYSTEM I DON'T
WANT TO BE.
YOU KNOW.
JULIUS CAESAR UP HERE BUT AT THE
WORD WE WERE WE BECAUSE WE WE
WANT TO SEE SOME CONSOLIDATION
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH I MEAN I THINK.
WITH THOSE TWO DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS.
RESULT IN DIFFERENT ACTIONS BY
THE BY THE BOARD.
YES I I THINK THAT IF WE EVER
WILL I PREVIOUSLY WE DID NOT
HAVE THE AUTHORITY ON THE ON THE
SEWER SERVICE SIDE TO REQUIRE
MANDATORY --
CONSOLIDATIONS AND WE WOULD
OBVIOUSLY TARGET AREAS WHERE WE
HAD NOT FUNCTIONING --
SU AD SEPTIC SYSTEMS.
IT IN CERTAIN AREAS IF THEY ARE
WELL MAINTAINED AND PROPERLY
MAINTAIN THEY STILL ARE AND AND
AND OKAY ALTERNATIVE.
BUT IF HEY'RE NOT IF THEY
AREN'T FUNCTIONING AND IF THERE
IS A LANCE EASILY OR EFFICIENTLY --
ECONOMICALLY I'M THIS IS NOW A
TOOL THAT WE HAVE IN OUR TOOLBOX.
TO BOTH THE EMBERS.
OF THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WHO HAVE.
THIS NON FUNCTIONING --
SEPTIC SYSTEM AND THE BROADER
PUBLIC HEALTH I MEAN THE THE
POINT IS SET AT THEY MAY BE FINE
WITH THE NON FUNCTIONING AS A
SEPTIC SYSTEM BUT IT'S IT'S
HAVING ADVERSE EFFECTS ON THE
GROUND WATER IN GENERAL AND CAN
DOING CONTAMINATION.
JUST WANNA.
OR IF YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
MUSCLE THEN YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LARGER CONSOLIDATION GOAL
HERE OF THE STATUS QUO IS NOT
WORKING.
AND AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR ON IN
A MY ENTHUSIASM TO GET THESE
FEELINGS SYSTEMS [inaudible]
CONSOLIDATED AND AND THEY'RE
NEVER GOING TO GET THE HAVE THE
WHERE WITH ALL TO TO OPERATE SO.
I DO THINK IT'S BOTH THE MISTER
CHAIR THAT.
SOME INDIVIDUALS MIGHT BE OKAY
WITH NOT HAVING A FUNCTIONING
SEPTIC SYSTEM BUT I THINK THAT
THERE ARE.
MANY --
INDIVIDUALS WHO JUST DON'T WHO
WHO ARE NOT AN WHO SEE THE THE
RISK TO THEMSELVES.
I'M AS WELL AND AND THEY JUST
DON'T HAVE THE WHERE WITH ALL AS
YOU SAY TO OR OR THE A POLITICAL
MUSCLE TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT
BUT I I AGREE THIS IS THIS IS
WAY BEYOND INDIVIDUALS IT ALSO
HAS TO DO WITH.
THE PUBLIC.
LA --
ANYTHING TO ADD ON THIS.
OKAY THIS IS. SEVEN FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
SIX POSITIONS AND ANOTHER ONE
POINT -- SIX
FROM THE WASTE WATER WASTE.
THIS CHARGE PERMIT FUND SO PUT
UP THE PUBLIC HEARING MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE ON SEWER
SERVICE PROVISIONS FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY CLAIBORNE
ATTORNEY WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY I
HEAR A VOICE STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS PROPOSAL IN THE PROPOSED
FUNDING --
WE WORK WITH RESIDENTS OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY IN
THESE COACHELLA VALLEY MANY OF
WHOM ARE WORKING ON SEPTIC TO
SEWER CONVERSION PROJECTS.
AND ARE REALLY LOOKING AT
SOLVING WHAT'S BOTH --
I HEALTH PROBLEM AND THAT WATER
QUALITY THREAT --
IN THIS NEW AUTHORITY WHEN
IMPLEMENTED WILL GO A LONG WAY.
TO MANY OF THEM ARE MOVING
VOLUNTARILY SOME OF WHICH ARE
NOT SO.
STRONG SUPPORT IN THANK YOU.
CAN NEXT.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JONATHAN NELSON WITH A COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
WE WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR.
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S HUMAN RIGHTS --
WATER LAW ACTUALLY INCLUDES
SANITATION AND WASTE WATER AND
THAT DEFINITION BUT THAT OFTEN
SLIPS FROM THE CONVERSATION I
THINK.
THIS TOOL WILL PROVIDE AN
AUTHORITY THAT FRANK HAS BEEN
NEEDED FOR A LONG TIME BUT ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT.
THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS
CONVERSATION IS TO SUPPORT IT
AND THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
THE CONVERSATION AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I REMIND MY
COLLEAGUES YESTERDAY THAT
LEGISLATION ESTABLISHING THE
RIGHT DIDN'T INCLUDE THAT
FUNDING FOR THE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE STATE'S WE'RE DOING THIS
AND IN BABY STEPS THANK YOU FOR
THE COMMENT.
IT'S CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING.
MOTION TO APPROVE.
AS REQUESTED BY CENTER REQUIRE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN IN MOVING --
TO ANOTHER AND ASSEMBLY BILL AB
TWENTY FIVE A ONE STATE
ADMINISTRATORS CONSOLIDATION
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
YES SO THIS REQUEST AS YOU AS
YOU NOTED IS --
INCREASE ASSOCIATED WITH AB
TWENTY FIVE A ONE BUT I WILL
POINT OUT THAT THE CONSOLIDATION
STARTED AS SB EIGHTY EIGHT SO
THERE YOU GO --
WE'RE EXPANDING THE CAPACITY
HERE THIS GRANTS DO WITH ORTIZ
TO THE BOARD AND EXPANDS OUR
ABILITY TO USE CONSOLIDATIONS AS
AN APPROPRIATE TOOL. TO ADDRESS
WATER SYSTEMS AND AS YOU
MENTIONED WITH ISSUE TWENTY NINE
COMING UP.
KEY TOOL ASSOCIATED WITH THAT.
OF THE SPECIFIC REQUEST IS FOR
SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND OF
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR
PERMANENT POSITIONS.
ADDRESSED A GREATLY EXPANDED
NUMBER POTENTIAL CONSULTING
LEAVE WILL OCCUR AS A RESULT OF
THIS --
REALLY COMBATING SMALL LARGE
PURSE GIVES ME COMBATING THE
APPLIED A SMALL WATER SYSTEMS IS
IS REALLY ONE OF OUR OUR MAIN
FUNCTIONS IN OUR BOWL ASSOCIATED
WITH.
A LOT OF THE WORK WE'RE DOING.
AND THE DIRECTION WE'RE GOING
THERE'S SEVEN THOUSAND FIVE AND
WATER SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA
COMPARED TO NINE HUNDRED WASTE
WATER SYSTEMS AND SEVENTY FIVE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES SO YOU CAN
SEE THE FRACTURED NATURE.
OF THE WATER UTILITY DELIVERY
SYSTEM IS JUST OUT OF COMPORT
WITH ITS OTHER COMPONENTS.
TOM AND AS WE DRESS THAT.
WE WE REALLY MOVING AHEAD 90% OF
OUR VIOLATIONS COME.
COMES WITH FIVE HUNDRED OR LESS
CONNECTIONS SO IT'S OBVIOUS
WHERE ARE BECAUSE OF CONCERN
LIES.
WITH THE UP.
AFTER SB EIGHTY EIGHT WE ADDED
TO STAFF TO WORK ON THIS
SPECIFIC AREA PRIOR TO THOSE TWO
STAFF WE HIT.
A CONSOLIDATION AVERAGE OF ABOUT
FOUR PER YEAR.
AFTER THAT STAFF WE'VE NOW DONE
FORTY IN ONE YEAR OR FORTY SIX
IN ONE YEAR AND FIFTEEN THE
OTHER FOR A TOTAL OF NINETY SIX
SO THOSE TWO STAFF OF MADE A BIG
DIFFERENCE.
WE BELIEVE THESE FOUR STAFFEL
TICKETS EVEN FARTHER IT IN
ADDRESSING THAT NEED.
I HELP ME UNDERSTAND THE ROLE OF
THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION WE'RE ASKING FOR
TO PERMANENT POSITIONS.
AND AND AGAIN IN MY MIND RIGHT
NOW IT'S EVERYBODY WANTS HAVE
MORE COLLABORATION PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT WE SHOULD BE LAYS.
LASER FOCUS ON THOSE WATER
BOARDS YEAH IT'S GREAT TO BRING
THEY HAVE A PUBLIC PROCESS
ALLEGEDLY.
ALLEGEDLY AND WHEN WE GO IN.
FOR IN IN --
YEAH OR POTENTIAL CONSOLIDATION
THAT'S I DON'T KNOW FIRED IF.
IT WAS SORT OF BLACK AND WHITE
IT'S IT'S IN A COUNTY YOU DON'T
HAVE THE ADMINISTRATIVE.
WHERE WITH ALL I DON'T HAVE TO
MAKE THE ABILITY TO READ THE
SYSTEM WHETHER THE PUBLIC KNOWS
OR NOT WE'VE GOT THE AUTHORITY?
TO ORDER THE CONSOLIDATIONS.
THAT IS SO THE ADDED SO OTHERS
OUT THERE IS A LOT OF PUBLIC
WORK TO GOES INTO IT FIRST THERE
ARE REQUIRED PUBLIC MEETINGS AS
PART OF THE LAW AND I I BELIEVE
THAT THEIR APPROPRIATELY THERE
FROM THE STANDPOINT OF GETTING
THE COMMUNITY ON BOARD WITH
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
A LOT OF TIMES WE DISCOVER
THERE'S A DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE
COMMUNITY AND THEN THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE SMALL WATER
SYSTEM.
AND KIND OF THEIR MOTIVATIONS SO
IT'S HELPFUL FOR US TO HAVE
THOSE PUBLIC MEETINGS THE
ESTABLISH.
THE COMMUNITIES CLEAR DESIRE TO
MOVE AHEAD WITH CONSOLIDATION WE
WOULD IT'S ALWAYS BETTER WHEN
IT'S DONE ON GOOD TERMS AND NOT
MANDATORY COMPONENTS SO WE DO A
LOT OF WORK UP FRONT TO TRY TO
GET IT TO BE BALLING.
FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE PARTY IN
THOSE.
THAT PUBLIC PARTICIPATION OF
SPECIALIST WE HAVE WE ALREADY
USM A TON ON THIS AND THIS IS
REALLY GOING TO BACK FILL THE
WORK THERE AND IT REALLY IT
ALLOWS TO EXTEND AND THIS IS NOT
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC HEARING CEASE
TO THE PUBLIC HEARINGS THAT WE
HAVE TO DO THAT'S ALREADY
REQUIRED.
WOULD JUST COULD BE DOING MORE.
CONSOLIDATION ACTIVITIES GIVEN
THE STATUS THAT THAT'S YES
ALRIGHT YES THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION --
LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
A HERE ON ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY ONE THE STATE
ADMINISTRATORS [inaudible]
CONSOLIDATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN AYE
REALIZATION OF WHAT COLOR BACK
TO BACK THERE AND MY CLAIBORNE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL --
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
PROPOSAL AS WELL ESPECIALLY
INSOFAR AS ITS IMPLEMENTING AB
TWENTY FIVE OH ONE WHICH GIVES
THE STATE THE STATE BOARD
AUTHORIZATION TO ORDER EXTENSION
OF SERVICE THE PRIVATE WELL
COMMUNITIES --
IT'S LONG PAST TIME TO START
ADDRESSING THOSE THAT HAVE
FAILING WELLS --
AND THOSE THAT HAVE WATER
QUALITY PROBLEMS AND THE PRIVATE
WELLS SO LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THAT.
AND SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL THANKS.
THANK YOU NEXT.
TURN MEMBERS JONATHAN NELSON
WITH THE COMMUNITY WATER CENTER.
I ALSO STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL --
THERE ARE AN ESTIMATED --
ROUGHLY TWO MILLION CALIFORNIANS
NOT SERVED BY PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS THESE ARE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS.
AND AGAIN THIS IS A TOOL IN THE
TO A LONG TIME TO BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY START CHIPPING AWAY AT
THAT PROBLEM BUT AS WE'LL TALK
ABOUT AT THE END OF THIS HEARING
THE OTHER.
PART OF THE COIN AGAIN IS THE
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING BUT WE
SUPPORT --
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL AND WE HAVE
SEEN AT THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION THE STATE WATER
BOARD HAS MADE A DIFFERENCE IN
COMMUNITIES THAT WE WORK WITH
AND COMMUNITY SOLUTIONS SO.
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THAT OFFICE
AS WELL THANK YOU.
IS THERE A MOTION TO APPROVE --
BUT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL BUSH BY CENTER MINING
CULTURAL.
ASKING BY [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONEY.
KEEP THAT MATTER --
OPEN.
I KNOW WILL PUT THE MATTERS
APPROVED BUT WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY TWO THIS IS OUR
WILDLIFE PREVENTION RECOVERY
LEGISLATION.
THE TIMBER HARVESTS.
EXEMPTION A UTILITY CORD OR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PERMITTING.
WHAT A TITLE FOR SB NINE A? ONE
TWENTY TWO POSITIONS
[inaudible]
I'M.
AND THE FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION
[inaudible]
MORNING THAT.
THIS BUDGET YEAR ONGOING IS.
OUR TEARS DOWN TO ONE POINT.
EIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON YES MISTER
CHAIR -- AS
YOU AS YOU NOTED WERE LOOKING --
FOR TWENTY TWO PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND THEN THE FUNDING
THAT YOU OUTLINED --
60% OF WHICH WOULD BE FROM THE
GENERAL FUND AND 40% FROM THE
WASTE DISCHARGE PERMIT FUND --
THE WATER BOARD --
I THINK AS WE ALL DO.
SUPPORT THE THE VERY BROAD
POSITIONS.
VISIONS OF THIS LEGISLATION IS
AIMED AT REDUCING.
THE RISK OF WILD FLOWER FIRE.
WILD FIRE AND ON INCREASED
FOREST'S RESILIENCY --
THOSE ARE VERY LAUDABLE.
GOALS IT IS GOING --
TO SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
THE OF OUTLANDER MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES AND AND THUS
DISTURBANCES TO THE ENVIRONMENT
WHICH MAY HAVE --
POTENTIAL IMPACTS ON WATER
QUALITY ACROSS THE STATE'S
THIRTY THREE MILLION ACRES OF
FOREST LAND AND ROUGHLY. FORTY
THREE THOUSAND MILES OF UTILITY
CORRIDORS AND SO THE THE IT'S
BEEN A NINE OH ONE WILL ALLOW.
REQUIRED THE WATER BOARDS --
TO FULFILL CERTAIN --
AND IMPLEMENTATION OBLIGATIONS
UNDER UNDER THE ACT AND WE'RE
ASKING FOR THE STAFFING TO DO
THAT -- SO.
WE ARE CONCERNED I THINK --
AND THOUGHT --
IT IS THAT IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
IF -- THE
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE AUTHORIZED
ARE NOT CONDUCTED --
APPROPRIATELY THAT IT THAT THERE
COULD BE AN INCREASE OF
SETTLEMENT PESTICIDE --
DISCHARGES TO WATERS OF THE
STATE THAT THEY COULD ALTER --
FOREST AND STREAM CHANNEL
HYDROLOGY BY INCREASING AND
CONCENTRATING STORM WATER RUNOFF
INCREASING EROSION AND POTENTIAL
SETTLEMENT DISCHARGES TO SCREEN
STREAMS --
INCREASE RISK TO DOWNSTREAM
INFRASTRUCTURE IF THERE ARE
LANDSLIDES.
ON THAT COULD AFFECT ROADS AND
LAND AND WATER CROSSINGS --
OR RESULT IN JUST THIS CHARGING
CHEMICALS IN THE FORM OF
PETROLEUM AND PESTICIDE PRODUCTS
THAT ARE USED ADJACENT TO OUR
UPSLOPE OF SURFACE WATERS.
I'M AND AND THAT ANY OF THOSE
IMPACTS COULD --
AFFECT BENEFICIAL USES OF STATE
SEVEN TATIAN WHICH COULD.
AFFECT HABITAT AND THUS THE
HEALTH OF AQUATIC SPECIES AND
AND THEIR HABITATS --
INCREASED POTENTIAL FOR ELEVATED
WATER TEMPERATURES AND RESULT IN
HUMAN HEALTH RISKS INCLUDING
THOSE FROM HARMFUL ALGAL BROOMS
BLOOMS --
AND POTENTIAL POTENTIALLY COULD --
THREATEN DRINKING WATER SUPPLIES
THROUGH INCREASED SETTLEMENT IN --
AN INTRODUCTION OF CHEMICAL
CONTAMINANTS.
SO PART OF WHAT WHAT WHAT THE
WATER BOARD AND WHAT'S ACT WHAT
WE'RE BOTH REQUIRED AN
AUTHORIZED TO DO UNDER SB. NINE
A ONE ARE TO FIRST DEVELOP A NEW
STATEWIDE GENERAL ORDER OF
PLEASE TAKE CHARGE DISK.
DISTRICT REQUIREMENTS A NEW
PERMIT FOR CONSTRUCTION AND
MAINTENANCE OF UTILITY QUARTERS --
AND THEIR ASSOCIATED --
ACCESS ROADS WITHOUT FOR SEVERAL
POSITIONS --
AT THE STATE WATER BOARD TO GO
THROUGH THAT.
I'M AND AND ALSO TO ESTABLISH A
SYSTEM FOR CONDUCTING FIELD
INSPECTIONS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
UTILITY QUARTER MAINTENANCE.
AND THEN ON THE OTHER MAJOR
COMPONENT --
IS.
TO INCREASE NUMBER POSITIONS OR
PROVIDE POSITIONS --
IN OUR REGIONAL BOARD OFFICES --
TO SUPPORT THE INCREASED NUMBER
OF FIELD INSPECTIONS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH
TIMBER --
WITH WITH SOME OF THE NON
DISCRETIONARY TIMBER HARVEST
EXEMPTIONS --
THESE EXEMPTIONS NOW LOW ALLOW
TEMPORARY ROAD BUILDING WITH NO
PRE PRE APPROVAL REVIEW --
WHICH IS WHICH IS FINE BUT IT
INCREASES OUR OUR IT STABLISHES
OUR NEED NOW TO INSPECT THE WORK
THAT IS DONE TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT IS DONE --
IN THE APPROPRIATE WAY AND THEN
IF NECESSARY TO PURSUE --
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS AGAINST
THOSE WHO ARE CUTTING AN
AUTHORIZED US DISCHARGES OF
WASTE INTO THE WATERS OF THE
STATE -- I I
DID WANT TO SAY I'M AM JUST ONE
THING ABOUT WHY IT --
MY THERE IS SUCH A SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND CONTRIBUTION TO
THIS -- ASK
AND THAT IS THAT --
UNDER THE TEN NINETY TWO WHICH
ESTABLISHED THE TIMBER
REGULATION AND FORCE RESTORATION
FUN THE BOARD IS PROHIBITED FROM
COLLECTING PERMIT FEES --
FROM COMMERCIAL TIMBER
HARVESTING OPERATION --
AND THERE FOR THE GENERAL FUND
HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED AS AN
APPROPRIATE SOURCE OF FUNDS --
TO TO SUPPORT THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE DEDICATED TO THE FOREST.
INSTEAD ENVIRONMENT I'M THE REST
OF THE FUNDING COMES OUT OF THE
THE IN NON FORESTED AREAS WOULD
COME OUT OF OUR OUR FEE BASED
FUNDING.
OKAY HELP ME ORCHESTRATOR SAID
SYMPHONY I'VE GOT YOUR FOLKS
THERE I'VE GOT.
WE'VE GOT. FIVE HUNDRED ACRES
WE'RE GONNA DO THIS XCELERATED
NINE OH ONE TIMBER HARVEST PLAN
I'VE GOT THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE I GOT.
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY I GET U. N.
F. GOT -- TO
CALIFORNIA WATER BOARD THERE ARE
REGIONAL WATER BOARD IS GONNA BE
THERE.
OBVIOUSLY THE LEGISLATURE HAS A
DESIRE ON THESE AND THESE PLANS
TO REDUCE THE FUEL THAT'S IN ON
THE ON THE FIELD.
WE'VE GOT.
FIELD INSPECTION.
GUIDE ARE WE GONNA HAVE
CONSOLIDATED FIELD INSPECTIONS
ARE WE GONNA HAVE THREE FIELD
INSPECTIONS BY EACH STATE AGENCY
[inaudible]
LOOK AT LET'S SAY THE ROAD.
RIGHT.
WE WILL COORDINATE WITH OUR
SISTERS SISTER AGENCIES TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE I'D.
DO NOT KNOW ABOUT THE TIMING OF
OUR INSPECTIONS AND WHETHER
THOSE ARE AND THAT.
CAN BE DONE IN IN SYNC OR NOT
AND WE CAN RELY ON EACH OTHER'S
WE WILL WE WILL HAPPILY LOOK
INTO THAT BUT I THINK THAT IN
BILL IN.
WE DID WORK WITH OUR WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN THE RESOURCE AGENCY
AND THIS AND THIS.
NUMBER OF POSITIONS OUT AND
ALLOCATION OF RESPONSIBILITIES
AS WHAT WE COLLECTIVELY --
AND CAME UP WITH IN THE RUN UP
TO THE PASSAGE OF OF OF THE
LEGISLATION I MEAN JUST YOU KNOW
FOR AN UNSOPHISTICATED CHAIR YES
MY I WOULD SAY.
WHEN YOU'RE PUT IN THE ROAD IN
AS YOUR THINNING THIS FOR US
THAT WAS SORT OF BE A GOOD
COMMONSENSE ACTION TO TAKE
PURSES WE'RE GONNA RUN RIGHT BY
THE?
THE THE WATERSHED ITS ALREADY.
COMPROMISE AND WE'RE GOOD RUN --
LOGGING TRUCKS UP THERE I MEAN.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE
GENERAL ORDER ON THE UTILITIES
WHICH WHICH MAY HAVE SOME
OVERLAPPING.
YOU KNOW.
INSURANCE WITH THE WATER QUALITY.
SO PUTTING IN PUTTING IN ROADS
AND YOU KNOW BEING BEING AM
CONSCIOUS OF THE THE THE SLOPES
THAT AND THE RISK THAT AND IT
UNTIL FOR RUN OFF DOING IT DOING
THE DOING THE WORK.
I'M RIGHT AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE --
LASTING IMPACT THESE ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE TEMPORARY ROADS.
THEY'RE THEY'RE JUST GONNA BE A
LOT OF ACTIVITIES A LOT OF THEM.
PRESSURE TO DO THEM. TO DO THEM
SOME I THINK THERE'S SOME COMMON
SENSE AND RULES OF THE ROAD THE
RULES OF THE ROAD THAT PEOPLE
WILL -- THAT
WHO ARE CONSTRUCTING THESE ROADS
WILL TAKE INTO ACCOUNT SOMETIMES
DOING THINGS --
FASTER DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
DOING THEM BETTER AND WE JUST
WANT TO BE ABLE --
TO CATCH.
THEM.
A POTENTIAL M. IMPROPER RISKY
ACTIVITY EARLY ON RATHER THAN
TRYING WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
SOME INVESTMENTS --
IN HABITAT RESTORATION THAT HAVE
BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS AND
YEARS IN SOME OF THESE WATERWAYS
AND CAN INVOLVE A LOT OF A LOT
OF MONEY FROM OUR ALL OF OUR
COLLECTIVE.
STATE AND FEDERAL PARTNERS AND
TRYING TO HAVING TO DO THAT --
IN OF MITIGATION --
ACTIVITY.
AGAIN OR AFTER THE FACT IS IF IF
WE CAN THROUGH TIMELY
INSPECTIONS AVOID OR REDUCE --
OR GET MEDICATION GOING QUICKLY
I THINK THAT --
THE LONG TERM INVESTMENT.
WILL BE PROTECTED AND WE WILL BE
ABLE TO GO AHEAD AND ALLOW THE
APPROPRIATE ACTIVITIES TO GO
PRIOR APPROVAL NORMALLY THIS
KIND OF ACTIVITY WHICH WOULD
HAVE BEEN DONE ANA.
SMALLER SCALE WOULD HAVE
INVOLVED EITHER WOULD HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED AT ALL OR WOULD HAVE
BEEN SUBJECT --
TO OUR REVIEW HEAD OF TIME SO
WE'RE SORT OF DOING I'M BACK AND
ACTIONS THEM.
BY A GUEST THE OTHER THING IS
THAT WE CAN JUST LET CAL FIRE
AND OUR FIRE TRUCKS GO UP.
AND FIGHT THE FIRE ACT AS YOU'RE
DOING IT AND JUST DEAL WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES I MEAN I DON'T KNOW
WE HAVEN'T HAD A REPORT OF WHAT
THE EROSION IN THE B..
T. WETLAND AND HOW WATERSHED
DAMAGE HAS BEEN FROM THE FIRES
AND WERE SORT OF DEALING WITH
THAT THE HUMAN CONSEQUENCES AND
AND THE BURN AND AND GETTING
THAT.
TOXIC.
MATERIALS ADDED THERE BUT WE
HAVEN'T WE HAVEN'T GONE THROUGH
WATERSHED BY WATERSHED AND SAY
WHAT WAS THE I GUESS IF I'M
PLAYING MONDAY MORNING
QUARTERBACK WHAT WAS THE
AVOIDABLE OR UNAVOIDABLE --
CONSEQUENCES AND WHAT'S THAT
COST COULD BE TRIED TO REPAIR
THAT RIPARIAN WAY --
SO HERE AT LEAST WE MAY BE
MOVING FAST BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE WE ALSO ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT NEXT FIRE AND AND HOW.
HOW THE?
WORKS TOGETHER ON THESE ON THESE
ACTIVITIES BECAUSE WE WANT TO
LOOK AT WHAT THE HARVEST TO GO
ON AND IN THAT CREW TO MOVE OVER
TO THE NEXT.
ONE AFTER THE OTHER RESOURCES TO
GO AND SAY.
WHOOPS.
WE COMPROMISED THIS RIPARIAN.
OUT WHERE THE HABITAT.
FIX THAT.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT REQUEST.
SO SO WE ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT --
IN THERE WHEN THEREIS WHEN WHEN
THERE IS A MASSIVE FIRE OR EVEN
A SMALLER FIRE THAT THERE.
OFTEN ARE VERY SUBSTANTIAL --
THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH I'M CONSEQUENCES AND THAT
THERE WERE THERE HAPPEN AND IN
SOME OF OUR RECENT FIRES A LOT
OF LANDSLIDES AND SEDIMENTATION
ISSUES AND HARM TO HABITAT AND
WE'VE.
HAD TO DO A LOT OF REMEDIATION
IF WE CAN FIND --
AND MITIGATION IF WE CAN FIND
SOME DOLLARS TO DO IT AND A LOT
OF IT HAS YOU KNOW WE WE AREN'T
ABLE -- TO
SO WE'RE NOT AN THAT THIS IS A
THIS IS A GOOD INVESTMENT IN.
REDUCING RISK UP FRONT RATHER
THAN --
DEALING WITH THE CONSEQUENCES OF
A BIG FIRE WE JUST THINK THAT
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THOSE ARE
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE THAT WE CAN --
IF IF WE HAVE THIS KIND OF
SUPPORT TO TRY --
TO SURE THAT THE THE MEASURES
THAT DO HAVE SOME IMPACTS ROAD
ROAD SEGMENTATION OVERALL --
IF IF THERE'S A LOT OF IT DOES
HAVE SOME.
SOME IMPACT AND AND WE CAN JUST
TRY TO MINIMIZE THAT I'M.
AS PART OF THIS LARGER FIRE
SUPPRESSION --
AND FOREST HEALTH INITIATIVE
THAT THAT'S A WIN WIN.
I GUESS THAT THE THE OBVIOUS
NEXT QUESTION WOULD BE.
YOU KNOW WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS WERE
USING THE FUN THAT WE HAVE.
PREVENTION AND AND THIS IS
INCLUDED IN THAT UMBRELLA WE
ALSO HAVE HEALTHY SOILS.
AND WE HAVE WETLAND REMEDIATION
WE KNOW THAT WE CAN WE CAN
IMPROVE WATER RETENTION BY JUST
BY JUST.
MAKING SURE THAT THE WATERSHED
IS SORT OF WORKING THE WAY IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE WORK AND I'M NOT
NOT A 100% --
I WASN'T EVEN A 100% OR IN
SCHOOL BUT BUT IF WE COULD GET
THE WATERSHED SORT OF DOING WHAT
IT'S SUPPOSED TO DO.
THAT NATURALLY THE WAY IT'S
BUILT MONEY INTO DIFFERENT AREAS
BUT JUST HAVE THE NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT WORK THE WAY IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE OR IN THAT AT
LEAST HAVE A IDEA THAT THEY
COULD RECOVER --
SO BECAUSE THAT IS THE AUCTION
[inaudible]
RESULTS.
MIGHT PROMPT THIS LEGISLATURE TO
PUT MORE MONEY INTO THIS TYPE OF
PROGRAM SO.
IT'S A HEADS UP I GUESS.
FROM FROM THIS POINT IS THAT WE
MAY WANT TO SEE MORE OF THIS
TYPE.
ON THE PREVENTION BUT I'M
HEARING YOU SAY THAT THAT WE
HAVEN'T DONE A REALLY GOOD JOB
ON THE RESTORATION FOR THAT WERE
ALL THE FIRES HAVE ALREADY BEEN
BUT SHOULD BE AT A HEALTHY SOILS.
YOU KNOW.
PROGRAM SO.
I'M.
I THINK THAT.
POST POST FIRE RESTORATION IS
YOU KNOW T ABOUT.
AN ISSUE THAT WE'RE ALL HAVING
TO COME TO TERMS WITH WITH AND
THINK ABOUT AND HAS ACTUALLY
HELPED US.
FOCUS AND GET BEHIND I AM.
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT AS
FREQUENTLY --
AND I GUESS ALL --
AND AND SO I I HEAR YOU I
MESSAGE RECEIVED THAT IF THIS IS
SUCCESSFUL --
MAYBE THEY'LL BE MORE OF IT AND
I I THINK THAT --
OUR MESSAGE IS IS THAT WE'RE ALL
FOR IT AND WE JUST WANT.
TO REINFORCE THE TO BE DONE AND
THEN -- I
SPOKE WAY IF POSSIBLE TO PROTECT
WATER WATER QUALITY I'M.
SO THAT WE AGAIN SO THAT WE
MAXIMIZE THE BENEFITS --
AND MINIMIZE THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THIS WORK I I COMPLETELY
KNOWLEDGE IT'S LESS --
OF DISTURBING AND DEVASTATING
AND THEN --
TO TO THE ENVIRONMENT AND THE
BENEFICIAL WATER USES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THEN MAJOR
WILDFIRES BUT IF WE'RE GOING TO
DO SOMETHING IN IT WE SHOULD
PROBABLY BEHOOVES US TO DO IT.
RIGHT AND WHILE.
HELLO COMMENT.
I REALIZE THAT I SAID I WAS
GOING -- TO
HOLD THE OR HAVE A PUBLIC
HEARING ON THE MATTER ISRAEL
BEHOLD OPEN AT THE END OF THE
APARTMENT BUT THIS IS THE ONLY
MATTER THAT.
IS BEFORE US WITH THE STATE%
WATER RESOURCES BOARD THAT WE'RE
ASKING THE WHOLE OPEN SO.
WILL CONDUCT A PUBLIC HEARING
NOW SO IF THERE'S ANYBODY HERE
INTERESTED.
IN COMMENTING ON ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY TWO WILDFIRE PREVENTION
RECOVERY LEGISLATION PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING WAS A
MOTION BY SEN --
BATTLE.
WE DON'T HAVE A IGNORE THAT
MOTION.
AND AND CENTER REQUIRE THANK YOU
SO MUCH IS THE CHAIR AND I DO
APOLOGIZE AND HAVE.
TO COME TO THE FISH FORM AND
I'LL BE COMING BACK OBVIOUSLY TO
VOTE.
BUT BEFORE I DO IT IS GOING TO
TAKE A MOMENT NOT EXACTLY IN
THIS ISSUE BUT RELATED ISSUE --
THAT THE BOARD HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY INVOLVED WITH AND THAT
IS THE RECOVERY IN LAKE COUNTY
BEEN AN ACTIVE ENGAGE PARTNER --
BOTH ON CONSOLIDATION UP IN COBB.
A COMMENT IN IS WELL --
AS HELPING BUILD OUT THE SEWER
PROJECT ANDERSON SPRINGS WE CAN
REBUILD.
THOSE UNDER NINETEEN HOME TO
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THAT.
WERE BURNED DOWN IN THIS WHEN I
SAY THANK YOU TO YOUR STAFF I
AIM TO THE ENTIRE TEAM FOR ALL
OF YOUR SYSTEMS OVER THESE PAST.
THREE YEARS IT'S BEEN A HELL OF
A THREE YEARS AND WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL CAN BE DOING WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITHOUT YOU JUST WANNA SAY
THANK YOU.
ALL THE ISSUE OPEN MOVING ON THE
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THREE THIS
IS OR FAN SITE CLEANUP FUNDS.
PETROLEUM CONTAMINATION ORPHAN
SITES [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
THE STATE BOARD IS REQUESTING A
TEN MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION FOR THE PETROLEUM
CONTAMINATION OR FAN SITE
CLEANUP FUN --
IN FISCALYEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY WE
DO HAVE PROJECTS THAT ARE
WAITING ON ARE AWAITING
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE AND WILL
WILL.
WILL OR COULD BE FUNDED AS SOON
AS THE AUTHORITY IS AVAILABLE --
SO -- THESE
ARE SITES WHERE THERE ISN'T --
I AND AND IDENTIFIED AT RISK
IDENTIFIED RESPONSE PARTY BUT WE
DO HAVE --
AN ENTITY THAT'S ONE WILLING AND
ABLE TO GO IN AND DO DO THE
CLEAN UP THIS THE DEMAND FOR
THIS.
GOES UP AND DOWN --
ACCORDING TO SAY YOU KNOW BASED
ON CERTAIN FACTORS BUT AT THE
MOMENT WE DO HAVE SOME --
WE HAVE SOME PROJECTS IN THE
QUEUE AND WE SAID AND FOR YOU
KNOW THAT THIS IS VALUABLE IN
TERMS OF PROTECTING HUMAN HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND SHOWING OUR
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT AND
RESTORE GROUND WATER QUALITY
[inaudible]
L. [inaudible]
WE DON'T.
THIS IS THE LAST --
ONE I MISSED IT EARLIER ITEMS ON
ISSUE --
SIXTEEN CAM K<c.cyan> ACCORDING TO</c>
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL WE JUST WANT TO SUPPORT
THE BUDGET REQUESTS FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB.
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN ESTABLISHMENT
MISTREAT OF HEARINGS OFFICE --
WE BELIEVE THAT THESE RESOURCES
ARE CRITICAL FOR THE WATER BOARD
TO BE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY
ENFORCE WATER RATES --
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR WATER
RIGHTS HOLDERS YOUR EARLIER
RECOMMENDATION TO CLOSE THAT
ITEM IN THE PREVIOUS BUDGETED
AND SORRY I MISSED EARLIER.
RIGHT.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING ON I ALL
ISSUES RIVER RELATED STATE WATER
RESOURCE SUPPORT AT THIS PART OF
OUR HEARING --
THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER
REQUIRE DISAPPROVE THE OR OR CAN
SITE CLEAN UP.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASKING I TENS REQUIRE.
MONEY STERN.
WE'LL KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN.
DON'T GO TOO FAR AWAY LET'S CALL
UP THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE [inaudible]
WE HAVE [inaudible] THREE
MATTERS.
HAVE A BATCH MATTERS THIS IS
WHAT START OFF WITH THE THE
OVERVIEW IF YOU HAVE ANY.
NUMBER THIS IS SAID DEPUTY
MASAHARU.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON A CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MEMBER MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE.
I YEAH REAL QUICK OVERVIEW --
THAT OUR BUDGET FOR NINETEEN
TWENTIES APPROXIMATELY FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS INCLUDING
OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY COMPONENTS.
AND DAD IS EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
ELEVEN POINT SEVEN POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT ALL OF OUR DEPARTMENT
OPERATIONS.
I A CAN RUN THROUGH OUR VARIOUS
FUNDS THAT'S A HUNDRED ALMOST A
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
OF AG FUND.
FEDERAL FUNDS AT A HUNDRED AND
SEVEN GENERAL FUND AT A HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN FORTY THREE POINT
SEVEN FOR CANNABIS CAN POINT ONE
FOR THE DROUGHT WATER PARKS
CLIMATE COASTAL PROTECTION
OUTDOOR ACCESS FUND. FORTY THREE
MILLION FOR GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDS.
AND TWENTY SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION AND OTHER FUNDS.
AND IF AND I NOTICED THAT WE
HAVE A A NET REDUCTION OF SIXTY
TWO MILLION.
AS IN FOR THE DAIRIES THE
METHANE READ REDUCTION.
I GAG I GUESS SOME OF THAT'S
OFFSET BY THE HEALTH HEALTHY
SOILS.
AS I KNOW YOU SEE OF COMMENTS
FROM PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
CONTINUE THAT ANAEROBIC DIGESTER
IN THE IN THE NEWER MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS.
YEAH I HAVE CURRENT YEAR WE GOT
NINETY NINE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
JERRY DIED GESTURES AND
ALTERNATIVE NOR MANAGEMENT.
AND SO THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL THIS YEAR BRINGS THAT
DOWN.
TO TWENTY FIVE THAT WAS THE THE
BIGGEST PART OF THAT REDUCTION.
IN IN THE HEALTHY SOILS ARE
REDUCTION [inaudible]
I AM.
THAT ONE OF SIXTY EIGHT WE HAVE.
IT SEEMED LIKE THERE WERE STILL
SPACE AND PROP SIXTY FOR THE
HEALTHY SOILS.
YES WE DO HAVE SOME FUNDING AND
PROP SIXTY EIGHT ON HEALTHY
SOILS.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE SOME
FUNDING AND GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION ALSO FOR HEALTHY SOILS.
WE HAVE IT IN TWO DIFFERENT
PLACES NOW.
RIGHT I GUESS THE COULD THE
QUESTION IS IS THAT IF YOU.
THE SOONER YOU MAKE THE SOILS
HEALTHIER OR START THAT PROCESS
THE BETTER MORE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION MORE PRODUCTIVITY --
IS IT A PROBLEM OF GETTING.
FARMERS ARE PEOPLE ARE TO
PARTICIPATE WITH WITH IT OR IS
THERE A IS JUST GENERALLY.
SO YOU'RE WANTING TO KNOW ARE WE
COMFORTABLE OR WHAT ARE WE
GETTING DONE WITH WHAT'S BEEN
ALLOCATED.
YEAH IT IS A PROCESS WE HAVE TO
START AND RELIES LARGELY ON
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS.
IN SOME OF THOSE ARE ON
INDIVIDUAL FARMS AND IN SOME OF
THOSE WILL BE COLLECTIVELY WERE
OTHER GROWERS IN THE AREA COULD
COME AND VIEW THEM.
AND PROJECTS THERE RELATE HEALTH
OF SOILS ARE GENERALLY THINGS
THAT NEED TO HAPPEN OVER TIME --
YOU KNOW THERE'S SOME THINGS
THAT YOU CAN APPLY SAY COMPOST
MATERIALS MAKES OBSERVATIONS AND
HAVE MEASURABLE RESULTS.
BUT THERE'S OTHER THINGS THAT
INVOLVE THE GROWING OF COVER
CROPS OR SPECIFICALLY ALTERING
CHIT TILLAGE PRACTICES FROM WHAT
THEY HAD BEEN LONG STANDING.
IN MEASURING THOSE RESULTS OVER
TIME.
SO YEAH IT IS THIS KIND OF A
SLOW YOU KNOW FROM THE THE
PERSPECTIVE OF SOME THINGS YOU
CAN PUT MONEY TOWARDS AND YOU
CAN SEE IMMEDIATE MEASURABLE
RESULTS AND SAY THAT'S A GOOD
PRACTICE.
SO THIS ONE HERE BECAUSE GROWING
CYCLES GENERALLY RUN THROUGHOUT
THE THE SEASONAL PATTERN IT
TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF TIME BUT
YEAH WE DO.
WHO WHO SHARE YOUR INTEREST IN
THIS OBVIOUSLY AND WE WANT TO
PLACE THIS MONEY OUT THERE WITH
PROJECTS THAT ARE TO US GOING TO
HAVE A HIGH DEGREE OF SUCCESS?
IN A SPECIALLY REPEATABILITY IF
IT IS A GOOD PRACTICE AND WE CAN
MEASURE THOSE POSITIVE IMPACTS.
AND THEN WE CAN GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT THERE SO THAT
OTHER GROWERS AND RANCHERS ADOPT
THOSE PRACTICES AS QUICKLY AS
THEY CAN BECAUSE YOU'RE RIGHT.
THE QUICKER THEY ADOPTED IN THE
MORE WE GET THE OVERALL BIG
PICTURE RESULT THAT WE'RE AFTER --
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A FILE ON THIS.
WILLIAM A COMMENT ON THAT YOUR
FOR YOU FOR HEALTHY SOILS NOW WE
ASK [inaudible]
FROM [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
VERY GOOD LET'S.
WITH THAT OVERVIEW LET'S MOVE
THE ISSUE NUMBER.
LET'S MOVE TO TURLOCK ANALYST
POSITION NUMBER TWENTY FOUR YOUR
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR IS FOR ALMOST
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL
FUND FOR THE PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA PHASE OF THE DESIGN
BUILD PROJECT. FOR A NEW FULL
SERVICE K. CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
HEALTH HEALTH AND FOOD SAFETY
LABORATORY SYSTEM LABORATORY IN
THE NORTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
THIS ONE'S GOING TO REPLACE AN
EXISTING FACILITY THIS.
OBSOLETE IS PROBABLY NOT EVEN A
STRONG ENOUGH WORD IT'S BOTH
OBSOLETE IN ITS AGENTS
FUNCTIONALITY BUT ALSO IN ITS
SIZE.
WELL RIGHT NOW WE ONLY PROCESS
AVIAN US.
A SAMPLES THERE WE CAN'T HANDLE
ANYMORE MILLION ROOM THERE IN
THE NECROPSY AREA TO HANDLE
LARGE ANIMAL LIKE A DAIRY COW.
AND AS YOU'RE AWARE TURLOCK SITS
IN THE MIDDLE OF JERRY COUNTRY
SO WE REALLY DO NEED THAT
CAPACITY SO THIS.
LAB IS ESSENTIAL FOR US TO HAVE
THAT PRESENCE --
BUT IMPORTANT TO KNOW RIGHT NOW
IN THE TIMES THAT WERE IN THAT
WE FIND OURSELVES WITH.
KEEPING THAT LAB CAPACITY GOING
WERE RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF A
VERY VERY BIG EFFORT TO TRY TO
WRAP A KATE.
VERY WANT NEWCASTLE DISEASE
WHICH RIGHT NOW IS MOSTLY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT AS
RECENT AS LAST WEEK WE DID HAVE
A SINGLE FIND UP HERE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WHICH HAS THE PRODUCERS AND THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY VERY EDGY.
SO IT JUST UNDERSCORES THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS LABORATORY
NETWORK THAT WE MAINTAIN AN TWO
YEARS AGO THE BUDGET HAD
ACQUISITION COSTS.
INCLUDED IN AND THAT IS THIS.
WRESTLING THESE THAT'S A G. SENT
TO THE CURRENT FCILITY OR IS
THIS.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS IT'S NOT
IT'S LOCATED A FEW MILES AWAY.
BECAUSE ADJACENT I DON'T BELIEVE
IT HAD THE CAPACITY TO REALLY
BUILD OUT A LAB [inaudible]
OKAY -- I'M
YOU STILL OWN THE PROPERTY ON
THE CURRENT LAP.
THE CURRENT YEAH THE CURRENT LAB
IN THE PROPERTY THERE THOSE VERY
MINUSCULE.
FOR WHEN YOU COMPARE TO THIS LAB
OR GOING FROM ABOUT FIFTY ONE
HUNDRED SQUARE FEET ABOUT FORTY
ONE THOUSAND SQUARE FEET.
SO IT WILL BE [inaudible]
WE APPROVE THE REQUEST.
AND WE GO INTO THE DESIGN BUILD
PROCESS HE GETS DONE WHAT DO YOU
SEE HAPPENING WITH A FIFTY ONE
FOOT FACILITY DECEPTICON --
AVIAN SPECIES FACILITY IS GET
RENOVATED DOES A GET.
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE
[inaudible]
DEPARTMENTS [inaudible]
ASSET.
IN YOUR CHART FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BUT ACTUALLY GO THROUGH
THE SURPLUS PROPERTY PROCESS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES.
THE LOOK AT THE EXISTING
FACILITY SEE IF THERE IS A USE.
ONE I CONTINUE TO USE BY --
DEPARTMENT FOR NAGRA CULTURE
WHICH WE DON'T ANTICIPATE BUT
ALSO IF ANOTHER STATE ENTITY MAY
HAVE A USE EVEN IF IT WERE
RENOVATED OR IF IT WAS
COMPLETELY DEMOLISHED IN --
COULD BE IS THE LAND AND THEN
FROM THERE IT GOES THROUGH THEIR
NORMAL PROCESS.
I'VE SURPLUS THE NORMAL EGS
PROCESS WELL YEAH DURING GO TO
ANOTHER LOCAL GOVERNMENT ENTITY
A COUNTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
THEN BRINGING THAT WE CAN COME
UP WITH AND BETTER PROCESS AND
ALL MY TO RESPECT TO THE PEOPLE
THAT WORK FOR D. G. S. IS JUST
SEEMS.
MIND BOGGLING SOMETIMES HOW
INEFFICIENT WE ARE WITH WITH
DEALING WITH THAT PROCESS ELLIE
OKAY YOU HAVE A AN ANIMAL HEALTH
LABORATORY COMMENT.
WE DIDN'T RAISE ANY ISSUES WITH
THE PROPOSAL.
OKAY -- THIS
IS.
THIS IS --
ALMOST FOUR MILLION DOLLAR.
NEW FACILITY LABORATORY LET'S
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON ISSUE
NUMBER [inaudible]
TWENTY FOUR HAVE A COMMENT.
IS MAKE SURE I JUST WANTED
FINANCE.
AND I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
THE FOUR MILLION AS FOR THE
DESIGN PHASES NOT THE ENTIRE
LABORATORY WHICH WILL BE MUCH
MORE COSTLY AND I'M SURE YOU.
KNEW THAT BUT I WANTED TO
CLARIFY.
ITS DESIGN BUILD RIGHT WE'RE
GOING FROM DESIGN DETAILED
DESIGN BUILD SO THIS WOULD BE
THE DESIGN WE WILL COME FORWARD
NEXT YEAR OR THE YEAR AFTER
DEPENDING ON SCHEDULE WITH THE
BUILD.
OKAY I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU WERE ALWAYS DONE BY
WORKING DRAWINGS THE COST OF A
WORKING DRAWING ON IT NOW AND
AND THAT CONCEPTUAL CONS.
I MEAN.
IT'S I'M SURE.
THERE MUST BE SOMEBODY ELSE MUST
HAVE A LAB SOMEWHERE BUT THIS
MAY BE THE STATE OF THE ART OKAY.
HI MY NAME IS ASHLEY HILL AND
I'M AT AN ACTING CO DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL HEALTH AND
FOOD SAFETY LABORATORY WHICH IS
THE SYSTEM.
OF WHICH THIS LABORATORY IS A
PART OF AND I JUST WANT.
TO THANK --
WELL EXPRESS SINCE TO THE CHAIR
IN THE COMMITTEE I'M WE ARE
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING
ABLE TO REPLACE THIS AGING AND
OUTDATED FACILITY --
UP WITH BOTH THE LAB THAT CAN
STOCK IN THAT AREA AS WELL AS
IMPROVED CAPACITY FOR HANDLING
POULTRY RELATED ISSUES --
AS PEOPLE HAVE MENTIONED THERE
ARE SOME EXISTING --
ISSUES AFFECTING THE CAMANCHE
COMMERCIAL.
AND YOU KNOW COMMERCIAL AND
BACKYARD POULTRY INDUSTRIES.
AND WE JUST HAD AN ISSUE COME UP
YESTERDAY WHERE A COUPLE OF THE
MAJOR POULTRY PRODUCERS IN THE
AREA.
ARE EXPERIENCING AN INFECTIOUS
KARAI IS A OUTBREAK AND THE
TESTING THAT WE WOULD LOVE TO BE
DOING IN THE TURLOCK LABORATORY
WE CAN'T DO THERE BECAUSE OF THE
EXISTING FACILITY LIMITATIONS SO
IT.
THE SAMPLES ARE HAVING TO BE.
DRIVEN UP TO DAVIS TO BE DOING
THE TESTING UP HERE WHICH YOU
KNOW SLOWS DOWN TURN AROUND TIME
AND THE POULTRY INDUSTRY HAS
EXPRESSED THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS I JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT
THANK YOU.
OKAY WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING I'M.
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
APPROVE AS PROPOSED.
CENTER MINING MOVES PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ASKING BY OWNS MCGUIRE
MONNING.
KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN FOR OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE BIO DIVERSITY INITIATIVE.
YES THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST FOUR
POINT TWO MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND AUTHORITY FOR FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY AND THREE POINT
NINE MILLION IN GENERAL FUND.
AUTHORITY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PLAN ON GOING AND EIGHT
POSITIONS TO INITIATE.
PLANNING AND COORDINATION OF THE
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BIO DIVERSITY
INITIATIVE ROAD MAP.
OF THIS PROPOSAL ALSO REQUEST
FUNDING TO RESTORE PHASE NOXIOUS
WEED MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
THE GOALS OF THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
INCLUDE ESTABLISHING THE
CALIFORNIA BIO DIVERSITY
INITIATIVE WORKING GROUP.
AND THAT WORKING GROUP WILL BE
CO CHAIRED BY THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND THE SECRETARY OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE.
WHAT WE ENVISION HAPPENING HERE
IS ACCELERATING AND STREAMLINING
PREVENTION DETECTION AND
MANAGEMENT OF INVASIVE SPECIES
AND PASSED EXPANDING SETON GERM
PLASM BANKING AS A HEDGE AGAINST
PERMANENT LOSS OF NAY NATIVE
PLANT BIODIVERSITY?
AND ESTABLISHING A SOIL CARBON
MAP OF CALIFORNIA.
DUE TO OUR AGRICULTURAL
WARRANTED MISSION CDFA AS UNIQUE
EXPERTISE SEAT IDENTIFICATION
SEED PHYSIOLOGY AND SEE QUALITY
ASSESSMENT.
THE FAA'S WILLING TO CONTRIBUTE
ITS EXPERTISE AND COLLABORATE
WITH OTHER AGENCIES UNIVERSITIES
AND NGOS TO WORK TOWARDS THE
SAME GOAL PRESERVING AND
PROTECTING NATIVE PLANT
BIODIVERSITY.
AND HELP IDENTIFY GAPS IN
EXISTING EFFORTS.
I KNOW THERE'S SOME CONCERNS
THAT MAYBE THERE'S DUPLICATION
OF EFFORT.
AND THERE'S A A LACK OF
COORDINATION WITH SOME OF OUR
OTHER AGENCIES OR SOME OTHER
ENTITIES THAT ARE ALREADY DOING
SOME OF THIS WORK.
SO WE JUST WANT TO ASSURE THE
CHAIR THAT --
WE REALIZE THOSE CONCERNS ARE
OUT THERE AND WE VERY MUCH WANT
TO WORK IN ALL OF THE AREAS THAT
NEED THE ATTENTION AND THE
EXPERTISE THAT OUR DEPARTMENT
CAN PROVIDE.
AND WE WILL GLADLY DEFER TO
OTHER AGENCIES OR EVEN NON
GOVERNMENTAL OPERATIONS TO
HANDLE THE AREAS THAT THEIR BEST
POSITION TO DO THE WORK WE
APPRECIATE THAT WE WANTED IF
THEY ENCOURAGED BY THE
COLLABORATION WE JUST.
WANTED FIGURE OUT WHERE THE
HOUSE AT YOU KNOW WHO SHOULD BE
DOING.
YEAH AND THE TOUCH ON IS A GERM
PLASM BANK.
YEAH AND WE HAVE SAID WE HAVE
LABORATORY TRAINED BOTANIST WHO
ARE VERY WELL VERSED IN THIS
AREA.
AND SO WE FEEL THAT WE CAN BE
VERY VALUABLE IN THIS OP.
THERE ARE GERM PLASM BANKS THAT
EXIST AROUND THE STATE A LOT OF
THEM AROUND AND HIT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
WE'RE ASKING FOR MONEY TO DO A
STUDY TO IDENTIFY WHAT IS THE
BEST.
ROLE FOR US TO PLAY AN OUT YOU
SHOULD WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
ENHANCING OUR CURRENT LAB
FACILITY TO TRY TO DO MORE IN
THIS AREA [inaudible]
OKAY.
HELLO YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON
TERMS LASSEN BANK WILL SHOW MY
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WOULDN'T RAISE ANY
SPECIFIC ISSUES WITH IT BUT AS
NOTED IN THE ENGINE DAY.
THERE IS A QUESTION OF WHETHER
THE GERM PLASM BANK --
ITS MISSION ALIGNS MORE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE.
OR WITH THAT --
DEPARTMENT IF IT NOW WITH
CULTURE THINK IS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD NOW WITH CULTURE POINTED
OUT THE INVASION THIS IS AS
ATTENTIVELY SOMEONE WHERE THEY
WOULD USE THEIR EXISTING
LABORATORY CAPACITY.
ON AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO OKAY.
OKAY TO HOLD THE MATTER OPEN
LET'S CONTINUE HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS LET'S MOVE TO THE
I'M GONNA SCREW THIS UP --
ASIAN CITRUS.
PHYLLIS DILLER PHYLLIS IN THE
LONG LONG BEING.
DOT ACTION.
YEAH THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND AUTHORITY IN TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION IN AGRICULTURAL FUND.
TO FORTY AND SIXTY FIVE
POSITIONS IN FISCAL NINETEEN
TWENTY AN ON GOING.
BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING AS AS
WE'RE GOING WE'RE PROPOSING TO
STAND UP THE NEW DIVISION THAT
WILL FOCUS ON FIGHTING BOTH THE
ASIAN CITRUS PSYLLID AND THE
RESULTANT DISEASE LONG LONG BANG.
AND SO.
THE CURRENT EFFORT RIGHT NOW
EXIST PRIMARILY WITHIN ONE MAJOR
LARGE --
BRANCH WITHIN OUR CURRENT
DIVISION OF PLANT HILLS AND PEST
PREVENTION.
AND WE FEEL THAT THIS BETTER
POSITIONS US TO TAKE THESE NEW
RESOURCES AND PAIR THESE UP WITH
SOME RESOURCES THAT OF BECOME
SOMEWHAT DEDICATED OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS IN THIS EFFORT.
AND PULL THEM INTO AN
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE THAT
WILL BE FOCUSED SINGULARLY ON
THESE -- TWO
CITRUS THREAT HERE.
AND WE THINK THAT THAT'S GOING
TO HELP US OPERATE IT'S GOING TO
KEEP THE FOCUS THE TRAINING THE
LOCATION OF THE STAFF IN AREAS
WHERE THEY CAN RESPOND REALLY
QUICKLY TO NEW DETECTIONS.
AND ALSO TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND
AND ENHANCE EXISTING WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE IN THIS AREA.
AND SIMILARLY SPEAKING THEN IT
FREES UP SOME OF THAT FROM OUR
EXISTING DIVISION THAT HAS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ALL TYPES OF
RESPONSES NECESSARY WHEN THERE'S
A PEST DETECTION SUCH AS MED FLY
ORIENTAL FRUIT FLYER.
IN ASIAN GYPSY MOTH OR THINGS
LIKE THAT.
SO WE FEEL OPERATIONALLY THAT --
THIS IS.
THE RIGHT TIME IN THE RIGHT WAY
TO DO THIS.
LA -- DO YOU
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT WHY SEVEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IS
LEFT OVER FROM THIS CURRENT
YEAR'S BUDGET WE WE DID
RECOMMEND THAT YOU ASK ASK THAT
QUESTION ALONG WITH SEVERAL
OTHERS THAT ARE NOTED IN THE
AGENDA.
AND BUT WE ARE RECOMMENDING
APPROVAL OF THIS PROPOSAL --
GIVEN THE RECENT SPREAD OF ASIAN
CITRUS SELIGMAN LONG BEING AND
THAT -- FACT
THAT AIDS IS CONTINUES TO SPREAD
A SHOWN BY SOME OF THE GRAPHICS
IN YOUR IN YOUR AGENDA.
WE THINK THIS REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL STAFF AND IT'S A
DIVISION IS REASONABLE.
SO LET'S GO BACK TO THE
DEPARTMENT.
WE GOT THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
IN FEDERAL FUNDS IN THREE POINT.
EIGHT NINE MILLION IN STATE
FUNDS FROM THIS BUDGET THAT
YOU'RE NOT GETTING.
DON'T EXPECT TO EXHAUST.
ON THE GENERAL FUND SIDE YES
THAT IS CORRECT WE GOT A ONE
TIME INFUSION --
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR OF TEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND IT WAS ALWAYS GET A LARGE
INFUSION LIKED OUT OF ONE TIME
DOLLARS TO EFFECTIVELY SPEND IT --
BECAUSE YOU OBVIOUSLY DON'T WANT
TO LEAN TOWARDS PERMANENT
POSITIONS THAT MAY BE LEFT ON
FUNDED IN FUTURE YEARS.
AND SO YOU REALLY HAVE TO FOCUS
IN ON EFFORTS TO COULD BE ONE
TIME IN NATURE --
HOWEVER WE DID PUT THE MONEY
WHERE WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
MOST EFFECTIVE.
AND AS WE SPEAK THIS CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR WE'VE COME A LONG
WAYS AND WE'RE STILL GONNA MAKE
PROGRESS ON THE CERTAIN CHANGES
IN OUR LAB PROTOCOLS IN THE WAY
WE HANDLE SAMPLES AND WE'RE
INCREASING OUR THROUGHPUT TO BE
ABLE TO PROCESS SOME OF THE
SAMPLES THAT COME IN OUT.
OF THE FIELD SO THAT GOING
FORWARD IN THE FUTURE WE CAN
HIRE MORE PERMANENT STAFF TO
COLLECTED DO MORE SAMPLING WORK
CAN BE ABLE TO HANDLETHOSE
WITHOUT CREATING BOTTLENECKS AT
THE LAB.
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING SO WE KNOW PART OF
THIS.
REVOCATION PROCESS IS GETTING
INTO THE PROPERTIES OF FOLKS IS
NOT THE COMMERCIAL.
OUR FRUIT PEOPLE THIS IS THE THE
THE GUY WITH AN ORANGE TREE IN
HIS I HIS BACKYARD AND I KNOW
FROM LAST YEAR'S HEARING HERE
BEFORE THERE WAS A PROBLEM OF OF
GETTING ACCESS TO PEOPLE'S HOUSE.
AND AND DEALING WITH
[inaudible]
THE THE DETECTION AN ERADICATION.
YEAH THOSE WILL ALWAYS BE
ASPECTS OF THE PROGRAM THAT WILL.
HAVE TO STRUGGLE WITH INNER
CHALLENGES WE THINK WE'RE DOING
A REALLY GOOD JOB WE A LOT OF
THIS MONEY ALSO GOES TOWARDS OUR
REACH EFFORTS SO THAT WE CAN
EDUCATE THE COMMUNITIES ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUR EARLY
DETECTION WORKING PART OF OUR
EARLY DETECTION WORK RELIES ON
ACCESS. TO THE CITRUS TREES TO
BE ABLE TO PULL LEAVE SAMPLES
AND SEND THEM TO OUR LAB.
IS EARLIER WE CAN DETECT THE
DISEASE IN A TREE IN THE EARLIER
WE CAN RESPOND TO IT AND YES IT
DOES --
RESULT IN ABATEMENT OF THAT TREE
WHICH A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T LIKE.
BUT WE HAVE FOUND THAT MOST
PEOPLE ONCE THEY BECOME EDUCATED
ON THE DEVASTATING IMPACT OF THE
DISEASE --
NOT ONLY TO CALIFORNIA IN
GENERAL BUT JUST TO THE WHOLE
NEIGHBORHOOD ALL THEIR NEIGHBORS
HAVE TREES IN A LOT OFPEOPLE
HAVE MULTIPLE TREES ALTHOUGH
SOMETIMES WE END UP HAVING TO
SUGGEST THAT.
A LOT OF MORE INTERESTING HE TO
ME I THINK PEOPLE.
LIKE HIM FOR THE DECORATIVE I
MEAN I GOT A DWARF LEMON TREE
AND I GOT MORE LEMONS AND WHAT
TO DO WITH.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU DO WITH IT
JOHN I'M MARC COUPLE MONSTER
ORANGE TREES AIR A LOT.
YES A LOT OF ORANGE THIS LOT
ORANGES TO ALL RIGHT WE DO WORK
THROUGH THOSE CHALLENGES OF
PROPERTY ACCESS --
BUT WE WE FEEL WE DO A PRETTY
PRICE.
NOT EXPANDING OUR FEDERAL FUNDS
A WE WILL FULLY EXPAND OUR
FEDERAL FUNDS UNFORTUNATELY AS
WE WERE COMMUNICATING NUMBERS
BACK AND FORTH WE MISS ESTIMATED
AT NUMBER AND WE HAD ESTIMATED
ARE FEDERAL FUNDS TO BE AT
FIFTEEN MILLION THIS YEAR.
AND WE'RE ONLY GONNA EXPAND
TWELVE BUT OUR FEDERAL FUNDS ARE
ONLY GOING TO BE AT TWELVE SO WE
EXPECT TO FULLY EXPAND ON SO
GENERALLY YOU KNOW HE TOUCHES
RESULT IN AN ACCOUNTING ERROR ON
OUR PART THAT WE WERE WORKING
WITH THE WRONG NUMBERS.
WE HAD SOME OF OUR DIALOGUE WITH
LA L..
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION.
I'M.
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN UP PUBLIC
HEARING ANYBODY HERE.
WITH THIS.
CITRUS PEST AND DISEASE
PREVENTION OUR PROGRAM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I MAY TOUCH ON DRAW FROM
PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK.
ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM WE OPPOSE THE CITRUS BEST
IN DISEASE PREVENTION PROGRAM%
RESOURCE ASK FOR FIVE MILLION
UNLESS.
AS AMENDED TO ADD FUNDING FOR
CDFA STAFF POSITIONS FOR
INCREASING CITRUS PLANT
RESILIENCE TO TACKLE HLB DISEASE.
SO FAR CDFA HAS FOCUSED ON PEST
CONTROL AND PEST MANAGEMENT
OPERATIONS AND THE CURRENT
BRIDGE BUDGET PROPOSAL IS ALSO
FOCUSED ON EXACTLY THE SAME.
PREVENTION IS AT LEAST AS
IMPACTFUL AND MORE COST
EFFECTIVE THAN TREATMENT OF THE
DISEASE.
RATIFICATION OF THE CROP DISEASE
VECTORS IS VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE
AND RARELY IF EVER WORKS WE
STRONGLY --
CDFA TO VIEW THE MANAGEMENT OF
HLB THE HOLISTIC COMPREHENSIVE
MANNER AND REFRAIN FROM A SHORT
SIGHTED APPROACH OF A SINGULAR
FOCUS ON VECTOR CONTROL.
IT IS CRITICAL TO INCREASE
STAFFING IN CDFA OF SPECIALISTS
IN THE FIELDS OF SOIL HEALTH AND
MICROBIAL ECOLOGY.
SELECTION DEVELOPMENT OF DISEASE
RESISTANT SINCE WE ASK FOR
INCREASED STAFFING AND A
CORRESPONDING ADDITIONAL BUDGET
ALLOCATION OF ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ARE AT LEAST 20% OF THE
OVERALL BUDGET ASK.
A CONTROL OF CITRUS GREENING
DISEASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL.
IN SUPPORT OF TODAY'S PROPOSAL
WANT TO THANK THE ADMINISTRATION
AND YOUR COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT --
TO ASSIST IN THE INDUSTRY WITH
THE CONTROL OF THIS DISEASE AN
INSPECTOR --
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT KNOW THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES HAPPENING --
BEYOND WHAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
DOING THE DEPARTMENT IN THE AND
THE REASON AND THE IMPORTANCE
FOR THE STAFF THAT THEY'RE
ASKING FOR IS THAT THEY COME IN
AS THE AS THE WITH THE THE STATE.
AND THE ABILITY TO ACTUALLY
PROVIDE SOME OF THESE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES IN
CONTROL ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
NEEDED IN THESE URBAN AREAS.
THIS IS DONE IN CONJUNCTION.
WITH THE INDUSTRY HELPING FIND
EDUCATIONAL OUTREACH.
IT'S ALSO DONE IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE CITRUS INDUSTRY
INVESTING.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF ACTUALLY
CLOSE AROUND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE IN IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A LAB.
AT UC RIVERSIDE FOR THE PURPOSES
OF A BIOLOGICAL.
BIOLOGICAL CONTROL.
I'M IN ADDITIONAL RESEARCH
THAT'S TAKING NATIONWIDE.
WITH FUNDING FROM USDA AND OTHER --
PRIVATE INTERESTS TO FIND A CURE
FOR THIS DISEASE SO I THINK THAT
IT'S HE NARROWLY FOCUSED I HAD
TO LOOK AT THE DEPARTMENT AND
SAY THAT THEIR ACTIVITIES THAT
THEY'RE DOING --
IS ONLY FOCUSED ON ENFORCEMENT
THAT'S THE ROLE RIGHT NOW.
THEIR ROLE IS. TO TRY TO IS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO CONTAIN
AN AND STOP THIS DISEASE.
IN THE PAST THAT SPREAD TO THE
INDUSTRY USDA THE UC SYSTEM IS
TAKING ON THE OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES OF LOOKING INTO
THE RESEARCH LOOKING INTO THE
BIOLOGICAL CONTROL LOOKING INTO
OTHER EFFORTS THAT WE CAN PUT
OUR HANDS AROUND.
IN TRYING TO PREVENT THE
DEVASTATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
CITRUS INDUSTRY.
LIKE WE'VE SEEN IN OTHER AREAS
SO.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION TO THE COMMITTEE
ABOUT THE HOLISTIC APPROACH THAT
THAT'S BEEN --
PURSUED.
BY THE INDUSTRY STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS TO LOOK AT
THIS -- AND
MID BECAUSE OF ALL OF THAT
THAT'S HAPPENING WHAT CDFA IS
PUT BEFORE YOU TODAY IMPORTANT
FOR YOU TO SUPPORT A AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR APPROVAL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
X..
THANK YOU TURN NUMBERS NIKITA
CREDIT WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AT
LIKE TO LINE MY COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF ME THAT WITH THE
PESTICIDE ACTION ARE IN.
THAT WORK WE TO OUR CONCERNS
WITH THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
RECOGNIZE IT'S AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE BUT ENERGY SIMILARLY
BELIEVES THAT THIS BUDGET
ALLOCATION SHOULD INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT'S
FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING PLANT
RESILIENCE AND DISEASE
MANAGEMENT.
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON ORGANIC
COMPLAIN CONTROLS THE WE'RE NOT
RELYING EXCLUSIVELY ON
PESTICIDES THAT JUST CLICK HERE
FOSS THAT ARE KNOWN TO BE HIGHLY
NEUROTOXIC THANK YOU.
OKAY.
LET'S CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING.
THIS IS A RECOMMENDATION IS
PROVE HIS BUDGET.
QUESTION FROM PLEASE.
BERMAN.
YOUR RESPONSE TO THE THE TWO
CONCERNS ABOUT INVESTING IN
[inaudible]
RESURGENT.
ORGANIC COMMITMENT TO MORE
EXPLORATION.
YEAH WE ARE DEFINITELY COMMITTED
TO THAT.
WE HAD A VCP TWO YEARS AGO THAT
WAS A FAIRLY COMPREHENSIVE ONE
FAR PAST PREVENTION SYSTEM IN AN
INCLUDED ABOUT SIX POSITIONS AND
SOME DEDICATED DOLLARS. FOR
BEEFING UP OUR ABILITY TO
OPERATE.
ALMOST TWO HISTORICAL LEVELS FOR
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT WE
HAVE A BRANCH WITHIN OUR PLAN
HEALTH AND PEST PREVENTION
DIVISION.
THAT IS CALLED THE INTEGRATED
PEST CONTROL AND THAT'S WHAT
THEIR FOCUS SAYS SO YEAH THAT IS
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT AS
PART OF OUR PORTFOLIO.
AND TO THAT END WE ALSO HAVE
DONE IN COOPERATED WITH --
WHAT WAS MENTIONED WITH THE UC
AND WE'VE COORDINATED RELEASES
OF PARASITIC WASPS THAT TARGET
ASIAN CITRUCEL IT'S --
IT'S A TECHNIQUE THAT PROBABLY A
LOT MORE MATURITY BEFORE IT CAN
BE CONSIDERED MORE EFFICACIOUS
ON A LARGER SCALE BUT EVERYTHING
STARTS WITH DOING --
PROJECTS LIKE THE ONION AND
EXPERIMENTING WITH THOSE TYPES
OF TECHNIQUES AND I APPRECIATE
THAT I'M ALSO CURIOUS IS
CHLORPYRIFOS USED IN CONTROLLING
THE DEPARTMENT DOES NOT USE
CHLORPYRIFOS.
THIS MONEY DOESN'T GO TO FOR
PEER FOR US NOW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LIKE.
TO PREPARE TO MOVE THERE'S
THERE'S A MOTION TO APPROVE HIS.
THIS CALL THE ROLL.
I CASKEY HI ENDS WITH MINOR
MINING.
MATTER OPEN THE CHAIR NEEDS. TWO
OR THREE MINUTES A PERSONAL TIME
WILL TAKE A PAUSE BEFORE WE GET
TO THE VARIOUS TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS STRUCTURE LIKE SHOULD
BE LIKE
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT --
YEAH
[inaudible]
THE TRANSITION [inaudible]
YEAH.
I LIST BRING THE MEETING.
BACK TO ORDER WE'RE GOING ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER. TWENTY SEVEN AND
THIS IS.
ENTITLED VARIOUS TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS.
YEAH WE HAVE VARIOUS TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS --
I SEE IN THE LA OWES RIDE UP THE
TWO OF THEM GOT PULLED OUT AS
WHAT THEY ARE IN AGREEMENT WITH
US THAT ARE PURELY TECHNICAL AND
THAT WAS.
THAT SOME CONVERSION OF CAN HELP
TELL A PERMANENT POSITIONS.
AND ALSO THEY DIDN'T HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH OUR POSITION
REDUCTION DUE TO THE CALIFORNIA
MILK MARKETING ORDER MOVING OVER
TO THE FEDERAL MILK MARKETING
ORDER.
I'LL JUST NOTE ON THAT ONE
THOUGH.
IT WASN'T A REDUCTION TO ZERO AS
A REDUCTION TO FIVE BECAUSE WE
STILL HAVE A SMALL PROGRAM.
THAT PERFORMS A SERVICE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA AIR INDUSTRY AND
THAT'S OPERATING THE WHAT'S
CALLED THE QUOTA IMPLEMENTATION
PROGRAM [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M MOVING ON TO THE ONES THAT
WERE PULLED OUT --
FOR SCRUTINY I GUESS YOU COULD
SAY.
THE FIRST ONE UP IS MOUNTAIN
PASS BORDER PROTECTION STATION
OPERATION EXPANSIONS.
AND WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING HERE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
IN EIGHT POSITIONS IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AN ON GOING.
WHAT THAT'S GOING TO DO IS HELP
US TO OPEN UP ADDITIONAL LANES
AT MOUNTAIN PASS BORDER PROTECT?
CIVILITY THAT'S A RELATIVELY NEW
FACILITY I A REPLACED AN OLDER
FACILITY THAT WAS VERY AN
ADEQUATE AND IT'S A MUCH LARGER
FACILITY.
AND WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS WE'VE
OPERATED IF WITH THE EXISTING
OPERATIONS STAFF THAT WE HAD
THAT THAT'S NOT AN ADDED
ADEQUATE TO KEEP THE LANES OPEN.
OR IDEALLY TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY ON ALL LANES BUT WE REALIZED
THAT YOU REALLY DON'T NEED THAT --
WE TRY TO KEEP ALL LANES OPEN
DURING WHAT WE ANTICIPATE TO BE
HEAVY PEAK PERIODS.
BUT WILL WERE NOTICING AS IS
THAT THERE ARE TIMES WHERE WE
JUST. TO KEEP SOME LANES OPENED
FOR ADDITIONAL HOURS.
AND SO IT'S JUST BECOME A
MANAGEMENT --
IT SURE CHALLENGE FOR US TO
PLACE PEOPLE ON SHIPS AT TIMES --
WE KNOW THE TRAFFIC'S GOING TO
BE PEAK AND WE THINK THAT THESE
EIGHT POSITIONS AN EXTRA MONEY
WILL HELP US TO BETTER MANAGE
THAT SITUATION. TWO THINGS WE
WANT TO AVOID WANT AVOID THE
BACK UPS.
BECAUSE A BACK UP TO A PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE BUT ALSO WITH THE
BACKUP TO DO OVER TIME IS IS IT
IN SENSE.
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO JUST GET
AROUND AND NOT EXPERIENCE THAT
BACK UP TO TRY TO BY PASS THAT
STATION.
AND THEN THE DEFEATS THE WHOLE
PURPOSE OF HAVING THE STATE FORM
THE INSPECTIONS THAT WE NEED TO
DO.
OR WHEN CHP SAYS PUBLIC SAFETY
YEAH WERE VERY SENSITIVE IS THAT
LIKE SAFETY ISSUE --
WHAT HAPPENS IS THEY TELL US
THAT WE JUST HAVE TO START
WAVING ALL TRAFFIC THROUGH WHICH
THEIR AGAIN COMPROMISE OUR
ABILITY TO DO A PROPER
INSPECTION?
ALL RIGHT IN EVEN WITH THE
ADDITIONAL STAFF MEMBER THIS IS
SAID AT A CHALLENGED.
SPOT ON THE I'VE.
FIFTEEN IT IS THE BEST A
CIRCUMSTANCE IN THE TRAFFIC
PATTERN THERE IS INCREASED QUITE
A BIT.
WE GET OVER ONE POINT THREE
MILLION VEHICLES IN A THOUSAND
BOTH SAID TRAVEL THROUGH THERE
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE LAST
QUARTER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
LOOKING AT NUMBERS THERE.
THOUGH IT GETS AN UNUSUAL LOT OF
TRAFFIC AND I MENTION BOATS.
WATER MUSCLE INSPECTIONS FOR
FISH AND WILDLIFE THERE.
SO THESEINSPECTIONS A LOT MORE
THAN JUST LOOK FOR BUGS
EVERYBODY ALLS ON THE BUG
STATIONS BUT WE PERFORM A LOT OF
WORK FOR OTHER AGENCIES AT THESE.
OR PROTECTION STATIONS AS WELL.
WE HAVE.
YEAH WELL AS A CROSS STATE LINES
SOME OF THE BOATS HAVE THOSE
[inaudible]
BART PARTICLES.
YEAH C<c.cyan> THE MUSCLES.</c>
YES HE BROWN C<c.cyan> THE MUSCLES</c>
ARE PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY COULD BE EASILY
TRANSPORTED ON BOATS THAT --
RECREATIONAL BOATS COMING IN
FROM OTHER STATES STATES
SPECIALLY FROM ARIZONA.
OKAY LET'S AS FOR THE LA ELSE
COMMENT ON I GUESS TO BE TWENTY
SEVEN A ON THE MOUNTAIN PASS
BORDER.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE US COMMENTED BALLOT.
THAT TECHNICAL BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL IN GENERAL AS NOTED
EARLIER.
WITHOUT THAT ONLY TO THE THESE
PROPOSALS ARE ACTUALLY TECHNICAL
IN NATURE.
THAT THE OTHER --
FIVE IT'D A FULL BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT WHEN WE REQUESTED
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT THEY HAVE BEEN VERY
FORTHCOMING IN COOPERATIVE AS
HAS THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND THE LESS WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT ON ON THESE PROPOSALS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE RECEIVE
INFORMATION.
PARTICULARLY IN CASES WHERE IT'S
FUNDING FOR NEW ACTIVITIES
PROPOSING NEW POSITIONS OR
EXTENSION OF FUNDING ACTIVITIES
FOR EXAMPLE SOMETIMES THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED POSITIONS
ON A LIMITED TERM BASIS WITH THE
IDEA THAT THE DEPARTMENT WILL
COME BACK A COUPLE OF YEARS
LATER.
AND WE'LL GET AN UPDATE ON THEIR
PROGRESS TOWARDS IMPLEMENTING
THAT PROGRAM BEFORE THEY APPROVE
THOSE POSITIONS ON A PERMANENT
BASIS.
SO WE ARE RECOMMENDING THAT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT JUSTIFICATION PART
APPROVING THE BUDGET PROPOSALS
AND ALSO.
ASKED THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IN
THE FUTURE --
PROVIDE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS
WHEN.
AND ALSO I FINING ACTIVITIES AND
THEIR POSITIONS AT THE
LEGISLATURE PREVIOUSLY
AUTHORIZED ON THE ON A LIMITED
TERM BASIS THAT SORT OF COVERS
OUR OUR OVERARCHING CONCERN
WE'RE NOT RAISING ISSUES WITH
ANY OF THE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS.
OKAY.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE OFFICE OF
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY THIS IS
TWENTY SEVEN BE.
WE'RE ASKING FOR NINE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND A
DISTRIBUTED MINISTRATION IN ONE
POSITION IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND
A HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO THOUSAND
AND ONE POSITION AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AN ON GOING.
AND THAT'S TO BEEF UP BASIC.
THIRTY AND OVERALL SECURITY IN
OUR SYSTEMS AND AS A RESULT OF
AN AUDIT THAT WE UNDER WENT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE MILITARY.
WE MOST RECENTLY UNDERWENT ONE
TO THEIR STEPPING UP THEIR AUDIT
CYCLES WITH ALL STATE AGENCIES
AND SO I THINK A POLICY A LOT OF
THESE REQUEST FOR EXTRA IT
PERSONNEL. TO FOCUS IN ON
SECURITY ISSUES.
IN THE MIX HOW MUCH OF IT IS
THAT THE PHYSICAL --
UPDATE OF EQUIPMENT I GUESS.
OF THE NINE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
THIS WE'VE GOT THREE THINGS AT
LEAST I DON'T HAVE IN FRONT OF
ME I SHOULD PROBABLY.
I CAN GET THAT BREAK DOWN TO YOU
LATER HOW MUCH OF THAT WILL GO
TOWARDS THAT.
OKAY YEAH IT'S DEFINITELY WERE
LOOKING AT A WHOLE SUITE OF
DIFFERENT TOOLS THAT WE CAN USE
TO ENHANCE THE SECURITY OF OUR
SYSTEMS [inaudible]
OKAY.
LET'S MOVE ON THE TWENTY SEVEN
SEAT.
SPEAK A DEVIL TEST ALTERNATIVES.
YEAH.
BECAUSE OF THE ONE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND AG
FUND A STORY IN FOR NINETEEN
TWENTY AN ON GOING.
THAT'S FOR OUR OFFICE OF
PESTICIDE CONSULTATION THE
SUPPORT SCIENTIFIC DEVELOPMENT
OF BIOLOGICAL CONTROL EFFORTS
AND TESTING OF ALTERNATIVES FOR
PESTICIDES BEING CONSIDERED FOR
D. REGISTRATION IN CALIFORNIA.
WE DO NOTED IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
WE DO RECEIVE FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND AND GENERAL
FUND AUTHORITY. TO SUPPORT
SCIENTIFIC DEVELOPMENT FOR
PESTICIDES.
OUR DESPITE THAT AUGMENTATION.
THE OFFICE OF PESTICIDE
CONSULTATION AND ANALYSIS
RETAINS A SHORTFALL IN RESOURCE
OF FORTY THAT'S NECESSARY TO
FULLY IMPLEMENT PLANS TO DEVELOP
PESTICIDE ALTERNATIVES.
THIS FUNDING WOULD ALLOW OP
COULD A FUND BETWEEN THREE OR
FOUR NEW CALIFORNIA INTER
REGIONAL RESEARCH PROJECT NUMBER
FOUR PROJECTS A COLUMN I ARE
FORCED [inaudible]
AND THOSE ARE TARGETED TOWARDS
NEW BIOLOGICAL CONTROL PROJECTS
EVERY ONE TO THREE YEARS AND ALL
THE PROJECT OUTCOMES WILL BE
INCLUDED IN THE GRANT AGREEMENTS
AND VERIFIED BY OUR SCIENTIFIC
STAFF.
IS IN HOUSE WORK WE HEARD FROM
ON THE CITRUS PROPOSAL --
UC IRVINE DOING SOME WORK
OBVIOUSLY I SOON DAVIS IS DOING
SOME SOME SOME WORK YOU WORK
WITH THE UNIVERSITY SERVICES
JUST.
ENTIRELY IN HOUSE.
THIS MONEY WOULD PASS THROUGH US
AS SO PRIMARILY PROBABLY TWO
PEOPLE AT RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS
LIKE THE UC SYSTEM AND WE USE
OUR SCIENTIFIC STAFF TO VALIDATE
THOSE AND ALSO TO PROVIDE.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE INITIAL
SCOPE TO MAKE SURE THAT IS
FOCUSED IN ON WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE [inaudible]
OKAY.
BUT LET'S MOVE ON TO INDUSTRIAL
HEMP.
TOM THIS PROPOSAL'S REQUESTING
SIX POSITIONS AN ONGOING THERE'S
NO FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH THIS --
THE FUNDING WILL BE AS A RESULT
OF ONE OUR REGULATIONS BECOME
PUBLISHED AND WE START
COLLECTING REGISTRATION FEES FOR
REGISTERING PEOPLE WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN GROWING INDUSTRIAL
HEMP.
AND WHAT TYPE OF A RESPONSE THE
THANK YOU CAN TO GET FROM THE
COMMUNITY THIS IS GOING TO BE --
WE'VE GOT ON THE THE MEDICAL
SIDE WE'VE GOT IN AND INTO CS
SIX GROUP OF GROWERS THAT WANT
TO A PRODUCER --
BUT THIS CIVIL MARIJUANA.
THANKS TO HIM.
THIS IS GONNA BE BIG BUSINESS
AND YEAH WE'RE HEARING THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF INTEREST FROM
COMMERCIAL GROWERS WHO WANT TO
ADD THIS INTO THEIR CROP MAX.
I'M BOTH OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE
THERE'S PROBABLY A POTENTIAL FOR
PROFITABILITY BUT IT DOES WORK
ITS WAY INTO A GOOD ROTATIONAL
CROP AS WELL.
OKAY.
I'M LET'S MOVE ON TO TWENTY
SEVEN E. THIS IS WORK DANI'S
ORGANIC WASTE MANAGEMENT.
THIS PROPOSALS FOR A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND IN GENERAL FUND
AUTHORITY IN ONE POSITION FOR
FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY
THROUGH.
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX AND
THAT'S TO ADMINISTER.
FUNCTIONS RELATED OUR DEPARTMENT
FROM CHAPTER SIX THIRTY THREE
STATUTES OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WHICH WAS.
EIGHTY NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE IT
REQUIRES CAL EPA TO COURTNEY WAS
SEVERAL STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING
OUR CDFA TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT POLICIES. TO AID AND
DIVERTING ORGANIC WASTE FROM
LANDFILLS BY PROMOTING THE
COMPOSTING OF SPECIFIC ORGANIC
WASTE BY PROMPTING THE
APPROPRIATE USE OF THAT
COMPOSTING CALIFORNIA.
I KNOW YOU HAVE AN INTEREST IN
HEALTHY SOILS SO THIS IS. ONE
PART OF THAT EFFORT.
THE RIGHT THIS IS NOT WITHIN
HEALTHY SOILS BUT IT'S ANOTHER
AREA THAT ARE DEPARTMENTS ACTIVE
IN THAT FEEDS INTO THE OVERALL
GOALS OF HEALTHY SOIL.
YEAH AND THIS IS JUST THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PART OF YET TO
ASSIST THE THE FUNDINGFOR THE
PROGRAM WORK WITH CALLIE PA SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT THESE
ORGANIC WASTE MATERIALS THAT ARE
GOING INTO LANDFILLS. TO THE
POST A BALL THAT WE CAN GET
THOSE INTO A COMPOSTING
ARRANGEMENT.
OKAY KALI SIX IS A I'D ISSUES
TWENTY SEVEN A THROUGH D..
IF ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
IF NOT THE RECOMMENDATION IS THE
WHOLE OPEN ON OPEN THE PUBLIC
HEARING LATER LET'S MOVE ON TO
YOUR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
REQUEST.
YEAH THIS PROPOSAL ASKS FOR
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND AUTHORITY IN FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY TO ADDRESS.
CRITICAL STRUCTURAL DEFICIENCIES
IN OUR HAWAII FRUIT FLY REARING
FACILITY.
AND AT OUR PLANT PESTS
DIAGNOSTIC CENTER THIS LOCATED
IN SACRAMENTO.
I'M BASICALLY AT OUR FLEW FROM
FIRING FACILITY THERE. FOR
MAXIMUM PRODUCTIVITY WE NEED TO
HAVE CLIMATE CONTROL TO BE VERY
OPERABLE AND WE CAN'T HOW
FLUCTUATIONS IN THE OLD
EQUIPMENT IS NOT AS RELIABLE AS
IT SHOULD BE.
AND IF WE HAVE TO WATER
TEMPERATURE FLUCTUATIONS THEN IT.
CUTS DOWN ON OUR REARING
CAPACITY.
AND THAT'S AN INTEGRAL PART OF A
TECHNIQUE THAT WE USE DOWN IN
THE LA BASIN WHERE WE WERE.
WE REYES MED FLIES STERILE MED
FLIES AND WE RELEASE THEM DOWN
IN THE BASIN SO THAT THEY CAN
ACT AS MEETING DISRUPTORS THERE.
THAT'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE
NATURAL STE.
IN AND OUT OF OUR PLAID.
PLANTAS DIAGNOSTIC LAB.
WE'VE INVESTED A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT AMOUNT OF MONEY IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS FIXING THE ROOF
THERE WAS A AGING ROUGH AND WE
GOT ALL THAT FIX BECAUSE WE HAD
EXTREME WATER INTRUSION PROBLEMS
THERE.
AND SO THIS MONEY WILL GO
TOWARDS ALL THE THINGS BELOW THE
ROOFLINE FOR INSTANCE WE HAD A
LOT OF WINDOW ISSUES WHERE
WINDOWS FLASHING WAS INADEQUATE
WATER WAS COMING IN AND WE HAVE
A LOT OF VERY EXPENSIVE AND
SENSITIVE LAB EQUIPMENT IN THERE
AND WATER INTRUSION.
DOES NOT BODE WELL FOR THAT
EQUIPMENT.
LUCKILY WE GOT IT DONE LAST YEAR
BEFORE THE RAINS CAME THIS YEAR
WELL YEAH WE'RE STILL GETTING WE
STILL HAVE PARTS OF THAT
BUILDING THOUGH THAT THAT'S
HAPPENING LIKE I SAY WINDOWS
DOORS THAT ARE NOT SEALED UP
ADEQUATELY AND THINGS LIKE THAT
SO THAT'S WHAT THIS MONEY'S
GONNA.
DO IS ACCOMPLISHED ALL THAT.
FINANCE STAFF IS RECOMMENDING
THAT WE ADD LANGUAGE TO GIVE
NOTIFICATION TO THE JOINT.
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET.
COMMITTEE.
THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE --
WE'RE COMFORTABLE WITH EFFORTS
ON THAT.
BRENT AND I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
IN ANOTHER SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE --
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
WAS --
PROPOSED --
OF FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE --
REPORTING DOWNSTREAM SO WE'RE
AWARE OF THAT TEN WOULD ONLY ASK
THAT THE EFFORT TO BE
COORDINATED --
AT THE END OF THE PROCESS.
MAKE IT SO WE SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON THE S. R. L..
OKAY THIS IS THE FIRST
MAINTENANCE IS ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY EIGHT WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SOMEONE
REPORTING TO THE THE CHAIR OF
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO OPEN THE
PUBLIC HEARING.
ANYBODY HERE ON DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
OKAY THERE'S A RECOMMENDATION AS
AMENDED WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASKING I OWN MY PLANNER MONEY.
NOW I NEED TO OPEN THE PUBLIC
HEARING ON CALIFORNIA OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE.
ISSUES THAT WE LEFT OPEN ANYBODY
HAVE A GENERAL COMMENT ON ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE LEFT OPEN.
WHICH WILL.
INCLUDE BIO DIVERSITY AT THE
TWENTY SEVEN HE'S.
EXCEPT RAP EXCEPT OUR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON FURTHER THAN THEM
YOU HAVE THE NAME PLAN SOCIETY
ON ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE BY
DIVERSE INITIATIVE.
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF OF STAFF
RECOMMENDATION LEADING THE ITEM
OPEN AND THIS WILL ALLOW FOR THE
ADDITIONAL TIME FOR CDFA TO WORK
WITH CITY OF W. ANOTHER PARTNERS --
TO TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IT MEANS
FOR US TO TO REALLY MOVE FORWARD
ON THE GERM PLASM AND SEE
BANKING QUESTION --
C. M. P. S. IS BEEN VERY
INVOLVED TO DATE ON ON BEING
ABLE TO SEED BANK ABOUT HALF OF
THE THE RAREST OF THE RARE.
NATIVE PLANTS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE BELIEVE WITH AN
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT --
OF ABOUT TWO MILLION DOLLARS THE
THE PROCESSING CATEGORY
CATALOGING OF ALL OF OUR AROUND
REYES PLANS IN CALIFORNIA. TO IT
TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY ENSURE.
THAT WE CAN PREVENT PLANT
EXTINCTION A A STATE --
AND LIKELY WITHIN TWO YEARS --
TIME IF THE FUNDING IS MADE
AVAILABLE --
AND TO DATE THAT WORK HAS BEEN
DONE IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
THE NGO COMMUNITY UNIVERSITIES --
AS WELL AS WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP FOR FUNDING --
SO WITH THAT --
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
ENGAGE WITH WITH EVERYBODY ON
THIS ISSUE --
AND THANK YOU ALL FOR THE FOR
THE TIME TO THE COMMON.
THANK YOU.
THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS --
DOUG JOHNSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
INVASIVE PLANT COUNCIL WE'RE A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS.
BOTH PLOT PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
LAND MANAGERS ACROSS STATE
WORKING TO PROTECT THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENT ECONOMY.
AND WE ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF THE THREE OF FOR INVASIVE
PLANT MANAGEMENT OR THE NOXIOUS
WEED MANAGEMENT ACCOUNT.
IN THIS A B. C. P. IT'S CRITICAL
INVESTMENT IN THE STATE'S
NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE BY WHICH
I MEAN THE BIODIVERSITY.
THE AGRICULTURE BUT ALSO FIRE
PROTECTION.
AND WATER RESOURCES SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT --
MOVING THIS BUDGET ITEM FORWARD
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE MATTEO CROWN
BEHALF THE PENINSULA OPEN SPACE
TRUST AND SANTA CLARA VALLEY
OPEN SPACE IT'S ALREADY ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE ITEM
TWENTY FIVE THE BIODIVERSITY
INITIATIVE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PARTMINER FAST FOOD THAT CULTURE
WE WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING.
AND MOVE ON TO TODAY'S MAIN
EVENT BE ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
NINE THIS IS THE CITY FOR
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
BUDGET CHAIN PROPOSED BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL THIS IS I ASKED
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES BOARD
THE COME BACK AND JOIN THE FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE.
DEPARTMENT.
COMES BACK THIS.
IS THIS THIS IS A WHOLE MESS OF
WHO WOULD LIKE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN.
I CAN OKAY.
REVENUE CHAIR WERE CUT Y. CASKEY
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY --
DERREN PLANUS OUR DIRECTOR OF
THE DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER.
AS YOU KNOW IN TWENTY TWELVE THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED AB SIX
EIGHTY FIVE WHICH ESTABLISHED
CALIFORNIA'S HUMAN RIGHT TO
WATER POLICY.
THAT POLICY CLEARLY AND
UNEQUIVOCALLY STATES.
EVERY HUMAN BEING HAS A RIGHT TO
SAFE CLEAN AFFORDABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE WATER ADEQUATE FOR
HUMAN CONSUMPTION.
I'M PLEASED TO SAY THAT OVER THE
LAST FOUR YEARS.
THE DIVISION A DRINKING WATER IS
COMING OUT.
WE HAVE MADE COME OVER TO THE
OUR STATE WATER BOARD WE HAVE
MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN
THIS REGARD.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ADDITIONALLY
PROVIDED THE BOARD WITH
PNEUMOTHORACES AS WELL.
ADDRESS SAFE DRINKING WATER
PROBLEMS --
THAT INCLUDED.
PROP ONE CAPITAL FUNDING FOR
DRINKING WATER AND WASTE WATER
TREATMENTS FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THE ABILITY TO
USE THOSE DOLLARS.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS WELL.
AND ALSO CREATE A ALSO INCLUDED
THE CREATION OF THE OFFICE O
SUSTAINABLE WATER SOLUTIONS TO
FOCUS ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR NEEDS.
ALONG WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
ORDER CONSOLIDATION OF SMALL
SYSTEMS WITH LARGER SYSTEMS AND
LIMITATIONS ON THE CREATION OF
NEW SMALLER SYSTEMS.
INCLUDED THE ABILITY TO HELP
PROVIDE DRINKING WATER
ASSISTANCE TO SMALL COMMUNITIES
AND DOMESTIC WELL OWNERS IN
CERTAIN CASES.
BUT YOU'RE GOING TO DROUGHT.
AND AS YOU ALSO GAVE US THE
ABILITY LIMITED FUNDING TO HIRE
AN ADMINISTRATOR TO MANAGE
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS.
SIMPLY LACK MANAGERIAL FINANCIAL
OR TECHNICAL SKILLS TO MANAGE
WATER TREATMENT FACILITIES.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP MANY
COMMUNITIES ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF HELPING MANY MORE.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS THE
BOARD HAS BROUGHT TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS
ARE FAILING. TO DELIVER SAFE
DRINKING WATER BACK INTO
COMPLIANCE.
TAKING ACTIONS AND PROVIDED
ASSISTANCE TO WATER SYSTEMS THAT
HAS LED TO THE CONSOLIDATION OF
A TOTAL NINETY SIX FAILING
SYSTEMS.
WERE LIKELY TO FILL WATER SYSTEM
SINCE.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND WE'VE
HELPED OVER TWO HUNDRED SMALL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SECURE
FUNDING FOR PROJECT PLANNING AND
CONSTRUCTION TO OUR OFFICE IS
STABLE WATER SOLUTIONS.
DESPITE THESE EFFORTS MANY LOCAL
WATER SYSTEMS IN THE STATE
PARTICULAR THOSE SERVING SMALL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
CONSISTENTLY FAIL TO PROVIDE
SAFE DRINKING WATER TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS.
WITH NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
SYSTEMS OVER THREE HUNDRED
SYSTEMS AT THIS POINT UNDER OUR
JURISDICTION THE JUST CAN'T
CONSISTENTLY MEET STANDARDS.
AND UNTOLD ANYMORE THERE ARE TOO
SMALL TO BE RAY.
WE ALSO OF UNTOLD THOUSANDS OF
DOMESTIC WELLS THE BOTTOM LINE.
IS THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP
THOUSANDS MORE SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND WE COULD HAVE
PREVIOUSLY.
BUT OVER MILLION OVER A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS STILL DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO CLEAN RELIABLE
DRINKING WATER.
WHICH TO MANY OF US IS THE
PREEMINENT WATER ISSUE OF OUR
TIME.
WHEN THAT WE HAVE CALIFORNIANS?
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT.
THE LAST REMAINING PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE FOR ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER IS TO PROVIDE.
A STABLE FUNDING.
BURKE STABLE FUNDING FOR LONG
TERM OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE
FOR DRINKING WATER SYSTEM.
AS WOULD BE ESTABLISHED AND
REPOSE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
THIS IS AN REQUEST A FIRST
RESORT.
NOR IS IT A WAIT INDEFINITELY
PROP UP UNSUSTAINABLE SYSTEMS.
INSTEAD THE FUND IS THE KEYSTONE
TO A COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM THIS
STATE HAS THOUGHTFULLY PIECE
TOGETHER OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS WHICH INCLUDES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
CONSOLIDATION REGIONALIZATION
CAPITAL INVESTMENTS.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT IF THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVES FUNDING FOR
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE IT IS
A BORED INTEND TO USE THIS MONEY
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
THE BOARD INTENDS TO FIRST USE
THESE FUNDS ALONG WITH OTHER
TOOLS LEGISLATURE'S PROVIDED. TO
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY OF THE
FAILING SYSTEMS BEFORE
CONSIDERING FUNDING FOR
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
SOLELY.
IN MANY CASES FOR MAY FIRST THE
POINT OPERATE AND MANAGE A
FAILING SYSTEM BEFORE
CONSIDERING PROVIDING.
FUNDING FOR OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE.
AND WHILE THE CHALLENGE OF
ACCESS TO CLEAN DRINKING WATER
MIGHT SEEM TO SOME AS A RULE
ISSUE IT'S A PROBLEM THAT
IMPACTS COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
THIS IS AN URBAN SUBURBAN AND
RURAL PROBLEM THE SOLUTIONS NEED
AND NEEDS ARE UNIQUE TO EACH
COMMUNITY THAT IS FACING THESE
CHALLENGES.
I ALSO WANT TO ADDRESS DIRECTLY
THE CONCERN THAT I'VE HEARD FROM
SOME.
OF THE WATER FREE PROPOSED IN
THE TRAILER BILL WOULD NOT COULD
DIRECTLY BENEFIT COMMUNITIES
THAT ALREADY HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
OF CALIFORNIANS WE HAVE A MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
CLEAN AND SAFE DRINKING WATER
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY LIVE.
OR THEIR ECONOMIC STATUS.
AND AS CALIFORNIANS WE ALL PAY
FOR A WIDE RANGE OF PUBLIC GOODS
AND SERVICES EVEN THOUGH SOME
GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAMS
DISPROPORTIONATELY BENEFIT SOME
COMMUNITIES MORE THAN OTHERS.
DOES THIS PEOPLE ROLL PARTS OF
THE STATE HELP PAY FOR STORM
WATER PROJECTS A PRIMARILY
BENEFIT URBAN AREAS.
IT IS JUST AS REASONABLE AND
APPROPRIATE FOR PEOPLE IN
COMMUNITIES ARE LUCKY ENOUGH TO
ALREADY HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER. TO CONTRIBUTE A
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY TO HELP
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT DO NOT
YET HAVE ACCESS.
IN ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH THIS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
ESTABLISH A NEW SPECIAL FUND.
FOR THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
ASSIST COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY
DISADVANTAGED AND PAYING FOR
SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM COST OF
ATTAINING ACCESS.
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
STATUTORY LANGUAGE TO ESTABLISH
A PROGRAM PROVIDE GRANTS LOANS
AND ADMINISTRATOR CONTRACTS ARE
SERVICES.
TO ASSIST A LITTLE COMMUNITIES
AND HOUSEHOLDS IN SECURING THAT
ACCESS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET PROPOSES
WILL FUND THE STATE BOARD IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE. TO TAKE INITIAL
STEPS TOWARDS IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS NEW PROGRAM INCLUDING
DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING
FEEDING COLLECTION SYSTEMS.
ADOPTION OF AN ANNUAL
IMPLEMENTATION IN PLAN AND
DEVELOPMENT OF A MESS A MAP
RATHER OF HIGH RISK AQUIFER'S.
USED AS DRINKING WATER SOURCES.
THANK YOU AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THE FOOD NAG WHEN THE SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT THE THE DAIRY AND
FARMERS AND RANCHERS THE THAT
PART OF THE A PROPOSAL.
YEAH OUT THERE'S THREE MAIN
COMPONENTS AND THE PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR FEE
COLLECTION --
ONE OF THEM IS ON JERRY
PRODUCTION.
AND AS I MENTIONED IN AN EARLIER
COMPONENT OF THIS HEARING WERE
ALREADY INVOLVED IN THAT SO WE
WOULD JUST HAVE ADDITIONAL STAFF
THAT WOULD HELP US COLLECT THE
FEES NECESSARY THAT'S CONTAINED
IN THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
AND THEN ALSO TO COLLECT A FEE
ON FERTILIZER IN CALIFORNIA AND
THERE AGAIN WE ALREADY DO SOME
WORK IN THAT AREA AND COLLECT
WHAT'S CALLED A MILL FEE THERE.
AND SO WE WOULD JUST ADD
EXISTING STAFF AND DO A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT FRONT DATABASE WORK TO
HELP US DO THAT.
THE CONFINED ANIMAL FEEDING
OPERATION FEE THAT'S BEEN
PROPOSING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGES
AS YET UNSPECIFIED.
BUT WE WOULD AS THE LANGUAGE
STATES WE WOULD EXPERTISE TO
FACILITATE THAT SO THAT WE COULD
DETERMINE WHAT THOSE FEES SHOULD
BE AND HOW THEY SHOULD BE
APPLIED [inaudible]
OKAY --
HELLO WHAT'S YOUR COMMENT SIMON
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND WE HAD A NUMBER OF COMMENTS
FOR LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION.
A FIRST IS UNCERTAIN EXTENT TO
WHICH THE PROPOSE REVENUES WOULD
FULLY --
ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT COMPLETED
AN ESTIMATE OF THE TOTAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH BRINGING
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS.
THAT ARE CURRENTLY UNABLE TO
MEET WATER QUALITY STANDARDS IN
THE COMPLIANCE ON AN ONGOING
BASIS.
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD IS CURRENTLY
CONDUCTING A STUDY IT WAS --
STARTED LAST FALL HOWEVER.
IT'S NOT EXPECTED TO BE
COMPLETED IN TELL THE FALL OF
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY HOWEVER WE
NOTED THAT THE BOARD HAS STATED
THAT THEY THINK PARTS OF THE
STUDY MAY BE AVAILABLE SOONER.
ON IN THE ABSENCE OF THAT STUDY
WE MET AT A PRIVATE CONSULTING
FIRM ESTIMATED THE TOTAL COST
ADDRESSING INTIMIDATED DRINKING
WATER.
AT ROUGHLY A HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION HOWEVER THIS THIS
ESTIMATE IS HIGHLY UNCERTAIN
GIVEN THE LACK OF DATA
ESPECIALLY REGARDING THE NUMBER
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS AND WELLS
THAT FAILED TO PROVIDE SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
ACTUAL COSTS COULD BE HIGHER OR
LOWER THAN THE HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
I GUESS I GUESS ON IT FOR ASKING
THE WHOLE PUBLIC TO PAY IN WITH.
EXCEPT THE THE MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS ISN'T PART OF IT ON
THE COOPERATION THAT WE GET FROM
THE SMALL FAILING --
THE DISTRICTS MOVED TO SET ASIDE
THE WAY LESSEN FOURTEEN HOT CUPS
WHICH WE DON'T HAVE.
WHICH IS ANOTHER PROBLEM BUT
JUST LOOK AT THE IDENTIFIABLE
SMALL SYSTEMS THAT ARE WORKING
IF THERE'S MONEY THERE TO
CONSOLIDATE.
OR TO OR TO JOIN THE SYSTEM IF
THERE COOPERATIVE OF THAT IT'S
GOT A SAVE MONEY RIGHT I MEAN.
IF THEY WANT TO FIGHT AS BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO BE SELF DETERMINED
AND BUT WHATEVER THEY'VE BEEN
SAYING FOR YEARS THAT SEEMS TO
BE THAT.
A BIG SWING OF OF HOW MUCH MONEY
IS GOING TO BE SPENT WOULD YOU.
AGREE WITH THAT.
WELL FIRST OF OUR UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT WHEREVER POSSIBLE THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD LOOKS AT OPPORTUNITIES TO
CONSOLIDATE WATER SYSTEMS AND IF
THAT IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE --
AND COST EFFECTIVE APPROACH THEN
THEY GENERALLY PURSUE THAT.
ON AND GENERALLY WE WOULD AGREE
WITH WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT
THEY DID --
WHERE THAT IS THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE APPROACH THAT'S THE
APPROACH THAT SHOULD BE TAKEN?
THE QUESTION IS IS THE IS THE
SMALL FEELING SYSTEMS THAT SAY
OVER MY DEAD BODY YOU'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT CONSOLIDATE AND SINCE
IS A RELATIVELY NEW TOOL TO GO
IN AND TO SAY.
NO YOU WILL AND IF THAT BECOMES
A LEGAL CHALLENGES DAY I CAN
IMAGINE THE PRICE GOING UP
VERSUS WE DON'T HAVE THE WHERE
WITH ALL WE DON'T HAVE THE DOUGH
WE ARE WE DISAGREE THAT WERE
FAILING.
AT THE END OF HìNH INTERESTING
POINT -- BUT
YOU CAN IMAGINE SOME OF THIS
BALL GAME VERSUS JUST WATER IN
AG PEOPLE.
SO I CAN.
THAT'S AN UNCERTAINTY WILL NEVER
KNOW RIGHT I MEAN THIS IS.
HOW MUCH COOPERATION WE GET --
WHEN A FOR ALL IN UNDER THE --
THE PROPOSAL GO ON WITH YOUR
COMMENTS I'M SORRY.
AND ANOTHER POINT THAT WE MADE
IS THAT THAT THE MASTER THE
CHARGE PAIRS WOULD NOT BE.
DIRECT BENEFICIARIES THE PROGRAM
MEANING THAT THE MAIN
BENEFICIARIES OF THE PROGRAM
WOULD BE PEOPLE AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THE SERVER BY SMALLER WATER
SYSTEMS.
I'M.
THE LARGEST SHARE THE PROGRAM
COSTS HOWEVER WOULD BE PAID BY
WATER SYSTEM RATE PAYERS ACROSS
THE STATE MANY OF HIM OUR
CUSTOMERS OF LARGE WATER SYSTEMS
THAT ALREADY.
PROVIDE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER THERE'S FOR THOSE
SYSTEMS WOULDN'T BE ELIGIBLE FOR
ASSISTANCE FROM THE PROGRAM.
AND THE MAJORITY OF THESE RATE
PAYERS IS THERE ALREADY
RECEIVING THAT THAT AND THAT
HOWEVER THEY BE PAYING FOR
GENERALLY THE BULK OF THE COSTS
AND THEREFORE THEY'RE UNLIKELY
TO DIRECTLY BENEFIT FROM THE
PROGRAM.
AS THEIR WATER SYSTEMS WOULD NOT
BE ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR FUNDING
FROM IT HOWEVER THERE WOULD BE
THE INDIRECT BENEFIT OF THOSE
PEOPLE WHEN THEY TRAVEL TO OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE OR THEY STAY
IN PLACES THAT ARE BENEFITING
DIRECTLY FROM THE PROGRAMMING.
HAVING BETTER ACCESS TO SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
ANOTHER POINT THAT WE WANTED TO
RAISE IS THAT.
POSTED THE CHARGE PAIRS WOULD
NOT BE AT FAULT FOR THE
CONTAMINATION IT'S BEING
MEDICATED --
THE VAST MENTIONED FOR EXAMPLE
THE VAST MAJORITY OF NITRATE
CONTAMINATION IS CAUSED BY
AGRICULTURAL ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
FERTILIZER APPLICATIONS IN
ANIMAL OPERATIONS SUCH AS DAIRY --
COVERAGE WITH NOTHING AT SOME OF
THAT THE CURRENT NITRIC
CONTAMINANTS IN GROUNDWATER
THEY'RE NOT FROM THE CURRENT
AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS IS THAT
SOME OF THESE NITRATES ARE FROM.
LEGACY CONTAMINATION THEY COULD
BE FROM AS MUCH AS DECADES AGO.
WE LOOKED AT ALTERNATIVE FUNDING
SOURCES TO SEE IF WE COULD
IDENTIFY AN ALTERNATIVE FUNDING
SOURCE WE THINK GENERAL FUND.
IS AN ALTERNATIVE FOR THE TO
FUND THIS PROGRAM HOWEVER WE
ALSO NOTE THAT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER
PROGRAMS CAN HEATING FOR SCARCE
GENERAL FUND RESOURCES AND IF
THAT WAS CHOSEN A FUNDING
MECHANISM THIS PROGRAM WILL
CONSTANTLY BE IN COMPETITION
WITH THOSE OTHER PROGRAMS FOR
THAT GENERAL FUND.
THIS IS GOING TO PROGRAM WE
CREATE AND ON TO A FOR FINDING
ON BECAUSE IT WOULD BE PROVIDING
THE SAFE DRINKING WATER IF YOU
THAT FINDING DECREASED THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY PUT THAT SAFE
DRINKING WATER AT RISK.
ON YOUR PART.
WITH THE NITRATES.
A WORKING MODEL SEEMS TO BE A
SEVENTY THIRTY SPLIT ON WHAT IS
A LOT OF TOWARDS NITRATES IN
AGRICULTURE WHETHER IT'S A
LEGACY HERE I'M GOING. TO
DISAGREE WITH THAT THE VISION OR
THAT CALCULATION.
WE DON'T DISAGREE WITH THAT
CALCULATION WE JUST THINK
THERE'S CONSIDERABLE UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT IT ON AND THAT WAS PART
I'VE TALKED EARLIER ABOUT THE
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION DOLLAR
ESTIMATE.
THAT WAS DONE BY THE PRIVATE
CONSULTING FIRM AND I WAS PART
OF THEIR ESTIMATE SO I THINK
THERE'S THERE'S JUST UNCERTAINTY
THERE.
SO WE ALSO LEFT IN TERMS OF
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING SOURCES AT
BOND FUNDING BUT WE DON'T THINK
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE SOURCE
BECAUSE TYPICALLY IT'S USED FOR
A ONE TIME PROJECTS.
AND THIS WOULD REQUIRE ONGOING
FUNDING AND ALSO --
WE LOOKED AT SPECIAL FUNDS --
THAT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO
SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM WOULD HAVE
SUFFICIENT AVAILABLE FUNDS AND
WE WERE UNABLE TO IDENTIFY ANY
OF THE SPECIAL FUNDS AS AN
OPTION.
AND THEN FINALLY THE WE WANTED
TO POINT OUT THAT THE SAFE
HARBOR PROVISIONS WOULD AFFECT
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY THAT THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD.
THE SAFE HARBOR PROVISIONS
INVOLVE SOME POLICY TRADE OFFS
COMPARED TO THE STATE'S CURRENT
ENFORCEMENT APPROACH.
ON THE ONE HAND THE PROPOSAL IS
STRUCTURED TO BETTER ENSURE THAT
A SIGNIFICANT FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE FOR WATER QUALITY
MITIGATION THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
RATHER THAN T. THAN LIMITED TO
JUST CERTAIN AREAS IN THE STATE.
SPECIFICALLY FOR NITRATES AND
THE PROPOSAL IS THAT AS THE
STATE WOULD RELINQUISH SOME OF
ITS AUTHORITY --
TO TAKE CERTAIN ENFORCEMENT
ACTION SUCH AS CLEAN UP AN
ABATEMENT ORDERS AGAINST
POLLUTERS IF THERE OTHERWISE
COMPLYING WITH THEIR APPLICABLE
PERMITS IN WAIVERS AND I'M
TALKING SPECIFICALLY ABOUT.
THE AGRICULTURAL ENTITIES THAT
WOULD BE I PAINS CHARGES INTO
THE FINE SAID THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
I GUESS THE QUESTION WOULD BE
BEST PRACTICES GOING FORWARD I
WAS PART OF A STUDY GROUP
RECESSION THE WENT TO INDIA AND
WE WE HAD HAD A MEETING WITH.
AN INDIAN FERTILIZER COMPANY
THAT WAS GOING --
TO ALL ORGANICS THEY WERE GOING
AWAY FROM PETROLEUM BASE I
TREATING GOING TO YOU KNOW A
MORE HEALTHY SOIL WE TALKED
ABOUT THAT PREVIOUSLY SO SO WELL
THAT'S NOT BEFORE AS IF THE BEST
PRACTICES CHAIN SO THAT WE'RE
NOT.
CONTINUE TO USE THE PER.
THE EXCESSIVE NITRATES IN IN IN
THE SOIL.
THEN THAT MAY BE A SELF
CORRECTING THE NOMINAL AGAIN
THAT'S MORE.
AG THEN WATER RESOURCE POOR BUT
THE THE PROGRAM BENEFITS I MEAN
IF WE IF.
IF CALIFORNIA CHOOSE THE GO DOWN
THAT PATH [inaudible]
ALRIGHT COME.
CALLING SENATOR.
MINING SURPRISINGLY YOU HAVE A
QUESTION ON THIS.
THE FOR TO THE DIRECTOR AND SEE
IF YOU HAD ANY RESPONSES TO THAT
LA --
COMMENTS FROM.
PARTICULARLY IN THE AREA OF
EXPLORING OTHER [inaudible]
FUNDING OPTIONS.
OTHER FUNDING OTHER FUNDING
OPTIONS HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED AS
YOU WILL NOTE CENTER MINING YOU
KNOW THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE'S TAKINGUP THIS ISSUE.
AND WHAT WE CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
WITH IS THAT IT HAS TO BE A A
STABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE OF FUNDING FOR FOR
THE SYSTEMS TRANSITION AIR.
TRANSACTION YOU KNOW WHETHER
THEY'RE IN TRANSITION OR WILL
HAVE TO BE FOR OUR HOWEVER LONG.
YOU CAN'T JUST.
CUT OFFS AN ARBITRARILY OR OR
HAVE FLUCTUATING.
THE FUND BECAUSE OTHERWISE YOU
YOU DON'T HAVE AGAIN THAT
CONSISTENT.
ABLE FUNDING THAT THEY CAN COME
FROM IT AND SO --
IN THAT BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE ALREADY INSOFAR AS WE'VE
SPENT.
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN CAPITAL FUNDING --
FROM THE STATE REVOLVING LOAN
FUNDS AND AND OTHER SOURCES BOND
SIX CETERA INTO THESE
COMMUNITIES.
BUT AGAIN IT'S THE OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE COMPONENT IN SUBJECT
TO ABILITY PREDICTABILITY IT'S
GONNA BE VERY CRITICAL TO THE
PROGRAM THE SUCCESS OF THE
PROGRAM.
AND YOU HAVE AN ESTIMATE OF HOW
MANY OF THESE.
ROUGHLY THREE HUNDRED SYSTEMS
WOULD.
WOULD BE CANDIDATES FOR
CONSOLIDATION WITH THE CLEAN
WATER.
SOURCE --
ALL DEFERRED TO DURABLE HE
MISSED BUT YOU KNOW WHEN IT
COMES TO REGIONALIZATION
CONSOLIDATION IT'S PRETTY MUCH
OUR PRIMARY TOOL WE HAVE TO AS
DARREN IN ALWAYS POINTS OUT. 95%
OF OUR VIOLATIONS COME FROM
SYSTEMS UNDER FIVE HUNDRED
CONNECTIONS SO THERE'S A DIRECT
ISSUE HERE WITH.
THE REPAIR BAY SIZE IN YOUR
ABILITY TO SERVE CLEAN AND SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
SO -- SO
WHEN IT COMES TO OF THOSE THREE
HUNDRED OR SO I DON'T HAVE AN
EXACT NUMBER BUT I ALL ALLOWED
DARRON TO TO MAYBE IF IN CASE HE
HAS A BETTER IDEA.
OF YEAH AND I REALIZE IT MAY BE
AN ESTIMATE I'M JUST TRYING TO
GET A TEST SO OUR OUR ESTIMATES
ARE GOING INTO THIS JUST LOOKING
A CONSOLIDATION.
AMONG ALL OF MY POINT AND SECOND
ARM WERE WERE RANGING AND SO WE
WE DID VERY CONSERVATIVE
ESTIMATES BASED ON DISTANCE FROM
A LARGER WATER SYSTEMS AND
WHATNOT SO IT'S IT'S CRUDE --
BUT IT WAS LITERALLY BETWEEN A
QUARTER AND WERE AVAILABLE FOR
CONSOLIDATION JUST FROM KIND OF
A CURSORY REVIEW.
OUT WHAT'S MISSING AND WHAT WE
NEED TO DEVELOP FURTHER AS SOME
OTHER TOOLS ASSOCIATE WITH.
REGIONALIZATION THEY MAY NOT
REALLY BE TING PHYSICALLY BUT WE
NEED TO PUT SMALL SYSTEMS
TOGETHER UNDER ONE MANAGER UNDER
ONE BUILDING SYSTEM UNDER.
ONE PROFESSIONAL KIND A GROUP
AND THEN JOIN THEM TOGETHER AND
THAT WAY TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITION SEES WHICH WOULD BE
ANOTHER FORMER CONSOLIDATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
CAN WE TOUCH ON THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE UNDER THE CONTROL OF THE
STATE OR UNDER THE JURISDICTION
THE SMALL WELLS THE PEOPLE AT
LESS THAN.
FOURTEEN HOOK UPS AND ALL OF
THOSE --
SORT OF LIKE ELAINE ALLERGIES
[inaudible]
I I'M CONCERNED ABOUT SOME.
HOMES OR SOME PLACE WHERE PEOPLE
ARELIVING THAT ARE TOO FAR GONE.
THAT THE WELL WAS CONTAMINATED
THE SEPTIC IS CONTAMINATE THE
WELL IT WAS IN A NATURALLY
OCCURRING ARSENIC.
BE SEN IT'S JUST SOMEBODY BUILT
A HOUSE THERE ONCE UPON A TIME
AND CALLS AT HOME BUT FROM OUR
POINT OF VIEW FROM OF PROVIDING
SAFE DRINKING WATER.
IT'S NEXT TO IMPOSSIBLE TO DO
THAT BECAUSE YOUR SOUL REMOTE
REMOVE FROM.
OTHER FUNCTIONING --
SYSTEMS [inaudible]
THAT'S BETTER.
NOT OUR WATER RESOURCE OR NAG A
QUESTION IT'S IT'S IT'S A
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE BECAUSE
THERE'S AN EXPECTATION THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS.
THEY'VE.
BEEN HERE AT THE SEVERAL
COMMITTEES ABOUT THE HUMAN RIGHT
AND EVERYBODY HAS A RIGHT TO TO
WATER AND I'M CONCERNED WITH
SOME PEOPLE EXPECTING I'M GONNA
STAND MY GROUND.
AND YOU WILL CLEAN THIS UP IN I
DON'T KNOW WHAT WE WERE DOING A
LOT HERE BUT THERE ARE SOME
TOOLS WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS.
TO AT LEAST STATE.
JURISDICTION OVER THE SMALL OF
FACILITIES.
INDEPENDENT FACILITIES I GUESS.
HAS GIVEN ME ADD ONE THING THERE
I THINK YOU WOULD FIND IT
THERE'S A SURPRISING NUMBER OF
PRIVATE DOMESTIC WELLS
IMMEDIATELY OUTSIDE THE BOUNDS
OF EXISTING WATER SYSTEMS IT'S
BEEN A BIG SURPRISE MINE AS WELL.
A LOT OF WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
FOCUS ON IS HAVING THOSE PEOPLE
HAVE THE OPTION TO VOLUNTARY
CONSOLIDATE WITH THAT LARGER
WATER SYSTEM IT'S NOT A BIG
STRETCH.
BATTLE CAPTURE A LOT OF THEM
YOU'RE COMPLETELY RIGHT THERE
ARE SOME THAT ARE SO REMOTE THAT
THE QUESTION.
BEGS ITSELF AS TO WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO WITH.
THOUSAND AND THAT'S NOT THERE
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WE
CAN HELP VERY CLOSE TO
COMMUNITIES NOW THAT'S GOOD NEWS
I DIDN'T. TO HEAR THAT THERE'S
THERE'S INDEPENDENT WELLS
ALRIGHT LET'S OPEN UP
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER AND THE WELCOME
MISTER CHAIR --
IT'S INSPIRING AND NECESSARY
THAT YOU ALL TAKEN THIS
LEADERSHIP POSITION AND CALL YOU
IN THE GOVERNOR.
FOR I JUST KICKING THE CAN DOWN
THE ROAD FORCING US TO TRY TO
SOLVE THIS THIS YEAR --
WE WE KNOW WE HAVE --
TO THERE'S A LOT OF WHAT OTHER
CHALLENGES OFTEN WATER WRIT
LARGE -- BUT
THIS IS THE COUPLE TECHNICAL
QUESTION JUST FOLLOWING UP ON
SOME OF THE THINGS YOU REYES IN
TERMS OF THIS PARTIAL PARTIALS
[inaudible]
MEN.
IT WAS A SENSE LIKE WHAT NUGGETS
MIGHT EMERGE BEFORE WE HAVE.
TO GET OUR HEADS AROUND THIS AND
THEN.
ON THE CAN FIND ANIMALS FEE I
KNOW THAT THAT WAS STILL
OUTSTANDING AT THE TIME.
EXACTLY HOW THAT SHOULD THAT
CHARGE WOULD WORK ANY MORE
CLARITY THEY'RE JUST TRYING TO
ADD MORE INFORMATION INTO THE
POT FOR US.
TO HELP MAKE SOME GOOD DECISIONS
AND GET I'LL TAKE I'LL TAKE A
FIRST CRACK AT THAT AND AND THEN
PASS IT ON TO DERREN WHEN IT
COMES TO THE NEED TO SUFFER SO.
TAKING A STEP BACK WE AT THE
STATE WATER BOARD REGULATE
[inaudible]
SOMETHING AROUND.
WHERE WE?
THIRTY YES THREE THOUSAND
COMMITTEE SYSTEMS AND BUT THERE
ARE STILL YET AS AS A CHAIR
MENTIONED TO SOME THAT ARE
BEFORE BELOW FIFTEEN CONNECTIONS
OR FOLKS ARE DOMESTIC WELLS.
ONCE WE REGULATE WE KNOW QUITE A
BIT ABOUT WE HAVE A GOOD SENSE
OF WHAT THE NEED IS THE WHAT
WHERE WE NEED TO DODD THAT THE
FUNDING NEEDS.
AND WHERE WHERE THE PROBLEMS ARE
I MEAN JUST COMPLIANCE SERVE OUR
BIG BLINKING RED LIGHTS YOU KNOW
THAT'S THAT'S OBVIOUSLY A SYSTEM
IN NEED BUT THERE ARE.
SO MANY OTHERS THAT ARE MAYBE A
YEAR.
TWO YOU KNOW A PUMP FAILURE AWAY
FROM FROM BEING IN THAT CATEGORY
AS WELL NONETHELESS SO WE HAVE
THAT PART WE NOTE WE UNDERSTAND
QUITE A BIT.
IN THE NEEDS ASSESSMENT IS
REALLY SUPPOSED TO FILL IN RULES
AND WHAT ABOUT THOSE DOMESTIC
WELLS KIND OF COMPLETE THE
PICTURE OF THE THE THE THE THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT NEEDS AN AND
OTHERWISE AND SO.
I THINK THE PARENTS TIMELINE --
THAT BIGGER NEEDS ASSESSMENT IS
ABOUT A TWO YEAR TIME WINDOW AS
THE LA -- I
THINK INDICATED.
BUT OF THOSE ENTITIES WE ALREADY
REGULATE I THINK WE HAVE A
REALLY OPPORTUNITY.
TO GET MORE INFORMATION OUT HELP
YOU KNOW STAR TREK TAKE YOU LATE
WHAT THIS PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
LOOKS LIKE THE PEOPLE GET
GREATER CERTAINTY I THINK RUN
THE PROGRAM.
ON THE FEES ALSO TO DEFER TO
DARREN I THINK ON THAT THERE AND
YOU CAN GIVE A PIECE OF IT WILL
GO TO KEVIN ACT THE WITH THAT.
OKAY YEAH THE CONFINED ANIMAL
FEEDING OPERATIONS THE CURRENT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT.
INSTRUCTS US TO CONVENE A
WORKING GROUP AND TO EXAMINE
WHAT THE PROPER FEE LEVELS
SHOULD BE BASED ON WHAT'S OUT
THERE WHAT TYPES OF OPERATIONS
AND WHERE THEY'RE LOCATED.
AND SO WHAT WE ENVISION WITHOUT
LANGUAGE HOW WE WOULD WORK WITH
IT AS WOULD WORK VERY CLOSELY%
WITH THE WATER BOARD.
AND FIND OUT YOU KNOW WE DON'T
WANT TO GO OUT THERE IN RETREAT
THE WHEEL AS FAR AS TRYING TO
IDENTIFY DEFINITIONS OR THINGS
LIKE THAT.
AND SO YEAH WE WOULD DEFINITELY
COLLABORATE AND THEN MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS WORKING GROUP
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THAT IS
REFLECTED IN OUR WROTE BUDGET
REQUEST FOR SOME POSITIONS TO
HELP US DO THAT.
ACTUALLY BOTH THE INTEL WIDI
UNTIL WE GET TO THE REVENUE
ESTIMATES ARE TILL WE GET TO THE
TO FEES CHARGED WE CAN'T.
BEGIN TO SPECULATE ON WHAT THE
REVENUE ESTIMATE WOULD BE WE DO
HAVE REVENUE ESTIMATES ON THE
OTHER TWO COMPONENTS IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN THAT --
THE DERRY FEES WE ESTIMATE TO BE
ABOUT FIVE TO SIX MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND FERTILIZER
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FOURTEEN TO
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
.
WELL THERE'S A FEW THINGS THAT
WE WOULD HAVE TO CONSIDER AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S WHY IT WOULD
BE BASED ON A WORKING GROUP IS
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE SIZE OF
THE OPERATIONS.
HELLO WHERE THOSE OPERATIONS ARE
IN THEY ARE.
AND THEN BEGIN TO LOOK AT WHAT A
REASONABLE FEE STRUCTURES THAT
YOU CAN COLLECT FROM THAT.
I KNOW A A IT'S TOUGH BECAUSE
IT'S ALL SPECULATION AT THIS
POINT SO IT'S HARD TO COME UP
WITH A NUMBER --
I KNOW THE PEOPLE OF EXPRESS
CONCERNS ABOUT WOULD THIS IMPACT
VERY SMALL MICRO PRODUCERS.
I THINK IT'S PRETTY REASONABLE
TO SAY THAT WE DON'T LOOK TO
THEM AS THE BE THE BACKBONE OF
WHO WERE GOING TO COLLECT FEES
FROM.
AND THEY DON'T REALLY FALL
WITHIN ANYBODY'S DEFINITION THAT
I'VE SEEN OF A CONFINED ANIMAL
FEEDING OPERATION.
THE OF THOSE YOU KNOW THOSE ARE
THOSE TERMS HAVE MEETINGS IN
OTHER AREAS OF THE CODE IN AND
ALSO WITH AN OPERATIONAL
GUIDELINES OF OTHER AGENCIES.
I MEAN FROM THE BOARD.
OF THINGS WE MIGHT SEE.
HELLO MORE TRUNCATED TIMELINE IN
THE FULL ASSESSMENT TWO YEARS SO.
JOAQUIN OF OF CHEST WILL MENTION
THAT CLOSELY IT I THINK IT'S
REALLY GONNA BE THE FIRST PART
WILL BE THE WATER SYSTEMS THAT
ARE FAILING AND WE CAN GET AN
ESTIMATE OF THOSE THAT'S SO IT'S
INFORMATION WE HAVE --
I THINK CALI THE THE PIECE OF
WOOD FOLLOW THEN THAT WOULD BE.
LOOKING AT IT'S A GOOD BECAUSE
IT'LL BE A MODELING EFFORT OF
PRIVATE DOMESTIC WELLS THAT ARE
IMPACTED BY KNOWN WATER QUALITY
ISSUES ARE LIKELY BE IMPACTED
THE NEAR FUTURE PROBABLY THE
SECOND PIECE THAT WE CAN.
DELIVER AND THEN THE LONGER TERM
ONE IS ASSESSING WATER SYSTEMS.
OF A LOT WORSE ISN'T UNDER OUR
REGULATION THAT.
MIGHT FAIL BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY
A SUBJECTIVE REVIEW IN TIME TO
DO THAT.
A HOME IN A IN A FASHION AND
THEN EVEN HARDER THAN IS THE
STATE'S MALLS THOSE --
FOURTEEN TO FOR CONNECTION
SYSTEMS THAT.
IT HAS NO INFORMATION ON SO
WE'RE JUST GONNA BE VENTURING
INTO GETTING THAT FROM THE
COUNTIES.
TRYING TO PUT ALL OF THAT.
INFORMATION BECAUSE I ALMOST
GUARANTEE EVERYONE OF THEM HAS A
DIFFERENT SET OF INFORMATION ON
THOSE SYSTEMS AND PULLING THAT
TOGETHER AND TRYING TO TURN THAT
INTO SOMETHING MEANINGFUL NOW
BEEN A LONG STRANGE.
ONE WALKTHROUGH TIMELINE IN ON
YOU TO DO THAT.
FOR YES SO I THINK --
OUR GOAL FOR THE OF SYSTEMS ARE
FAILING WOULD BE AROUND ARM.
A PROBABLY EARLY FALL OF THIS
YEAR.
AND THEN ARM PROBABLY THE WATERS
THE DOMESTIC PRIVATE WELLS IS
PROBABLY GONNA BE WINNER.
OF NEXT YEAR SO THE WINNER OF
TWENTY TWENTY YOU'RE SAYING IN
THE END THAT'S FOR ALL THE OTHER
THREE PIECES OF THAT ALL THE
PIECES WERE GONNA TRY TO
COMPLETE BEFORE THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND YEAH.
BUT THERE'S NO MODELING EXERCISE
YOU CAN UNDERTAKE NOW DURING
THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION THAT
GIVES US ON OUR WE'VE ALREADY
STARTED EVERYTHING'S UNDER WAY.
AS FAST AS WE CAN GET IT WE DO
HAVE SOME CONTRACTS YET TO DO.
THE YES SO IT'S STARTED.
WE HAD TO WORKSHOPS ALREADY ON
TWO FACETS OF THIS WE HAVE
ANOTHER WORKSHOP COMING UP.
IN MAY THE WILL BE THE COST
ESTIMATION PIECE AND THEN WE
SHOULD BE ABLE.
TO GET OUR CONTRACTS OUT AND GET
PEOPLE WORKING RIGHT AWAY THE
GOAL TO TRY TO GET SOME
INFORMATION FOR THE END OF THE
SESSION I MEAN NOW YOU WON'T
HAVE THEM.
FOR THEM SOME PARK PIECES WERE
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE BEFORE THE
END OF THE SESSION BUT WE WILL
NOT HAVE A COMPLETE PICTURE BY
THE END OF THE SESSION.
ANY ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE ON WHAT
KIND OF INCREASE WE COULD SEE IN
TOTAL NEED HERE I MEAN YOU HAVE
IT JUST GENERAL ALL PARKS AT
THIS POINT I MEAN.
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW?
YEAH IT WE DON'T KNOW WE WE KNOW
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE WE DON'T
KNOW WE DON'T WE WE KNOW THE
AREA.
I GUESS I WOULD SAY THE WAY I
WOULD CATCH IT IS WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW THAT THE BLUE SKY
ESTIMATE THAT WAS DONE
PREVIOUSLY LAST YEAR --
USE THE INFORMATION THAT WAS
AVAILABLE AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO NOW IS SAY OKAY WE'LL WHAT
WOULD MAKE THE ESTIMATE.
SB NATION BETTER I WAS NOT
AVAILABLE AND NOTS THE
INFORMATION WE'RE SEEKING NOW TO
ADD TO THAT COMPONENTS I REALLY
DON'T HAVE A BETTER.
ONE THEN THEY'VE ALREADY DONE
WITH THE INFORMATION THAT'S
AVAILABLE AND WE MAY OR MAY NOT
BE SURPRISED WITH WHAT WE GET
YOU KNOW.
VERY LAST QUESTION BEING DOES
REMISS CHAIR IT JUST.
MORE BROADLY HAVE YOU HAVE YOU
BEEN LOOKING AT SORT OF OVERALL --
IN THEM NEEDS WE DO A LOT OF
BOND EXPENDITURES HERE BUT JUST
IN GENERAL THIS SORT OF
OUTSTANDING NEEDED IN.
ALL OUR WATER QUALITY PROGRAMS
WITHIN UNDER YOUR JURISDICTION
OF YOU ALL BEEN SORT OF WHILE
YOU'RE TRYING.
TO HONE IN ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE IS ALL FOR THESE VERY
SMALL OUTLYING COMMUNITIES YEAH
WE WE SORT OF LOOKING AT THE
BROADER.
THEY GIVE ALL THE ALL THE FUNDS
IF EVER REVOLVING YOU KNOW FOR
THE ROVING LOANS AND ALL THE
GROUNDWATER CLEANUP MONEY THEY
WERE MOVING THROUGH THESE BONDS
DO YOU DO A GENERAL SENSE AND
MAYBE FOR LA --
AS WELL AS IT IS IT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE SORT OF TRACKING GENERALLY --
OUTSTANDING OWN M. COSTS FOR
OVERALL SYSTEM NEEDS.
AT THAT THE LESSON AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND NO THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
WE GENERALLY BEEN TRACKING.
WE DON'TWE WE DON'T EVEN WHAT
IT'S GONNA TAKE TO OPERATE AND
MAINTAIN [inaudible]
ALL THE THINKINGOF ALL THE
OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE WERE
BUILDING PURSUANT.
TO THE VARIOUS WATER IN
RESOURCES BONDS THAT WE'VE BEEN
INVESTING IN OVER THE YEARS AND
SO.
WHAT OTHER --
IN M. CHARGES WE MAY BE FACING
IN THE FUTURE TO DEAL WITH THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ADDITION OF
THIS -- WE
TRACK THAT THE BOND EXPENDITURES
VERY CLOSELY AND AND WE'VE
REPORTED.
MANY TIMES ON ON THAT BUT AS FOR
THIS SPECIFIC OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE COSTS THAT WOULD BE
ONGOING THAT ARE RELATED TO THAT
CAPITAL.
EXPENDITURES FOR THOSE MINES.
NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF THAT THERE
MAY BE I MAY HAVE OTHER
COLLEAGUES AT THE OFFICE THAT
ARE WORKING IN THAT AREA.
IT'S PRETTY HIGH LEVEL ANALYSIS
BUT I THINK BE USEFUL JUST TO
GIVE US A SENSE OF CONTACT HERE.
FOR WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE
IN THIS CASE.
WHAT ELSE WE GOT ON OUR PLATE?
JUST FEEDBACK IN THE FUTURE HERE
MISTER YEAH I AM AND I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT YOU KNOW
[inaudible]
MOST.
WATER SPENDING IS LOCAL RIGHT
AND I SO IT'S KIND OF HARD FOR
US TO KNOW WHAT IS THE OPERATE
MISSION OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE FOR ALL THE SYSTEMS
THAT WE HAVE OUT THERE IN ALL
THE MANY.
WATER UTILITIES AND WHATNOT BUT
THAT BEING SAID I THINK THERE AN
AD -- MAYBE
AT LEAST A PLACE WHERE.
THERE MAY BE SOME HELP.
SO IT.
I'M JUST GONNA READ INTO YOUR OP.
BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA HANDING OUT
THE FUTURE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS AND
STUFF LIKE THAT SO WE DO DO --
AS PART OF THE THE DRINKING
WATER SRF IN THE CLEAN WATER SRF
A NEEDS ANALYSIS ON A CYCLE WITH
U. S. E. P. A. AND THOSE.
THOSE NUMBERS PRODUCE.
KIND OF A TWENTY YEAR WINDOW OF
WHAT KIND OF INVESTMENTS WE
EXPECT. TO BE MADE IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE CAN GET THOSE NUMBERS TO
I'D I'D HESITATE TO GET HIM OFF
TOP OF MY HEAD BUT I KNOW
THEY'RE LIKE IN THE SIXTY
BILLION DOLLAR RANGE TYPE OF
COMPONENT.
TO YOU KNOW MAKING HER GO BACK
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH
LOCAL INVESTMENT THERE'S GOING
TO BE IN OUR EXISTING SYSTEMS
YEAH.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THAT THAT
SCALE OF ORDER NINETEEN A LOT OF
ITS LOCAL BUT ANYHOW THANK YOU
AND APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK
FAMILIAR WITH YOU.
I THINK IN YOUR OUR CHRIST THANK
YOU MISTER THE LEGISLATURE COULD
PASS MORE.
GOALS JUST KIDDING THANK YOU
JURASSIC AROSE AND NOT DEPUTY --
MUST HORROR OUR INTENT IS TO
HOLD THE MATTER I'D LIKE TO OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC HEARING AT THIS
TIME HERE FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THIS IS.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE THE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
AND THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
AND THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU CHAIR Y. CASKEY AND
MEMBERS CINDY TECH WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES.
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION.
ON THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL.
WE AGREED WITH THE GOVERNOR AND
SENATOR MINING HAS LEGISLATION
THIS YEAR IN THIS AREA WE AGREE
WITH HIM THAT THERE IS A REAL
PROBLEM IN THERE NEEDS TO BE A
SOLUTION THIS YEAR.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THE PROBLEM
CAN BE SOLVED WITHOUT ENACTING A
WATER TAX.
THE WATER TAX IN THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL IS VERY SIMILAR TO
THE ONE THAT WAS PROPOSED LAST
YEAR THAT WAS IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET TRAILER BILL IN
THIS ISSUE.
AND YOUR CALL THAT THE JOINT ON
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
AFFIRMATIVELY REJECTED THE BILL
ON IN PART BECAUSE OF THE WATER
TAX.
ON THE MERITS I'D LIKE TO MAKE
QUICK A QUICK POINTS JUST THREE
OF THEM.
WE THINK IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
TO TAX SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE
HAVE TO HAVE IN ORDER TO LIVE.
THAT'S DRINKING WATER THEIR TAP
WATER.
SECOND THE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER
TALKS ABOUT A RIGHT TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER BUT ALSO WERE
RIGHT TO AFFORDABLE WATER.
IN THE TAX IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
COSTS FOR THE TAX WOULD ADD TO
THE COST OF WATER AND WORK
AGAINST KEEPING WATER AFFORDABLE.
SPECIFICALLY ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
THE WAY THIS IS PROPOSED WOULD
HAVE THREE THOUSAND ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND SYSTEMS IMPLEMENT THE
TAX.
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN MANY
OF THOSE INSTANCES THEY WE NEED
TO HIRE AT LEAST ONE STAFF
PERSON FOR BIG AGENCIES THAT
WOULD BE MORE THAN ONE STAFF
PERSON.
AND THOSE WOULD BE ONGOING COSTS
THAT WOULD ADD TO THE COST OF
WATER.
THERE'S ALSO THE ONE TIME COST
OF CHANGING THE INVOICES THAT
THE BILLING SYSTEM THE SOFTWARE.
WE'VE HEARD NUMBERS ON YOU KNOW
FOR ONE SYSTEM IT'S A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND A HUNDRED
THOUSAND IS A COMMON NUMBER YOU
HEAR SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND I'VE
HEARD A CITY SAY THERE'S IT'S
NOT MILLION DOLLARS.
JUST TO CHANGE THEIR BILLING
SYSTEM WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND SYSTEMS TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROPOSED TAX.
THE IMPLEMENTATION COSTS
SKYROCKET THAT WORKS AGAINST
KEEPING WATER AFFORDABLE.
IN THE THIRD QUICK POINT IS THAT
THE BILL WOULD BE THE PRESIDENT
FOR A STATE TAX ON WATER IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT THERE IS A
BETTER APPROACH SENATOR CAFIERO
IS CARRYING SB SIX SIX NINE IT'S
HEADED TO THE SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE.
IT WOULD CREATE THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER TRUST AND THAT
PROPOSAL CAN REPLACE THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE WATER TAX.
ARE QUIRK IN THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
ARE SPONSORING THAT LEGISLATION
DECENT I KERN IS HERE ON BEHALF
OF SEEING YOU A TO TALK ABOUT
THE TRUST.
LOSING AQUA WOULD REQUEST THAT
THE SUBCOMMITTEE REJECT THE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
BECAUSE OF THE PROPOSED TAX ON
WATER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JASON I CARD WITH THAT
AUSTIN GILBERT ROPES AND SMITH
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
AND THE ORANGE COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT --
GIVEN THAT THE ENTIRE ROOM IS
STANDING BEHIND ME I'M GONNA TRY
AND BE RELATIVELY QUICK --
SEE ANYWAY BUT I I'D ECHO ALL OF
OCT WAS COMMENTS.
REGARDING THE TAX --
THESE ARE THE REASONS WHY WE
HAVE AN OPPOSING LAST MINUTE
POSITION ON THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL AS CINDY SAID --
WE DO HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE
PROPOSAL THOUGH THAT WE THINK
CAN ADDRESS THIS EXTREMELY
SERIOUS ISSUE AND WE ACTUALLY WE
SHARE THE GOAL OF ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE.
SB SIX SIX NINE CABALLERO IS A
IS A VERY SIMPLE PROPOSAL WE
HAVE A BUDGET SURPLUS THIS YEAR.
TAKING A PORTION OF THAT BUDGET
SURPLUS AS A ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION.
SETTING ASIDE A TRUST INVESTING
THAT MONEY IN USING THE NET
REVENUE. TO GET OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE MONEY INTO THESE
COMMUNITIES WHERE IT'S NEEDED.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
MADE TO MAKE OUR MAINTAINED AND
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SAFE
DRINKING WATER TO PEOPLE.
IS IMPORTANT AND THAT'S THE
ESSENCE OF WHAT OUR TRUST
PROPOSE ONE SB SIX SIX NINE IS.
I THINK IT HAS A LOT OF MERIT.
NUMBER --
ONE YOU KNOW AS SANDY POINTED
OUT THE ATTACKS ON DRINKING
WATER IS AT ITS ESSENTIALLY IS A
REGRESSIVE TAX THIS IS HARD ON
FOLKS.
WHO ARE ARE LOWER INCOME WELL
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER YOU'RE AT
OR BELOW FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
OR SLIGHTLY ABOVE IT?
IT'S IT'S AN EXPENSE --
AND SO.
USING IT GENERAL FUND SURPLUS
MEANS WE'RE USING PROGRESSIVE
TAXES INCOME SALES TAX. TO TO
ADDRESS THE SAME PROBLEM.
THE BIGGEST CRITICISM THAT WE'VE
HEARD ON THIS PROPOSAL FRANKLY
IS THAT.
IN THE GENERAL FUND IS NOT A
RELIABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING.
I I I WOULD DISAGREE WITH THAT A
MAN I WOULD DISAGREE ESPECIALLY
IF IT WAS PUT IT ASIDE IT AS A
ONE TIME APPROPRIATIONS.
YOUR STAFF ACTUALLY POINTED OUT
IN THE ANALSIS THAT.
TAX HAS THE FLEXIBILITY TO BE
DIVERTED TO OTHER PURPOSES THERE
ARE NO GUARANTEES THAT THE THE
FEE WILL ALWAYS BE USED TO FUND
PURPOSES INCLUDING IN THIS
PROPOSAL.
YOU COULD ALSO SAY THE SAME
THING.
OF SB SIX SIX NINE AND IT'S
PROPOSAL FRANKLY OR ANY OTHER
PROPOSAL THAT WE PUT FORWARD.
BUT I ACTUALLY HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE THAT GIVEN THAT.
WE WERE DISCUSSING EARLIER TODAY
THAT THERE IS A MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM.
THAT IF THE LEGISLATURE CHOSE TO
SET ASIDE FUNDS TO HELP
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
RESPECT THAT DECISION AND CHOICE
GOING FORWARD --
AND AND WOULD NOT USE THOSE
FUNDS SAID A LATER DATE SO AGAIN.
WE WOULD URGE YOU GUYS TO REJECT
THE THAT THE TRAILER BILL AND
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
THEIR DOLPHIN TO HAVE TO LEAVE
CALIFORNIA CITIES --
I WOULD LIKE TO LINE MY COMMENTS
WITH AQUA AND CMU WAY THE LEAGUE
OF COURSE BELIEVES IN
MAINTAINING HIGH QUALITY
DRINKING WATER THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IS ESSENTIAL AND WE
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF A
STATEWIDE SAFE DRINKING WATER
FUND.
BUT FEEL THAT PLACING A TAX --
ON WATER IS NOT THE APPROPRIATE
FUNDING SOURCE SO WE WOULD
REQUEST --
THAT THE TAX BE REMOVED IN
ANOTHER FUNDING SOURCE
IDENTIFIED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE PAUL HILL OCCURRED
GENERAL MANAGER OF SAN JUAN
WATER DISTRICT IN EASTERN
SACRAMENTO IN WESTERN PLASTER
COUNTY -- WE
SUPPORT FIXING THE PROBLEM WE
THINK YOU NEED TO QUALIFY YOU
QUALIFY WHAT THE PROBLEM IS
FIRST AS YOUR STAFF REPORT SAID
THAT THE WATER WERE DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT THE WHAT THE SOLUTION IS.
A AND WE DON'T THINK A
REGRESSIVE TAX MAKES SENSE WE
SUPPORT SB SIX SIX NINE AND
RECOMMEND THAT YOU.
NOT PASS THIS BILL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
X..
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION WANT TO BEGIN BY
RECOGNIZING THE WORK THAT WAS
DETAILED IN THE METRICS
DESCRIBED BY CHAIR ASK ABOUT.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE LOCAL
AGENCIES LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS IN
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD IN PARTICULAR HAVE
UNDERTAKEN OVER LAST FIVE YEARS
WE THINK THAT THEY'VE DELIVER
REAL RESULTS.
THAT SIDES SAID WE RECOGNIZE
THERE'S A VERY REAL PROBLEM --
THIS IS A CRISIS THE CALLS FOR
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH --
WE THINK THAT MANY OF THE
ELEMENTS OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL HAVE MERITS FOR EXAMPLE
WE SUPPORT A HIGH RISK --
MAPPING ASSESSMENT WE SUPPORT
THE CONCERT FEDERAL FUNDING
ENFORCEMENT PATH FORWARD WE ALSO
APPROACH THE WE ALSO --
SUPPORT GENERALLY THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD'S
PROPOSED PROGRAM THAT WOULD BE
USED -- TO
IT MINISTER FUNDING TO
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN NEED AND
PRIORITIZE FUNDING AMONG THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT SAID WE DO
OPPOSE THE PROPOSED FUNDING
MECHANISM IN THE FORM OF THE
WATER TAX.
A WE SUPPORT AND ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH THE COMMENTS --
OF AQUA AND SEE ANYWAY THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON CAROLYN JENSEN WITH KP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
BOSTON'S WATER DISTRICT IN THE
MOJAVE WATER AGENCY --
WE ALIGN OUR IS OUR COMMENTS
WITH THE HAWKWIND SEE ME WAY
WE'RE OPPOSED TO ATTACKS ON
WATER AND WE SUPPORT SB.
SIX SIX THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
SOLOMON SALAS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY --
THE FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
AS WELL AS THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ASSOCIATED THAT IS
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO SB SIX
TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR MINING
OF LAST YEAR.
I DO WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR
HIS TESTIMONY HE DID HIGHLIGHTS
SOME OF THE FACTS AND I DON'T
WANT TO BE REDUNDANT BUT IT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY LOOKS FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO ENGAGE WITH HIM
AS WELL AS SECRETARIES
BLUMENFELD.
CROWFOOT OF COURSE SENATOR
MINING IN ALL OF THE VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TREES A BIRD
WHICH I'M HALF OF SERIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT NOT ONLY DO OUR
BUSINESS PARTNERS RYAN SAVING
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER BUT
THEIR EMPLOYEES THAT LIVE AROUND --
THEIR BUSINESSES DO AS WELL SO
WE'D LIKE TO BE VERY SUPPORTIVE
ALSO IN REGISTER SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBYING COALITION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JIM LIMBURGER ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA --
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL --
WERE VERY SKEPTICAL ABOUT
MEASURES THAT SATISFIED GENERAL
FUND REVENUES --
YEAH OVER THE WHEN THE ECONOMY
TANKS -- TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT FOR EXAMPLE --
THERE'S A KIND OF A CANNIBALISM
THAT TAKES PLACE AMONGST GENERAL
FUND PROGRAMS.
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT DON'T HAVE
STATUTORY OR CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTION AND BEARING THE BRUNT.
OF THE PAIN --
WE DO THINK WATER IS A HUMAN
RIGHT I WOULD SAY VIRTUALLY
EVERYBODY THAT SUPPORTS OUR
ORGANIZATION HAVE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE.
RANKING WATER --
WE DON'T VIEW GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS AS A CONSUMER GOOD
WHERE EVERY DOLLAR THAT I PAYING
TAXES HAS TO COME BACK TO ME IN
TERMS OF A DOLLARS WORTH OF
BENEFITS WE THINK THAT PROVIDING
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FOR EVERYBODY DEFINES WHO
WE ARE.
AS CALIFORNIANS IT'S AMERICANS
AS A SOCIETY SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL THANKS.
THANK YOU X..
GOOD AFTERNOON MELANIE CUEVAS
WITH KING TUNNEL WATSON HEARD
MEN ON BEHALF OF IRVINE RANCH
WATER DISTRICT IN EAST VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT.
BOTH OPPOSED TO THE TAX IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX NINE WE'LL
LINE OUR COMMENTS WITH BOTH CM
YOU A AND WITH AQUA THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR IN THIRTY
MILLION ON BEHALF SANTA CLARITA
VALLEY WATER AGENCY MAKES A
WATER DISTRICT.
AND ALSO SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT WE TOO
ARE OPPOSED TO THE TAX AND
BELIEVE A VIABLE SOLUTION WOULD
BE THE TRUST WE WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR KEEPING THIS ITEM OPEN
FOR FURTHER DISCUSSIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR JONES ON
BEHALF OF THE FLOOR RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT AND THE
ELK GROVE WAER DISTRICT.
WE LINE OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE
MADE BY AUCKLAND SEE ANYWAY.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO A STATEWIDE
TAX ON WATER AND WE SUPPORT SB
SIX SIX NINE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
X..
KAREN MEMBERS JONATHAN NELSON ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER AS WELL AS THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION.
CLEAN WATER ACTION SELF HELP IN
THE PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
LEAGUE AND THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
WE ARE IN A VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS.
ROSAL.
HOW WE WON OUT ADDITIONALLY
RECOGNIZE THE LEADERSHIP OF BOTH
SENATOR MINING AS WELL AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AS WELL AS THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
STATE WATER BOARD?
WE WANT TO PULL OUT --
QUICKLY A COUPLE POINTS ABOUT
WHAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE LOOKING.
FOR AND ANY PROPOSED SOLUTION
THAT ARE ENCOURAGINGLY REFLECTED
IN THIS PROPOSED SOLUTION WHICH
IS WHY WE ARE SO SUPPORTIVE.
FIRST OF ALL THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FIND
WOULD BE A SOLUTION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
URBAN ROLL THOSE THAT ARE SERVED
BY A PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM AND
THOSE THAT AREN'T LIKE DOMESTIC
WELL OWNERS ARSENIC.
NITRATE LEAD YOU NAME IT.
NO CALIFORNIANS TO GET LEFT OUT
THE WAY THAT SOME OTHER
COMPETING PROPOSALS SUPPORT.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL MEETS THAT
CRITERIA SECOND THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FIND
WOULD PROVIDE TRULY ONGOING
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT OUR BUDGET
CYCLE LOOKS LIKE AND WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN A RECESSION HITS.
FUNDING FOR ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER SHOULD BE RECESS
AND PROOF IT SHOULD BE A
PRIVILEGE.
THAT IS A AT RISK FOR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS WHEN
TIMES GET BAD. THIRTEEN LAST IF
ENACTED WILL DRINKING WATER FIND
COULD IMMEDIATELY BEGAN TO BE
IMPLEMENTED.
IT'S EASY TO LOSE THAT SENSE OF
HUMAN CRISIS HERE.
ARE COMMUNITIES HAVE TOXIC WATER
RIGHT NOW AND THEY'VE HAD IT FOR
YEARS IT IS PROPOSAL WERE
ENACTED INTO LAW TOMORROW IT
WOULD BE A COMPREHENSIVE.
FIX IT COULD IMMEDIATELY BEGAN.
MAGICAL THINKING REQUIRED HERE
OPPONENTS COULD SAY WELL WE CAN
SOLVE IT SOME OTHER WAY THEN WHY
HAVEN'T WE FOR ALL THESE YEARS.
PROPOSALS THAT RELY SOLELY ON
THE IDEA OF GETTING A MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF GENERAL FUND FUNDING.
THOSE BILLS ARE NOTHING MORE
THAN HOLLOW WORDS ON A PAGE FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES.
WE ESTIMATE THAT WOULD TAKE OVER
THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
IN A TRUST.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK AT AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING A FEW
WEEKS AGO.
CAME UP WITH AN ESTIMATE OF FIVE
BILLION.
THAT'S NOT REALISTIC.
THIS PROPOSAL IS IT REALISTIC
IT'S REAL AND OUR COMMUNITIES
DON'T HAVE TIME TO WAIT NOR
DESERVE TO WAIT FOR PLATITUDES
ARE FALSE HOLLOW PROMISES.
THAT WE APPLIED THE GOVERNOR FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP AND URGE SUPPORT
FOR THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FIND THANK YOU.
NEXT.
THANK YOU TURN SENATORS GENESIS
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE TIDEWATER
DISTRICT WE JUST WANNA LINER
COMMENTS WITH THOSE MADE BY
AUCKLAND SEEM YOU I THINK YOU.
AFTERNOON MY CLAIBORNE ATTORNEY
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE --
IN SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO CREATE A SAFE
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FIND.
A COUPLE THINGS I WANT TO KNOW
JUST REALLY QUICKLY --
BASED ON COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE.
THE FIRST IS THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL RIGHT NOW INCLUDES --
AND LOW INCOME EGGS EXEMPTION ON
THE FEE.
SO THAT'S 2100% FEDERAL FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL SO --
THERE'S AN EXEMPTION IN THERE
RIGHT NOW --
THE SECOND ISSUE IS ON SB --
SIX SIX NINE WHILE WE'RE HAPPY
THAT --
THERE ARE MANY MANY
ORGANIZATIONS AND PEOPLE WANTING
TO WORK ON THIS.
THAT BILL WOULD ONLY ADDRESS
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS AND
LEAVES OUT THOSE WHO ARE NOT
SERVED BY COMMUNITY WATER
SYSTEMS THERE'S TWO MILLION
PRIVATE WELLS IN THIS STATE MANY
OF WHICH ARE CONTAMINATED.
WE REALLY DON'T WANT TO LEAVE
THOSE OUT AND WE WE CAN'T LEAVE
THOSE OUT THAT'S NOT THE PROMISE
OF THE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER.
AND FINALLY I I JUST WANTED TO
THURSDAY WATER BOARDS POINT
EARLIER TODAY THIS IS REALLY A
CORNERSTONE OF THE LARGER --
PROGRAM SO.
IT'S NOT INTENDED TO REPLACE AND
INDEED IT'S INTENDED TO SUPPORT
PRIORITIZE CONSOLIDATION
EXTENSION OF SERVICE.
SOURCE PROTECTION ALL OF THOSE
THINGS CONTINUE AND ARE
PRIORITIZED IN THESE FUNDS COULD
BE USED FOR THAT.
AND THEN ONLY AS A LAST RESORT
WHEN THE OTHER APPROACHES AREN'T
FEASIBLE WOULD THERE BE
TREATMENT AND SUPPORT FOR
OPERATIONS MAINTENANCE THAT
DOESN'T CHANGE.
ANYWAY ONE OF THE STATE AGAIN MY
STRONG SUPPORT AND OUR STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT.
SO THOSE ARE GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY ME NUMBER OF BLANK
CAROL SINO MY NAME IS BLANKA
LOZANO BINGO THAT GO MANY OTHER
THAN IF I CALIFORNIA COME FROM
THE FROM THE COMMUNITY OF DELPHI
CALIFORNIA.
IT WILL BE ANOTHER THE
IS THAT PRO BONNIE IN THE MAIN
PHONE THOUGH THEY'VE THE MIDDLE.
OKAY THE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA
IS PROPOSING A FUN.
BUT I GET THOUGH THOSE IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK I'M ALSO WAS
A LOVELY.
THAT EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA
WILL BE HAVING AFFORDABLE WATER.
IT ALSO DOES ANYMORE SAMPLE YET
IT PROPOSES OF IT WILL BE.
FOR THE GOVERNOR.
THAT'S WHAT IS GOOD CHANNELS AND
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING THIS
GARBAGE.
AND GOD BLESS YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PAUL GARCIA AND I AM
FROM THE COMMUNITY OF DELL HI
CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO ELECTED OFFICIAL FOR
THE WATER DISTRICT THERE AND DEL
HIGH CALIFORNIA --
I AM HERE ALSO BECAUSE THERE WAS
TOO CONTAMINATED.
WELLS THERE AND HERE ALSO TO
SUPPORT OUR THE GOVERNOR AND IN
REGARDS TO THE SPECIAL FUND.
DOES SUPPORT A FORCIBLE AND SAFE
WATER AND THE WHOLE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND AND AND THE
COMMUNITIES THERE ARE MOSTLY
IMPACTED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
X..
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SOCIAL HER
NAME WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FUND WITH AN
ONGOING SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
SOURCE I THINK WE ALL BENEFIT
FROM.
THIS RELATIVELY SMALL INVESTMENT
AND PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE WELL
BEING OF FAMILIES ACROSS THE
STATE THERE ARE MILLION PEOPLE
WITHOUT CLEAN WATER THAT IS AN
ABSOLUTE.
FAILURE AND WE NEED TO FIX IT
RIGHT NOW THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MELISSA ROMERO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
THE WATER IS A HUMAN RIGHT AND
WE NEED TO DELIVER ON THAT
PROMISE WITH THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FIND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
X..
HELLO THANK YOU AYE FIRST ALSO
COMICAL WATER DISTRICT.
I JUST HERE --
TO ADD SUPPORT --
TO OR ECHO THE COMMENTS OF AQUA
AND MY COLLEAGUES HERE --
WE ARE AGAINST A REGRESSIVE TAX
AND IN SUPPORT OF SIX SIX NINE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR JOHN CLAM
BAFFLED ALAMEDA COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT ALSO HEAR ECHOING THE
COMMENTS OF OCCUPANCY --
JUDY REJECT THE TAX PORTION OF
THE GOVERNOR SAID DRINKING WATER
RIPPLES THANK YOU [inaudible]
NECKS.
A LITTLE TALLER.
ENTER MEMBERS PNEUMATIC ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF FOR HIS
FELLOW.
IN OPPOSITION TO THE WATER TAX
BUT IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX
NINE I'D LIKE TO ASSOCIATE A
MAJORITY OF MY COMMENTS WITH
WALKWAY AND SEE ANYWAY.
BUT WHAT I LIKE TO ADD JUST ONE
MORE POINT WE HAVE ESTIMATED ARE
ONGOING COSTS ALONE. TO
ADMINISTER THIS NEW TAX THOUSAND
DOLLARS. EIGHTY TO NINETY
THOUSAND OF THAT WE WOULD HAVE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I CAN AFTER MISTER MEMBER SORRY
STEVE WAS APPEARING HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF THE MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY.
WHO HAS NOTICED THE GAP IN THE
DATA ON THIS ANDIS WILLING TO
PUT THEIR MONEY WHERE THEIR
MOUTH THIS STATE TOOK NOTE THAT%
WE HAVE EXISTING PROJECTS IN THE
PIPELINE?
AND THE COMMITTEE RIGHT UP DID
AN AWESOME JOB OF SUMMARIZING
THOSE AND LAYING THEM OUT AND
MODOC NOTICED THAT NOBODY IS
ASSESSING THE IMPACT OF THESE
PROJECTS ARE IN THE PIPELINE
RIGHT NOW WHAT IMPACT THAT WILL
HAVE ON THIS PROBLEM GOING
FORWARD.
BECAUSE THAT'S A CRITICAL PIECE
OF KNOWING THE SCOPE OF THIS
PROBLEM SO THEY VOTED ON MONDAY
TO PUT UP MONEY TO FUND THAT
STUDY AS A SUPPLEMENTAL STUDY TO
THE COOLEST CITY THAT YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD ABOUT.
AND WE HOPE WE SHOW THAT THIS IS
A DISTRICT THAT CARES VERY MUCH
ABOUT THE PROBLEM IS COMMITTED
TO A SOLUTION.
IS WILLING TO PUT THEIR MONEY
OUT BUT IT'S JUST AS VIGOROUSLY
OPPOSED TO THE MECHANISM OF
ATTACKS ON INDIVIDUAL WATER
USERS.
WHEN EXAMINED LACKS A POLICY
BASIS THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRA CASKEY AND
MEMBERS TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENT OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FARMERS FROM
ALL THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND WHAT TO EXPRESS OUR VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ITEM ON THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FIND
APPRECIATE HIS LEADERSHIP THAT
OF HIS ADMINISTRATION AND OF
COURSE --
OUR CHAMPION CENTER MINING AS
WELL THANK YOU.
NECKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON BURKE L. I. L. ON
BEHALF OF EL DORADO YOUR
VACATION DISTRICT THIS OUR WATER
AGENCY ROLLED ON WATER.
DISTRICT AND WILL NOT BOTHER
WATER DISTRICT --
THE DISTRICTS WILL LIKE TO
ONLINE --
COMMENTS TO THOSE OF OUR CLIENTS
SEE ANYWAY THANK YOU.
MAX.
I E. IMPRESARIO THEA CAMERAS A
WATER DISTRICT IN VENTURA COUNTY --
MOST THEIR COMMENTS ON THE LINE
WITH US BUT JUST DO A COUPLE
THINGS I'D LIKE TO ADD --
TALK BUT THERE ISN'T WE DON'T
HAVE THE UPDATED.
NEEDS ASSESSMENT FROM THE STATE
YET.
YOU KNOW AND WHAT WHETHER IT'S
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR
AGENCIES ARE THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE OR HOWEVER MANY
THOUSANDS OF WELLS.
WE CAN ALL AGREE IT'S A PROBLEM.
MAYBE ONE OF THE ONLY THINGS WE
CAN AGREE ON RIGHT NOW BUT WE
AGREE ON THAT --
BUT IT'S ALSO A LIMITED PROBLEM
WITH THE DISCRETE PROBLEM SET
WITH SOME WITH DOABLE SOLUTIONS.
AND CAMERA CITIZEN THINK THAT
ATTACKS ON WATER INDEFINITE TAX
ON WATER IS NECESSARY --
IN PART BECAUSE IT LENDS ITSELF
TO INDEFINITELY PROPPING UP
FAILED SYSTEMS. ONE OF THE%
ADVANTAGES OF SB SIX SIX NINE
THE CABBIE YOU'RE A BILL IN THE
TRUST.
THE TRUST AIMS TO THE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE UNDERLYING
PROBLEMS --
THAT STRUGGLING WATER SYSTEMS
ARE FACING AND HELP THEM ACHIEVE
SELF SUSTAINABILITY WITHIN THAT
THE IN THE BILL THERE'S A TEN
YEAR FUNDING CAP THAT'S BUILT IN.
TO HELP INCENTIVIZE. TO HELP
INCENTIVIZE THE GUY THE QUICKEN
LOOKED IMPLEMENTATION OF
RESOLUTIONS --
TO THE PROBLEM.
YES SIX SIX NINE IS AN
OPTIMISTIC BILL AND WE JUST
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
EMBRACE SET UP THE MUSEUM.
AND ADOPT A FUNDING STRATEGY
THIS FOCUSED ON RESOLUTIONS.
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
GABRIEL SMITH AND I'M HERE --
TO REPRESENT THE CAL MUTUALS AND
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS ALLIANCE
WE SUPPORT EFFORTS TO HELP
CHRONICALLY FAILING WATER
SYSTEMS AND PRO VOTING SAFE
DRINKING WATER IN CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DOES NOT INCLUDE PROVISIONS THAT
WILL STEM THE TIDE OF NON
COMPLIANCE AS NEW DRINKING WATER
STANDARDS ARE ADOPTED WE HOPE
THAT THE FUND WILL INCLUDE
ELIGIBILITY FOR GRANTS.
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
SERVING TEN THOUSAND PERSONS ARE-MORE.
ENCOURAGE ECONOMIES OF SCALE
THROUGH CONSOLIDATION --
THIS IS CURRENTLY NOT AVAILABLE
ONE N. PROP SIXTY NINE WE ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST PROVISIONS
THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE STATE
WATER BOARD TO PLAN FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF GRANTS AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
AS NEW STANDARDS ARE ADOPTED.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE TRUST FUND
WITH SEED FUNDING FROM THE
BUDGET SURPLUS WILL ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCORPORATE
FINDINGS OF THE STATE WATER
BOARDS ON GOING NEEDS ASSESSMENT --
AND WE BELIEVE THAT WOULD BE
COMPLETED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
AND TWENTY ONE YEAR TO ASSESS A
TAX NOW MAY MEAN MISSING THE
MARK AND HAVING TO REVISIT THIS
IN TWO YEARS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE CHAIRS AND
A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S ALESANA HOW TO ANIMATE
PROGRAM OFFICER WITH THE WATER
FOUNDATION.
WE WANT TO COMMEND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR COURAGE
IN TAKING ON SUCH AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE I WITH THE TRAILER BILL
AND WE ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
THE PROGRESS THE STATE WATER
BOARD IS MADE TOWARDS.
SECURING THE HUMAN RIGHTS WATER --
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS THEY'VE
HAD THE DIVISION OF DRINKING
WATER.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE NEED FOR
A SECURE LONG TERM SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING SOURCE FOR THE IMPORTANT
WORK THAT THE WATER BOARD IS
DOING.
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THE
FACT THAT THIS FIN IS ABLE TO
ASSIST COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE NOT JUST IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
SOME MY COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY
HAVE MENTIONED --
THE LEAD CONTAMINATION PROBLEM
IN CALIFORNIA AND I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE ORGANIZATION
CALPERS.
PUT OUT A REPORT TODAY THAT
SOUNDS THAT.
BASED ON WATER BOARD DATA THAT
HIGHLIGHTED THAT THERE CURRENTLY
HAVE LEAD CONTAMINATION AS A
FINDING STATE IN.
THE TRAILER BILL THERE'S NO SAFE
LEVEL OF LEAD ACCORDING TO
HEALTH EXPERTS AB SO ONE
HIGHLIGHT THAT CALIFORNIA'S
GETTING AC PLUS RIGHT NOW
ACCORDING TO CALPERS --
AND LEAD CONTAMINATION STATE.
SO I WOULD JUST ONE HIGHLIGHT AS
WELL THAT NINETY FIVE SENSES A
RELATIVELY LOW PRICE TO PAY FOR
THE HUGE SOCIETAL IMPACT AND
SAFE DRINKING WATER CONTAMINANTS
INCLUDING LEAD.
SO WE'D LIKE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
ADDS DESCRIBES THEM AS THE
KEYSTONE HERE --
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
DEAL WITH SOME PARTNERSHIP THANK
YOU.
HI BRIAN --
JACKING WITH THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY --
RW A IS A JOINT POWERS
ASSOCIATION OF TWENTY ONE
SACRAMENTO AREA WATER SUPPLIERS
THAT PROVIDE DRINKING WATER TO
TWO MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO AREA.
WANT TO START WITH SOME
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS FOR THE CHAIR
FOR HIS WORK ON THIS ISSUE OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
HELPING AS ADDRESS SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT CENTER STERN IS
RAISING ABOUT WHAT IS THE SCOPE.
I AT LEAST HELPING US GET OUR
HANDS AROUND THAT WANT.
TO REALLY ACKNOWLEDGE CENTER
MINING FOR FORCING CONVERSATION
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE.
IN THE GOOD NEWS IS ALL OF THAT
HARD WORK HAS.
GOTTEN US TO PLACE WHERE WE'RE
REALLY HAVING.
TWO HOW DO WE PAY FOR THIS --
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
WATER BOARD AND THEN NEW CHAIR --
FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK.
THE JURY OF THE PLACE THAT WE'RE
COMING FROM ON THIS ISSUE IS OUR
MISSION STATEMENT IS TO RELY WE
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY AFFORDABLE
WATER.
ESSENTIALLY THE COMPONENTS OF
THE HUMAN RIGHTS WATER WE SEE A
LOT OF ALIGNMENT THERE ON WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE ONE OF
OUR BIG CONCERNS WITH THE WATER
TAX IS THAT.
AS YOU'VE HEARD THOSE COSTS ARE
GONNA GET PASSED ON TO OUR RATE
PAYERS GONNA HURT OUR ABILITY.
TO ACHIEVE THE AFFORDABILITY
COMPONENT POTENTIALLY SOME OF
THE ACCESS COMPONENTS OF THE
HUMAN RIGHTS WATER.
WE THINK THAT THE TRUST DOESN'T
HAVE THOSE DOWN FALLS BUT WE
WANT TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW WE CAN GET TO THE
FUNDING SOLUTION THAT THAT SHE'S
ALL OF IT.
THE GETS US TO THE PLACE WHERE
WE DO.
SAFE AFFORDABLE RELIABLE WATER
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU NEXT.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ALI HOW
THAT'LL RUN WITH THE WHEN A MAN
GROUP HERE ON BEHALF OF NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IN CREATING THIS THE
STATE OF WILL SOURCE OF FUNDING
TO PROVIDE CLEAN WATER TO EVERY
CALIFORNIAN.
NEXT AND HAS BEEN PART OF THIS
LARGER COALITION THAT HAS BEEN
WORKING IN THE PAST AND CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH SENATOR MINING AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR BREED YOUR
CONTINUED --
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE --
I WANNA LAND MY COMMENTS ON MY
HUSBAND SAID I WANNA LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH JONATHAN NELSON
FROM THE COMMENDED WATERS AND I
THINK HE PUT IT.
HIGHLIGHTED SOME REALLY GREAT
POINTS AND I THINK.
THIS YEAR IS OUR YEAR AND WE
REALLY WANT TO GET SOMETHING
DONE THANK YOU [inaudible]
NECKS.
EMILY ROSENBERGER WITH US YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF OUR
MEMBERS THAT LIVE IN THE FIRST
AND WORST MOST POLLUTED AREAS SO
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED AFTER
SEVERAL YEARS TO SEE SOMETHING.
COMING TO FRUITION AND WE LEARN
ARE COMMON FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
X..
BOARD CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME'S GREG BANDA SONORA
QUEST SACRAMENTO SUBURBAN WATER
DISTRICT AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
ALIGN ARGUES WITH AQUA THE CMU A
AND THE REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY.
AND WE'D ALSO LIKE TO SUPPORT
THE THE TRUST THAT --
IN SB -- SIX
SIX NINE ALSO ONE CARRY OUT TO
THAT TRUST IS THERE'S NO TENURE
CAP ON THAT'S WE THINK THERE'D
BE A REALLY GOOD FUNDING SOURCE
FOR THAT PROJECT THANK YOU SO
MUCH [inaudible]
NEXT.
AFTERNOON RENDON ROSSI WITH THE
CAL SIX ASSOCIATION WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOS UNLESS
AMENDED AND WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS FOR THOSE OF A
KOREAN SEEM YOU A THANK YOU
[inaudible]
LAST.
THAT MEANS TO BE QUICK.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE GRAY
LOUIS BROWN ON THE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL IN
CALIFORNIA FOR FREE ASSOCIATION.
IN SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TODAY I WANT TO THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO WANT TO
THANK CENTER MINING --
FOR HIS CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT.
THAT THERE HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANT
WORK DONE IN THIS AND THE BLUE
SKY -- STUDY
HAS BEEN REFERRED TO A COUPLE
TIMES IT WAS REALLY ONE OF THE
FIRST COMPREHENSIVE STUDIES TO
TRY TO GET BEYOND --
WHAT IS CURRENTLY REGULATED
TODAY AND IT IS REALLY KIND OF A
A GOOD PICTURE OF WHAT THAT
SCOPE IS?
HOW THE NUMBER CAME AROUND TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR WAS AN IDEA THAT
YOU CAN'T?
FIX ALL OF THIS AT ONE POINT BUT
IF THAT IF YOU CAME AT IT WITH
SOMETHING THAT WAS CONSISTENTLY
AROUND THE HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR RANGE THAT OVER A PERIOD
OF TIME.
COMBINED WITH OTHER EFFORTS LIKE
CONSOLIDATION YOU COULD REALLY
GET YOUR HANDS AROUND THIS.
THE HARDER STUDY FROM UC DAVIS
WAS REALLY KIND OF THE PREMISE
OF LOOKING AT THE THAT BALANCE
OF THAT SEVENTY THIRTY SPLIT ON
NITRATE CONTAMINATION AND OTHER
NATURAL CONTAMINANTS AND OTHER.
POLLUTANTS THAT YOU FIND IN
WATER SYSTEMS AND SO THERE'S A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT SOURCES.
CREDIBLE SOURCES --
THAT CAME TOGETHER TO KIND OF
PUT THIS COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION
TOGETHER AND IF YOU GET INTO THE
THE WEEDS OF OF THAT TRAILER
BILL.
THERE ARE OTHER SECURITY
MECHANISMS THERE'S AN ANNUAL
NEEDS ASSESSMENT BY STAKEHOLDERS
THAT WOULD BE A BROUGHT TOGETHER
BY THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD THERE'S A CAP.
ON THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF THE FUN
THE COULD BE HELD AT ANY ONE
TIME -- SO
TO TO MAKE SURE THAT IT NEVER
GOT TOO FAR OUT OF CONTROL I
MEAN THIS IS A REALLY WELL
THOUGHT OUT COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION THAT ULTIMATELY WILL
BENEFIT ALL CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE
THERE ARE PLENTY OF URBAN AREAS
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT HAVE ISSUES WITH SAFE
DRINKING WATER THAT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THIS AS WELL IT'S
THE RURAL AREAS THAT ARE GETTING
THE ATTENTION.
TODAY.
AND WHAT'S WRONG WITH THE RURAL
AREAS OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
GET IN A LITTLE EXTRA ATTENTION
TODAY FOR THE INABILITY TO KEEP
UP.
WITH SOME OF THE MOST BASIC
NEEDS THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE
SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY IN ADDRESSING THIS LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
AND THEREWE HAVE IT.
OKAY CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING.
PORTION OF THIS.
DOES ANYBODY FEEL COMPELLED TO
SAY ANYTHING ELSE.
ON THIS ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY NINE
AT THIS TIME IT'S OUR INTENT TO
HOLD MATTER OPEN.
I ANTICIPATE CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS THROUGH THE AGENCIES
IN.
HERE IN LEGISLATURE IN IN THE
HALLS SO.
I'D LIKE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I'M.
WE'LL.
CLOSE THIS SAID THE MATTER ON
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY NINE AND GO
BACK TO SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WERE BEFORE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME [inaudible]
HI.
SO WE ARE GOING TO OPEN THE ROLE
AND CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN THIS IS
INCREASE DRINKING WATER
LABORATORY SERVICES PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES STERN HI.
HI WILL KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN
FOR THE OTHER ABSENT MEMBERS AND
LET'S OPEN UP ISSUE NUMBER
SIXTEEN THIS IS A MINISTRY OF
HEARING OFFICERS PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS JONES STERN.
MOVING THROUGH THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES BOARD.
AGENDA WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN DRINKING WATER SYSTEM
SANITATION SURVEY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
OWNS STERN [inaudible]
HI.
SO WE'RE GONNA CLOSE THAT
MATTERED THAT MATTERS APPROVED
FOUR ZERO AND MOVE ON TO MICHAEL
PLASTICS AND AND DRINKING WATER
TESTING THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS JONES STERN BY.
CLOSE THAT MATTER OFF THAT'S
FOUR ZERO IT PASSES.
I'M.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN NON
POSSIBLE RE USE WELL WATER
SYSTEMS --
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
DOWNS STERN.
IT MATTERS A PROOF.
FOUR ZERO ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
THE SEWER SERVICE PROVISIONS FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES I'M
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND STERN.
IT MATTERS APPROVED FOUR ZERO
WILL CLOSE THE MATTER.
ISSUE IN NUMBER TWENTY ONE WITH
STATE WATER RESOURCES BOARD THIS
IS THE STATE ADMINISTERS
ADMINISTRATORS CONSOLIDATION
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
OWNS STERN.
THAT MATTERS APPROVED.
FOR ZERO IN ISSUE NUMBER --
TWENTY THREE THE ORPHAN SITE
CLEANUP AND GRANTS FOR STATE
WATER RESOURCE POOR PLEASE CALL
THE UP TO MEMBERS AND MINING.
I HI -- WITH
THAT MATTER SPRUE FOUR ZERO WILL
CLOSE THAT MATTER [inaudible]
I'M.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR THE
TURLOCK NORTH VALLEY ANIMAL
LABORATORY HEALTH LABORATORY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
OWNS MCGUIRE [inaudible]
DURING.
I THAT MATTERS APPROVED --
FOUR ZERO HUNT ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX THE CITRUS PEST AND
DISEASE PREVENTION PROGRAM
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HANDS MCGUIRE.
TURN BY THAT MEASURE SPRUE FOUR
ZERO AND ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
TO PUT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
OWNS MCGUIRE.
THAT MADISON PRUE.
FOUR ZERO GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTEEN I NUMBER FIFTEEN THIS IS
THE I INCREASE WATER LABORATORY
SERVICES PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
OWNS.
WE THAT MATTERS APPROVED FOUR
ZERO WILL CLOSE THE MATTER.
I DIDN'T DO THAT AND THEN ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING OFFICERS
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THAT MATTERS APPROVED FOUR ZERO
WE WILL CLOSE THE POT THE TO
ROLL ALL RIGHT.
THAT BEFORE SUBCOMMITTEE TO ONE
RESOURCES [inaudible]
ENERGY.
NATURAL RESOURCES ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION WE ARE NOW
ADJOURNED